WE'RE GONNA START OR- JOINT-
INFORMATIONAL HEARING SET
TRANSPORTATION SITS HERE WITH
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
SURE JACKSON IS WITH ME TODAY.
AND SHOULD WE WILL JOINTLY RUN
THESE HEARINGS. SO GOOD
AFTERNOON. THE COMMITTEE IS
HOLDING A HEARING TODAY ON.
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON MORE
MOBILITY OPTIONS MORE DATA
TRANSPORTATION PRIVACY ISSUES
INSURED MOBILITY DATA USE. AND
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK- SIR
JACKSON. AS WELL AS THEIR
COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUT WITH
TRANSPORTATION AND JUDICIARY ON
INSURANCE. WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK US SENATE GOVERNMENT
FINANCE COMMITTEE- SAM ACQUIRE
WHO'S HERE. AND. WE TO US WE
HAVE. OKAY. WE WANTED TO THANK
ALSO- ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
WHO IS AUTHORED LEGISLATION ON
SURE MOBILITY DURING THIS THE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION SO WE WILL.
HEAR FROM HER. AS WE GO THROUGH
THE HEARING. AND I WANTED IS
ALSO THANK HER FOR TAKING ON
THIS VERY COMPLEX SUBJECT
PROMPTING ALL OF US TO TAKE A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE DIVE.
THROUGHOUT THE DAY TO DAY AND-
THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING AND
WE LOOK FORWARD FROM HEARING
AND WORKING WITH HER ON OF
LEGISLATION. NOW FINALLY I WANT
TO THANK ALL OUR STAFF THAT
WORKED ON THIS HEARING WE'VE WE
WORK VERY HARD TO PREPARE
OURSELVES FOR THE SHARING. AND
WE'D LIKE TO THANK EVERYBODY.
NOW TODAY'S HEARING. IS
ACTUALLY THE SECOND OF TWO
JOINT INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS ON
THE TOP WITH THEM SURE MOBILITY
THE INNOVATIVE- SHARED USE OF
VEHICLE BICYCLE OTHER MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION INCLUDING RIDE
HAILING AND- THE RECENT
PHENOMENA OF ELECTRIC SCOOTERS
WE HAD OUR FIRST HEARING. BACK
IN NOVEMBER BY THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTS AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE IN THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE THAT
HEARING EXPLORED WHAT STATE
RIGHT REGULATION. MAY BE
APPROPRIATE FOR SURE MOBILITY
AND WE'RE DISCRETION SHOULD BE
LEFT TO LOCAL DISCRETION. AT
TODAY'S HEARING. ZEROS IN ON A
PARTICULAR ASPECT OF SURE
MOBILITY. THE GOVERNOR OF DATA
GENERATED THROUGH DEPLOYMENT OF
THE USE OF THE OF THE AND THE
USE OF SHARE MOBILITY DEVICES.
SURE MOBILITY DEVICES ARE
TRANSFORMING URBAN
TRANSPORTATION. WHERE THEY ARE
AVAILABLE- RIGHTS DELIVERIES IN
SHORT TERM RENTALS OF BIKES
CARS SCOOTERS SMOKE. CAN BE
USED NOW SECURED WITH THE TOP%
OF THE PHONE AND LIKE OTHER
INNOVATIONS THE- SURE
MOBILITIES MAY PROVIDE- VARIOUS
BENEFITS CONVENIENCE CONNECTING
RIDERS TO TRANSIT. AND
REPLACING CAR TRIPS WITH
SCOOTER BY CRISIS HOWEVER.
THESE BENEFITS ARE NOT A GIVEN
FOR EXAMPLE STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT- TENDENCIES CONTRIBUTE TO
CONGESTION AND TRIED TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP- HAS. DROPPED IS
ACTUALLY- GOING DOWN DR
SCOOTERS CAN BLOCK SIDEWALKS OR
GET THROWN INTO CREEKS AND
PONDS- WHICH IS WHAT MY WIFE
COMPLAINS ABOUT WHEN WE DO OUR
CREEK CLEANUP SO COME SOMEBODY
THESE ARE IN. THE CREEK. SO IT
IS A IT IS- AN ISSUE BOTH
REQUIRE OVERSIGHT. TO HEAR THAT
ACCESS IS DISTRIBUTED
ADEQUATELY EQUITY TO IT. NOW TO
ENSURE MOBILITY SERVICES WORK
IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST LOCAL
AUTHORITIES THAT MANAGE THE
PUBLIC RIGHT AWAY THE DATA. SO
DO THE ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS WHO
CREEK AND THE INDEPENDENT
RIGOROUS KNOWLEDGE- NEEDED TO
INFORM- GOOD POLICYMAKERS. IN
SP ONE WE FOR EXAMPLE PUT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN TO. A. R. D.
FUND FOR ACADEMIC RESEARCH ON
TRANSPORTATION. THE GOOD NEWS
IS THAT THE SURE MOBILITY
SERVICES GENERATE HUGE AMOUNTS
OF DATA. MOST IMPORTANTLY ON
WHERE THE VEHICLES ARE THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION NOW COLLECTS
SIGNIFICANT TNC TRIPPED OUT AND
LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO POLLUTE
THE REQUIRE REQUIRE SHARED
SCOOTER INSURED BIKE OPERATORS
TO PROVIDE THEM WITH DATA. SUCH
AS THE LOCATION OF AVAILABLE
DEVICES AND THE PAPS UPON WHICH
THE DEVICES ARE BEING WRITTEN.
HOWEVER SURE IN THE STATUS WITH
LOCAL AUTHORITIES ARE BEYOND
ALSO WITH RESIST SOME KIND OF
ALARM. THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
THAT. AND WAS USING THAT THE
MOVEMENTS OF SPECIFIC
INDIVIDUALS COULD BE DEDUCED
BREACHING- WRITERS RIGHT TO
PRIVACY. TO MITIGATE THE
PRIVACY RESTORE IS BEEN CALLS
TO LIMIT THE TRIPPED OUT OF
LOCAL AUTHORITIES MAY REQUIRE.
TO DEAL FOR TO BE DO YOU HAVE
THE DATA FIGHT AN AGGREGATED
TRIPPED OUT OF. IN RESPONSE
SOME AUTHORITIES AND ACCURACY
OF EXPRESSED CONCERN. THAT THIS
LIMIT ON DATA SHARING WOULD
SEVERELY LIMIT. AFFECTED
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
MANAGEMENT RESEARCH. SO DURING
TODAY'S HEARING. WERE FIRST
GOING TO EXPLORE WHAT DATA ARE
NEEDED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
OTHER GOVERNMENT ENTITIES AND
ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS TO FULFILL
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES AND
WRIST TO IT AND INDIVIDUAL
PRIVACY THAT COMES WITH
GENERATING ENSURING THE DATA.
THEN WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO A
DISCUSSION OF BEST PRACTICES
FOR PROTECTING THE PRIVACY OF
INDIVIDUALS USING SURE MOBILITY
DEVICES. NOW TRANSPORTATION-
FORTUNATELY IS EVOLVING RAPIDLY.
IN THE FUTURE IT MAY BE
TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE FOR
CITIES TO ACTIVELY MANAGE
TRAFFIC BY MONITORING THE
MOVEMENT OF THOMAS VEHICLES AND
DIGITALLY COMMUNICATING
STOPLIGHTS AND ROAD CLOSURE
INFORMATION RIGHT BACK TO
VEHICLES. OR THE FUTURE COULD
LOOK VERY DIFFERENT ULTIMATELY
THIS HEARING. SHOULD ELIMINATE
ILLUMINATE HOUSE STATE WIDE
GUARD RAILS CAN PROTECT
CONSUMER PRIVACY. WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME ENSURE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS CONTINUES TO WORK AND
WORK BETTER FOR THE PUBLIC
THANK YOU AND I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO CENTER JACKSON A SHE SHE HAS
SOME OPENING REMARKS SENATOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MISTER
CHAIR FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS IMPORTANT. ISSUE AND
HOLDING THIS INTRODUCTORY-
INFORMATIONAL HEARING- PEOPLE
ASK WHAT IS PRIVACY HAVE TO DO
WITH RIDE SHARING. AND THE FACT
OF THE MATTER IS IT IS A LOT TO
DO WITH IT- BECAUSE WE ARE
COLLECTING DATA. WE ARE
COLLECTING ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF
DATA AND PEOPLE WHO RIDE THESE.
VEHICLES IN ADONIS KNOW THAT
THEIR INFORMATION IS BEING
ACCUMULATED AND ONE COULD SAY
THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY BEING
SURVEILLED. BECAUSE THAT IS IN
FACT PART OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE IS THAT- AT THE AS MORE
DATA IS COLLECTED AS
INFORMATION IS COLLECTED EVERY
FIVE SECONDS OF A RIDE- THE
USER ALL THAT. EQUIPMENT HAS
NOT BEEN NOTIFIED NOT BEEN
REQUESTED TO PROVE TO CONSENT
TO THAT INFORMATION BEING MADE
AVAILABLE AND FRANKLY HAS NO
KNOWLEDGE OF MOST COMES. AS WE
LOOK AT TECHNOLOGY AND CLEARLY
THERE ARE EXCITING THINGS GOING
ON I MEAN USING ELECTRIC BIKES
AND SCOOTERS WHICH WE KNOW OF
EXPLODED IN POPULARITY AND
REVOLUTIONIZED AND WE'RE NOT
SURE FOR BETTER FOR WORSE BUT
CERTAINLY ARE REVOLUTIONIZING.
OUR TRANSPORTATION LANDSCAPE
YET. AS THEY GET THE THESE APPS
BASED SERVICES CONTINUE TO
PROLIFERATE POLICY MAKERS THAT
TO US. HAVE TO EXAMINE THE
WEALTH OF DATA COLLECTED AND
HOW THE INFORMATION BEING YOU
WE DON'T KNOW THIS. IT COLLECTS
WE'VE KNOWING WHAT'S BEING
WITHIN SO. A IT'S MY HOPE AND I
BELIEVE GIVEN THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE GOING TO BE TESTIFYING
TODAY WE WILL BE ABLE TO
EXPLORE. THE RESPONSIBLE USE OF
SHARED MOBILITY. DATA AND WAYS
WE CAN AGAIN CONCERNS SAFEGUARD
CONSUMER PRIVACY THERE'S A
BALANCING HERE BETWEEN THE
TECHNOLOGY IN ITS ADVANCES AND
THE- POSSIBILITY AND THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THIS
INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE USED
TO GET PERSONAL INFORMATION
ABOUT US. WHETHER IT'S BY SOME
KIND OF I KEEP IT IN A FIRE
VOTE VERSUS OUR NAME BUT JUST
THINK OF YOUR SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER- BEING USED NOW TO
FOLLOW EVERYTHING YOU DO. NOW
WE MAY NOT YOU KNOW YOUR NAME
BUT WE DO KNOW WHAT THAT SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER IS DOING. AND
THE QUESTION IN OUR SOCIETY IS
AS A DEMOCRACY IS A STATE WHERE
THE RIGHT OF PRIVACY IS
CONSTITUTIONALLY EMBEDDED IN
OUR IN. THE CONSTITUTION STATE.
LAW LIBERTY PROP PRICE. THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA MADE IT
CLEAR THE PRIVACY IS A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT COMPONENT
SO. OF UP I'M HOPING WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
GROWING ACCUMULATION OF DATA
NACHOS BY PRIVATE COMPANIES BUT
BY GOVERNMENT ENTITIES- KNOWING
THAT THE MORE DATA THAT'S
COLLECTED AND DISSEMINATED CAN
AGAIN IDENTIFY PARTICULAR
CALIFORNIANS. MAKING OUR
PRIVACY RIGHTS MORE VULNERABLE
SO- THE GOAL I HOPE IS AS WE
HAVE THIS DISCUSSION WE CAN
ENSURE THAT ANY DATA SHARING
LAWS AND REGULATIONS. ENSURE
DATA IS AVAILABLE BUT THAT IT
DOES NOT PLACE PERSONAL
INFORMATION AT RISK THAT TO ME
IS THE FIRE WALL. WE CAN
COLLECTED WE CAN FIGURE OUT
BETTER ROAD PATTERNS WE CAN
FIGURE OUT TIME OF DAYS THE
CAPS MORE P. ARE INCLINED TO
USE THE VEHICLES. ARE MORE THE
PATTERN. BUT NOT SPECIFICALLY
ARE FIGHTING WOULD YOU FOR I DO
IN MORNING WE GET UP WHETHER
WE- STOP AT STARBUCKS OR SOME
CAR PLACE THE WAY WORK. HEAVEN
KNOWS THEY CAN IT TELL YOU WHAT
KIND OF DRINK OR MORE LIKELY TO
GET THE NOT THIS IS THE CASE
FOR MISSION TECHNOLOGY MAKE
AVAIL. SO WE KNOW STUDY STUDY
SHOWS AND I'M SURE CAMPUS WILL
ATTEST. AT LOCAL IN THERE IS A
CORRELATION. EVEN WHEN CERTAIN
IDENTIFIERS ARE STRICT HEY. WE
WILL WE ARE. SEEMINGLY JULY
INFORMATION AND BE RE IDENTIFY.
AND I KNOW EXACTLY LATER THE
SENATOR BUT THE HISTORY RIGHT
NOW BUT THAT'S BECAUSE I'M AT
HIM THAT'S BECAUSE I HAVE DE
FROM WHEN HE GOT IN HIS CAR AND
STOPPED TO GET HIS HIS COFFEE
THIS MORNING- WE DON'T KNOW
THAT THOSE THINGS ARE HAPPENING
AND WE NEED TO BE AWARE WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT IS. ARE
ANONYMOUS HELLO XIN INFORMATION
ARE NOT REPENT OF FIGHTING AND
CAN TO PUT PER AND I BELIEVE
WE'LL BE HEARING TESTIMONY THAT
IS SOPHISTICATED TECHNOLOGY
GETS THEY'RE ABLE TO RE
IDENTIFY EVEN THOUGH WE DE
IDENTIFY SO BOTTOM LINE IT'S
IMPERATIVE I BELIEVE THAT WE
FIND A WAY TO GET LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND OTHER ENTITIES
THE DATA THEY NEED TO CARRY OUT
IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY
PURPOSES THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR TODAY WITH OUT. FROM OUR
THIS AND THE SURVEILLANCE I IT
IT WE ARE ALL TOO QUICKLY
BECOMING WE NEED TO PUT OUR
FOOT DOWN TO PUT A STOP. TO
DISSEMINATION PURSE INFORMATION
IN OUR SOCIETY. WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT THE COLLECTION AND
DISSEMINATION OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION IS DONE IN A
THOUGHTFUL AND INTENTIONAL
MATTER. GIVING THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT OF PRIVACY
IT'S TO DO RESPECT THEM WITH
THAT- I WANT TO THANK THE- THE
CHAIR- AND LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
TESTIMONY TODAY. DAY OF THE
REQUIRED YOU HAVE SOME COMMENTS
AND THANK YOU FOR SHARING THE
LAST HEARING WE HAD ON THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIR MADAM CHAIR- GRATEFUL TO
BE WITH YOU IN PRE SHEET- BOTH
YOU AND YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE. AS THE CHAIR SAID I'LL
BE VERY BRIEF- THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE ALONG WITH THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. HELD A HEARING ON E.
SCOOTERS. LATE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. AT HEARING WAS
FOCUSED ON EXPLORING CHALLENGES
AT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN E.
SCOOTER COMPANIES HAVE AT BOTH
FACE. AS THEY TRIED TO BE ABLE
TO ENCOURAGE GOLDEN STATE
RESIDENTS TO NON AUTOMOBILE
TRANSPORTATION MODES WHILE.
ENSURING THE SAFETY IN EXCESS
ABILITY OF THOSE DEVICES. FOR
WRITERS AND PEDESTRIANS. IN
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS
WE'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITIES
LONG AS MANY MEMBERS OF THE-
FINANCE COMMITTEE WE ARE. ME
WITHIN WE NEED TO MEET WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM ALL SIDES
OF THE ISSUE TO BE A- BEST
DETERMINE. POTENTIAL NEXT STEPS
AND I KNOW THAT THIS HEARING
WILL ALSO HELP DETERMINE WHAT.
NEXT STEPS HE- CHAIR SURE WHAT.
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY WOMAN
FREE. AS WELL AS THE RUMOR. FOR
THEIR WORK IN THE SPACE DABO.
DECIDED TO. WORK WITH THE CAN.
I AM. REALLY GET THIS. AND WE
HAVE ONE OPPORTUNITY. TO GET
THIS VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WHO'S HERE TODAY
AND OF COURSE. TO LISTEN LIMóN
IS WELL. LISTEN RIGHT HERE. IN
THE COMING. UP CAN WE WERE LIST
COLDER DEVELOP. TOOLS OF THE
ROAD WILL. FOR EACH PRESENT ON
LOCKS CONTROL THESE DEVICES.
BUT BERNIE LOCAL. AND LOOK FOR
TO WORKING. WITH MISS JACKSON
MISTER BELL. OF COURSE AUTHOR.
ON JUNE YOU FOR A LOT. TO
TURMAN. YES THANK YOU A- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE A REMARKS
YOU'RE GOOD OKAY. OKAY ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WOULD LIKE MAKE
ANY ON THE SUB WILL PROCEED NOT
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVED
FIRST WE WILL PER AND OF SHARED
MOBILITY AND THE TEENS SEE DATA
USE- WE HAVE- OR WITH WAY OF
THE FIRST BATTLE COME FOR
PLEASE- DR- GIULIANO DIRECTOR
OF THE MET TRANS TRANSPORTATION
CENTER. UNIVERSE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- WITH HER ASSISTANT
SO LEADER RENTALS GENERAL
MANAGER OF ITALY DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION DOCTOR REGINA
SO- KALO C. E. O. A POPULOUS.
TARO'S C. C. VAHRAM. ED
APPALLED PRIVACY AND SECURITY
POLICIES UBER DOUG ITO-
DIRECTOR CONSUMER PROTECTION
ENFORCEMENT AT CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
CHECK UPS NO TECHNOLOGY CIVIL
LIBERTIES ATTORNEY AT ACLU
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. OKAY WE
ARE HERE IN DOCTOR'S GIULIANO
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR AND WELCOME.
YOU MAY. BACK IS GONNA BE TO
SOMEBODY NO MATTER WHAT I DO I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT DOCTOR CAN
YOU TELL US ABOUT THE VETERANS
FIRST BEFORE YES- I WANTED TO
INTRODUCE MYSELF I'M CHEN ON-
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- I AM THE DIRECTOR
OF THE MED TRANS TRANSPORTATION
CENTER- ALL THE DIRECTOR OF THE
PACIFIC SOUTHWEST REGION
UNIVERSITY TRANSPORTATION
CENTER- THAT CENTER RICH IS A
CONSORTIUM OF EIGHT
UNIVERSITIES WE ARE FUNDED THE
US DEPARTMENT INTERPRETATION
FIVE. CITY IN CALIFORNIA M. THE
I. BEING ON BEHALF OF THE FIVE
UNIVERSITIES TODAY. I HAVE TO
ACKER EMAIL HEY IS A- PH DIS IN
THE YEAR AT THE OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- HE IS THE ONE WHO
ACTUALLY MOTIVATED US TO BE
HERE TODAY- AND- HE DID 90% OF
ALL THE WORK I'M GOING TO SHOW.
SO I WANT TO MAKE CLEAR IS THAT
TO. THE SITTING OVER THERE IN
THIS PRESENTATION. DID YOU WANT
ANYTHING MORE- MISTER BELL.
OKAY THANK YOU- I UNDERSTAND I
HAVE EXACTLY FIVE MINUTES I
THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE ON THE
SCREEN. WHAT DO I DO. TRY THAT
ARE PERFECT THANK YOU I AM NOT
TECHNOLOGICALLY BRILLIANT OKAY-
I HAVE ONLY FIVE MINUTES AND SO
I'M GOING TO MAKE FOUR POINTS
THE FOUR POINTS I'M GOING TO
MAKE- IS NUMBER ONE THAT
ACADEMIC RESEARCH IS IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST IN THIS
PARTICULAR FIELD-
TRANSPORTATION RESEARCH DEPENDS
ON DECEMBER GET DATA. DATA COLD
JUNE IS NOT THE SAME AS DATA
SHARING AND PRIVACY CONSTRUED
CONCERNS CAN BE ADDRESSED- IN
THE RESEARCH WORLD- I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE ALSO FOR. GIVING
US THE OPPORTUNITY AT THE
UNIVERSITY TO ACTUALLY SPEAK AT
THIS HEARING- I DON'T KNOW THAT
THE UNIVERSITY RESEARCH VOICES
ALWAYS HURTS THIS IS A MUCH
APPRECIATED BY US- THIS FIRST
POINT IS THAT. MAKE RESEARCH IS
IN THE PUBLIC. AND WHAT IS
WORSE IS THAT. REESE IS WHAT
GIVES US BETTER ON OF HOW
THINGS WORK RIGHT- AND HOW
PEOPLE BEHAVE IT HELPS TO
INFORMED IT HELPS TO INFORM
PUBLICPOLICY- AND IT'S CREATES
A NEW TOOLS IT'S THE RESEARCH
THAT IS ACTUALLY CREATED ALL
NEW MODES OF TRANSPORTATION
THAT WERE. OF AND- THAT'S WHAT
MAKES IT- SO IMPORTANT I THINK
TO THE PUBLIC COMMUNITY- AND
THIS IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
STANDARDS OF RESEARCHERS SO
HIGH- SO WHEN WE DO RESEARCH IN
THE ACADEMY WE ARE LOOKING. AT
CAN. CAN THESE FINDINGS BE
REALIZABLE- WE ARE LOOKING FOR
COMPREHENSIVENESS AND RECUR- WE
ARE LOOKING FOR IN AN INSTANT
OBJECTIVITY. AN WE ARE LOOKING
FOR QUALITY THAT MEETS A PEER
REVIEW US CRITERIA- IN SO
REALLY WHAT WE ARE INTO HERE IS
ACADEMIC RESEARCH THAT CREATES
A PROCESS- THAT IS SURE IS
QUALITY OF RESEARCH. OKAY NEXT
ON THIS POINT- IS- TO MOVE A
LITTLE BIT INTO THE
TRANSPORTATION SPHERE MORE DO
MORE SPECIFICALLY AND THE
QUESTION OF BY VERY SKEPTICISM-
TRAVEL BEHAVIOR RESEARCH- WE
ARE IT WE'RE IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
SOME VERY AMBITIOUS GHG
REDUCTION TARGETS. OF THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS
ACTUALLY AN INCREASING SHARE OF
ALL OF OUR G. G. EMISSIONS
BECAUSE OTHER SECTORS ARE DO
BETTER AND- WE DON'T SEE HOW
WE'RE GOING SHE THOSE TARGETS
WITHOUT JUSTIN WILL BEHAVE. SO
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US. BE ABLE
TO UNDERSTAND RISE STRAP TO A
DECISION. FINALLY HAVE A THIS
IS JUST SOME EXAMPLES OF THE
KINDS OF QUESTIONS- THAT COME
UP TO YOU- AND THAT HAVE THEIR-
GROUNDING EVEN RESEARCH THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE AND JUST TO
PICK OUT ONE OF THESE- HOW
SHOULD HER. SB PRIORITIZE THAT
A QUESTION OF DEMAND RIGHT
THERE'S A DEMAND OUT THERE FOR
SCOOTERS THERE'S A DEMAND OUT
THERE FOR TEA AND SEES THERE'S
THE BAND OUT THERE FOR LOCAL
DELIVERY TRUCKS. AND
EVERYBODY'S COMPETING FOR YOUR
SPACE SO HOW DO YOU DECIDE IT
WILL YOU NEED. THIRTY NEED SOME
STANDING ALL THE MAN PATTERNS A
TO MAKE GOOD DECISIONS THE
SECOND POINT IS THAT. RESEARCH
DEPENDS ON DISAGGREGATED DATA-
THIS AGGREGATE DATA MEANS DATA-
USUALLY OF INDIVIDUALS AND WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A VERY LONG
HISTORY OF. TRAVEL BEHAVIOR
RESEARCH BASED ON INDIVIDUALS-
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
ACTUALLY COLLECTED CALL TRAVEL
DIARY INFORMATION SINCE THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES. AND THOSE
TYPES OF SURVEYS- ABS. VALUABLE
TO US IN BEING ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW PEOPLE- TRAVEL
AND WHAT THEIR MOTIVATIONS ARE-
IF WE HAVE INDIVIDUAL DATA CAN
ALWAYS AGGREGATED RIGHT SEC. WE
ALWAYS SCALE IT UP WE COULD
ALWAYS COME UP TO LEVELS WHERE
WE'RE BEYOND THAT INDIVIDUALS
INTO GROUPS OR POPULATIONS-
INDIVIDUAL OF BE A DATA
ACTUALLY ALLOWS FOR THE BROAD
THIS TYPE OF RESEARCH- SO IF WE
REALLY WANT TO UNDERSTAND HOW
WOMEN WITH CHILDREN UNDER THE
AGE. TO HAVE A PREFERENCE FOR
DRIVING AS OPPOSED TO TEAM
PUBLIC TRANSPORT WE CAN
ACTUALLY ZERO WITH THE PRINT.
PATIENTS OF THAT PARTICULAR
pEVER IS UP WHEN WE ARE MEANING
DATA WE NEVER KNOW BUT WE FIND
AND THOSE DISCOVERIES ARE ALL
ARE YOU FOR. THIS IS. SLIGHTLY
GIVES YOU JUST SOME QUICK POLLS
OF THE TYPE OF RE C<c.cyan> THAT OF</c>
YOU ARE DEALING WITH IN THAT IS
A REAL RELY ON THIS TYPE OF
DATA SO THE FOR QUESTION ON
THIS HERE IS DO DOCK WITH
MOBILE IN RIGHT FIELD SERVICE
COMPLIMENTS. FOR OR TO- TRAVEL
MODES WELL THE WAIT IS THAT IS
ACTUALLY TO LOOK AT INDIVIDUAL
TRAVEL BEHAVIOR. I IT'S NOT
THAT THESE QUESTIONS COULD NOT
NECESSARILY BE ADDRESSED BUT WE
CAN ADDRESS THEM A WHOLE LOT
BETTER- IF WE HAVE THE DETAILED
DATA. JUST TO GIVE YOU A COUPLE
OF HIS EXAMPLES OF THE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT WE HAVE FOUND WAS
INDIVIDUAL I'VE STATED YOU HAVE
SOME EXAMPLES ON THAT SLIDE-
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION FOR EXAMPLE OF
GENTRIFICATION AND TRANSIT RICH
NEIGHBORHOODS. AT AND THEN WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN PEOPLE MOVE AROUND
THESE NEIGHBORHOODS THE END UP
WITH PEOPLE WHO HAVE HIGHER
INCOMES THAT ARE LESS LIKELY
THE TRANSIT IN THERE FOR WE GET
REAL BENEFIT THAT PUBLIC. LAST
MONTH WELL LOOKING AT. TWO
HUNDRED UNDER IN. THAT MOST OF
THE TIME WE GET WITH REESE IS
IN VIEW MILES TRAVELED. POINT
THREE PM DATA CALL IS NOT THIS
THING IS DATA WE HAVE ALL OF
BIG IN RESEARCH OF HIGHLY
CONFIDENTIAL DATA- THAT IS USED
FOR THE PURPOSE OF RESEARCH SO
IT'S COLLECTED AND IT IS STORED.
IT IS NOT THE STANDARDS FOR HOW
IT IS ACCESSED ARE VERY STRICT
SO IT'S VERY POSSIBLE TO HAVE
EXTREMELY SENSITIVE DATA- CUT
THE CENTRAL DATA WAREHOUSE THAT
IS ESSENTIALLY UNDER LOCK AND
KEY- KEEP IT OUT OF THE CLOUD
KEEP IT OUT OF. HE SORT OF NEXT
TURNER. AN THOSE ARE DAYS THAT
WE HAVE OF BEING ABLE TO
PROTECT THIS DATA- AND THEN
ONCE YOU HAVE THAT THEN YOU CAN
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT WHO HAS
ACCESS FOR WHAT PURPOSE- A GOOD
EXAMPLE OR THE US CENSUS DATA
CENTERS THAT ARE ALL OVER THE
UNITED STATES THERE ONE AT UCLA
THERE'S ONE AT UC BERKELEY FOR
EXAMPLE. AND THAT GIVES. ACCESS
TO COME TO PRIVATE INFORMATION
THAT THE GOVERNMENT COLLECTS ON
INDIVIDUALS- YOU ONLY GET
ACCESS TO IT BY VIRTUE OF AN
APPLICATION.  REVIEW OF THAT
APPLICATION AND ACCEPTANCE OF
THAT APPLICATION THEN WHEN YOU
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT DATA YOU
CAN USE THE DATA BUT YOU CAN
TAKE IT ANYWHERE. YOU HAVE TO
USE IT IN A BOX FACILITY YOU
CAN NEVER DOWNLOAD IT OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT SO WE HAVE
LOTS OF EXAMPLES- ALREADY
AROUND OF HOW WE CAN DO THAT.
SO ONCE YOU HAVE THAT SYSTEM
YOU COULD IMAGINE A WORLD IN
WHICH- WE HAVE SOME DETAILED
INFORMATION THAT'S MADE
AVAILABLE UNDER SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR RESEARCH
PERSON PURPOSES- WE HAVE
ANOTHER SET OF DATA- THAT IS-
USED FOR REPORTING AND FOR.
COMMON STANDARDS THAT CENTER.
AGO I MY LAST NIGHT THANK YOU-
AND THEN YOU COULD HAVE SOME
THAT IS OPEN TO THE BUT- I'VE
ALREADY MET. PRIVACY CONCERNS
CAN BE ADDRESSED THROUGH THESE
ACCESS RULES I'M HAPPY TO TALK
ABOUT THAT RELATED. SO I'M JUST
GIVE ALL THAT. WE HAVE MANY
EXAM THAT WE GIVE YOU OF. DATA
SOURCES THAT WE KEEP- AND THEN
FINALLY AT THE LAST SLIDE
HERE'S A FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU- BUT ALSO WE KNOW THERE ARE
LOTS OF ISSUES THAT WE WERE NOT
ABLE TO BRING UP IN OUR FIVE
MINUTE SLOT HERE- BUT WE'RE
HAPPY TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT.
WHETHER THERE ARE QUESTIONS. UP
IS A PROVIDE PROVIDERS SHOULD
BE SUBJECT THE SAME RULES
SOMETHING LIKE THAT SO YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU I WILL WILL
HOLD QUESTIONS TO THE OTHER
PANEL THAT WHILE IT'S EVERYBODY
QUESTIONS OF. IF THAT'S ALRIGHT
WITH EVERYBODY. AND SO WHERE
RENTALS. SHE'S THE GENERAL
MANAGER OF LA- DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION SO. VERY BUSY
PERSON. I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SENATOR
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME IN A DRESS
YOU AGAIN WE APPRECIATE THE
DIFFICULT IMPORTANT WORK. WE
WANT TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
SUPPORT THAT SO- I'M HERE TODAY
AS AS REALLY ONE OF THE ONLY
PEOPLE HERE WHO LIKE YOU IS
ACCOUNTABLE DIRECTLY TO THE
PUBLIC MY JOB IS TO SERVE THE
PUBLIC GOOD. AND THE STORY THAT
BROUGHT US HERE TODAY'S EXISTED
SINCE THE FIRST TWO WERE RIGHT
ABOUT A DECADE AGO CAN AT STAKE
FOR US IS WHETHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE CHEAP ROLLER MAY. OR
WHAT PRIVATE COMPANIES WILL
TAKE. CHARGE OF OUR SO. STREETS
AND SKIES. WITH RIDE SHARING
UBER AND LIFT MADE THE CLAIM
THAT INNOVATION AND PROGRESS
ARE AT ODDS WITH LOCAL
OVERSIGHT. AND THE RESULT IS
THAT OUR CITIES WERE LEFT TO
HANDLE THE COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
IN TRAFFIC AND- CONGESTION.
LIMITED SCOPE TO EMISSIONS.
GROWING PUBLIC. CONCERN DO YOU
SEE. WHAT TRANSIT USE. AND THE
MISTREATMENT OF WORKERS THAT.
FIRE THIS JUST LETTER. TO PASS
IT BE FIVE. THIS IS THE-
OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE WERE A MESS.
THAT WHY THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND NOW. NINETY CITIES.
WHY RECALL. BACCHUS UP. YOUR
BASIC DATA. OUT THERE. GOAL THE
PUBLIC OF. WE CAN. TO THEM TO.
ST INSIDE. CLEARANCE. THE
COMPLAINTS CAN. TO MAKE AN- IT
EASIER AT AND MAKE HOW INFORM
BY WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENING OUR
STREETS. TO BE CLEAR WE AB. DO
NOT. PERSONAL IN. ABOUT RIGHT.
QUITE I WAS TO. ALL OF THE
PROVIDE TO AVOID MANIPULATION
AND MISINFORMATION THE
CORPORATIONS HAVE ENGAGED IN
PREVIOUSLY TO THOSE WHO SUPPORT
LESS STRINGENT ALTERNATIVES I
HAVE A SIMPLE GEN IF A PRIVATE
COMPANY WERE PROVIDED
INCOMPLETE INACCURATE OR FALSE
DATA HOW WOULD YOU KNOW. HIS
WORK HERE IS PRETTY FOR DESPITE
WHAT SOME MAY HAVE YOU BELIEVE
LET ME LAY OUT HOW THE SYSTEM
WORKS THE FIVE SECONDS AFTER
SCOOTER IN THE PUBLIC RIGHT OF
WAY IS LOCKED OR UNLOCKED THE
COMPANY NO FIVE SAT AND SENDS
ITS LOW. THIS SAME CHOIR ALLOWS.
CHECK THE FOR PROFIT COMPANIES
IF OUR TEAM UNLOCKS THE SCOOTER
AND THE COMPANY DOESN'T SEND A
NOTIFICATION THEN WE KNOW THAT
ALL OF THEIR DATA IS
POTENTIALLY SUSPECT WE DECIDED
THIS TO ALLOW WHAT ANGELES TO
HAVE THE LARGEST MOBILITY PILOT
IN THE COUNTRY WITH THE
LIMITATIONS ON THE NUMBER OF
UNEASE THAT SIMPLE IS MEANT THE
CITY. WILL ALSO EVELYN WITHOUT
NEW IDEAS WAS AVOID ANOTHER
GATE WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
OUT GOOD IS YOU IN THE PUBLIC
WRITER WAY. ANY SENSE THE CITY
THE ROUTE AGAIN THE CARD IS
NOTIFIED CITY WHEN THEY MAY A
SCHOOL FROM ONE LOCATION TO
ANOTHER WHEN THEY TAKE A
SCOOTER OFF LINE FOR
MAINTENANCE OR BECAUSE IT'S OUT
OF SERVICE. UNFORTUNATELY THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF FALSE PREMISE
PEATED BUT FOLKS ARE
QUESTIONING CITIES RIGHT TO
REQUEST THE NOTIFICATION DATA
SOMEONE TO CLARIFY A FEW
MISCONCEPTIONS FIRST THE DATA
IS SAFE AND YOUR- WE CLASSIFY
THE STATE AS CONFIDENTIAL. IT'S
UP. AND IT IS NOT SUB THE
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT THE DATA IS
SECURE ACCESS EVEN WITHIN
DEPARTMENT IS STRICTLY LIMITED
AND WE HAVE RULES AND
GUIDELINES. FOR IT'S MY TO SAY
SHE- OR ANYTHING ELSE. THESE
LARGE AND SMALL HAVE STRONG
RECORD OF HIGHLY SO AND FOR.
NAMES ADDRESSES SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS CHECKING ACCOUNT AND
CREDIT CARD NUMBERS THAT
INFORMATION IS FAR MORE
SENSITIVE THAN THE INFORMATION
WE GET FROM OUR CAUCUS PROGRAM
SECOND WE COLLECT NO
INFORMATION ABOUT WRITERS EVEN
IF SOMEONE WERE ABLE TO LEGALLY
ACCESS OUR ROB DID DOCTORS DATA%
THEY NEED TO HACK OTHER SOURCES
TO COBBLE TOGETHER AN
INDIVIDUAL'S IDENTITY. CONTRACT
WE KNOW EXTENSIVE THE COMP KEEP
WHEN PEOPLE ARE NOT USING THEIR
VEHICLES THIRD THIS WILL NOT
BECOME A TOOL FOR SURVEILLANCE
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT THE DATA WE
RECEIVE ARE ONLYACCESSIBLE TO
LAWN FORCE THERE WAS. OR
WARRANT FURTHER MORE THE DAY WE
HAVE WOULD BE A LITTLE WELL YOU
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT WE HAVE
RECEIVED ZERO REQUESTS FOR IT
FOR THE THIRD PARTY
INTERMEDIARY ARE NOT A SOLUTION
OR SUBSTITUTE FOR LOCAL
OVERSIGHT THERE BENEATH WANT
BOOKER I'D AND COME. PRIVATE
SECTOR ACT PROVIDE GREAT EIGHT
IS AN THIS BUT THE PUBLIC
SECTOR IS BEST EQUIPPED TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND STE YOU
HAVE NO TO GAIN. I'M PROUD
SANTA TRACKER. NATION'S LARA.
BUT HE'S CENTER STE HAVE
COMPLIED WITH OVER. COMPLAIN OF
FALL INSTEAD EVEN AS RIGHTS
HAVE INCREASED SINCE APRIL WHEN
OUR PILOT LAUNCHED WE HAVE SEEN
MORE THAN SEVEN MILLION RIDES
ON THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND DACA
SCOOTERS AND BIKES JUST IN THE
CITY INSTEAD OF CLOSING THE
DOOR ON DOC LIST AND WAIT FOR
OTHER CITIES TO ACT WE OPENED
OUR DOORS TO MOBILITY COMPANIES
AND SAID LET'S FIGURE THIS OUT
TOGETHER. BUT THERE'S NO WAY WE
CAN RUN THE LARGEST PROGRAM
COUNTRY WITHOUT BALLOT INSIGHT
INTO WHAT'S HAPPENING ON OUR
STREETS AND SIDEWALKS EVENT
WHEN FLEET TAX. THREE THINGS
AND AUTONOMOUS VHICLES VERGE.
LIKE TO MAKE. IS ABOUT ROAD AND
THE SKY WE CANNOT MAKE IN THE
DARK WE'VE WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
WE TRY PRIVATE COMPANIES ARE
ACCOUNTABLE TO SHAREHOLDERS AND
WE ARE ACCOUNTABLE TO EVERYONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OF WILL
NOW TURN TO DOCTOR. OF REGINA
OF A CLUE THOUGH- CO POPULOUS
AND- YOU DON'T HAVE TO STAND UP
THERE IF YOU DON'T WANT TO YOU
CAN I MEAN SORRY. WHATEVER YOU
CHOOSE. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON TEARS FELL AND
JACKSON MEMBERS OF THE
TRANSPORTATION JUST YEAR
COMMITTEES THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY TO
DISCUSS THE IMPORTANT ISSUES
RELATED TO MOVE THE DATA AND
PRIVACY MY NAME NECKLACE WELL
I'M THE CEO AND CO FOUNDER
POPULOUS A DATA A SAN FRANCISCO
BASED SOFTWARE COMPANY POPULOUS
IS A THIRD PARTY PLATFORM THAT
EIGHT CITIES IN. AND COST
EFFICIENT TO. SECURELY UP TO
DATA FROM ABILITY OPERATE. TO
CREATE ENFORCE POLICIES TO
MANAGE MOBILITY SERVICES THAT
OPERATE IN THE PUBLIC RIGHT OF
WAY TO MY EXPERIENCE IS THE CEO
POPULOUS I SPENT THE MAJORITY
OF MY PROFESSIONAL CAREER AS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION FOCUSED
ON SUSTAINABILITY AND CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND AS AN ACADEMIC
RESEARCHER AT MIT THE BURKE
STANFORD AND UC DAVIS I
RECEIVED A PHD IN
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS FROM MIT
IN TWENTY TWELVE AND I ALSO
HOLD A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE WHICH I FROM
CORNELL APPROXIMATELY TWENTY.
WHEN YEAH TO EXPAND THEIR NEW
COMMERCIAL SERVICES IN SAN
FRANCISCO I WAS A PROJECT LEAD
FOR THE BAY AREA'S TWENTY FIVE
YEAR REGIONAL PLAN THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION A COURT CHALLENGE
THAT WE FACE DOES THAT WE HAD
ZERO INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
THESE NEW SERVICES FOR CHANGING
TRAVEL PATTERNS INTO TWELVE I
BEGAN TO WORK ON NEW SOLUTIONS
AND METHODS TO HELP AGENCIES.
AS THE INFORMATION THEY WOULD
NEED DRIVE PROGRESS ON KEY
PUBLIC. STATE ABILITY. WILL ACT.
TO TRANSPORTATION. SIMILAR TO
OUR FIRST PRESENTER HERE I
COLLECTED TRAVEL SURVEY DATA IS
THAT ACTUALLY LED TO SOME OF
THE FIRST STUDIES THAT
INDICATED THE IMPACTS OF UBER
AND LEFT ON OUR TRANSPORTATION.
DUMPSTER SOME OF THE MOST CITED
TODAY. TODAY ALL DESCRIBE THE
NATURE AND ROLE OF THIRD PARTY
SOLUTIONS. FORMER EMIGRATE SIR
OR AS A GREAT DEAL OF TIME.
ABOUT THE HOUSING OF DIFFERENT
GOVERNOR BOTTLES FOR THE DATA
SHARING OVER THE PAST EIGHT
YEARS. TODAY THERE ARE THREE
COMMON. THE DATA SURE. THE
FIRST IS BEING PRE AGGREGATED
DATA FROM OPERATORS. THE KEY
CRITICISM OF THIS APPROACH IS
THAT SOME AGENCIS DO NOT FEEL
THAT OPERATORS CAN TRUTHFULLY
SELF REPORT ON THEIR SERVICES
WHICH IS FAIR. THE SECOND IS
THAT YOU SING IT PARTS OF THIRD
PARTY SOLUTIONS SUCH AS
POPULOUS OF AGENCIES ARE ABLE
TO THEN RECEIVE- ROD DISAGREED
DATA FROM. OPERATORS TO THE
AUDITING SERVICES AND CAN THEN
JUST LEAVE TH INFORMATION THEY
NEED AND WANT IN FORM OF CHARTS
REPORTS VISUALISATIONS AND
OTHER DATA IT'S BETTER. THAT
ALLOW THEM TO MAKE THE KEEP.
AND PLANNING TO. THEY NEED TO
MAKE AS THERE ARE STORIES OF
THE PUBLIC RIGHT OF WAY. AND
THE THIRD MODEL IS FOR CITIES
TO DIRECTLY RECEIVE ROD
DISAGGREGATED DATA FROM ABILITY
OPERATORS I FIRST POPULOUS IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF KEY CHALLENGES THAT I
WITNESSED PUBLIC AGENCY OR
STRUGGLE WITH. WHEN DATA IS
DELIVERED DIRECTLY TO PUBLIC
AGENCIES SPECIFICALLY HOLDING
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL SENSITIVE
INFORMATION CAN BE DIFFICULT
FOR SOME AGENCIES THAT MAY LACK
THE DATA MANAGEMENT PROTOCOLS
THAT SHOULD BE IN PLACE TO
PROTECT THAT DATA. LIMIT ACCESS
TO IT. I'M CURRENTLY WE FOUND
THAT NOT OLD. THE FOR RESOURCES
TO BUILD INTERNAL SOLUTIONS TO
TURN WHAT IS A VERY LARGE VERY
MESSY DATA INTO THE USEFUL
INFORMATION THAT TRANSPORTATION
PLANNERS NEED. AND WANT FOR
POLICY AND PLANNING. OF THIS
KIND OF POLICY ARE SEVERAL
THIRD PARTY DATA GOVERNANCE
MODELS THAT FOLKS HAVE
CONTEMPLATED OVER THE LAST
DECADE I PURPOSELY. POPULOUS IS
A PRIVATE SECTOR COMPANY
DESPITE MY BACKGROUND IN THE
NONPROFIT ACADEMIC AND PUBLIC
SECTOR INSTITUTIONS. BECAUSE
THEIR NUMBER OF KEY CONSTRAINTS
THAT UNDER THESE INSTITUTIONS
FROM EFFECTIVELY SOLVING THE
MOBILITY DATA GAP. FIRST
SECURELY STORING CLEANING A
PROCESSING LARGE AMOUNTS OF GEO
LOCATION DATA REQUIRES
SIGNIFICANT ENGINEERING SOURCES
AND VERY FEW NONPROFIT AN
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS POSSESS
THEM. THAT BEING SAID IT IS
CRUCIAL THAT INDEPENDENT
RESEARCHERS AND EXHORTATION
CONSULTANTS HAVE ACCESS TO
MOBILITY DATE. ANSWER THE MANY
CAR AND- OF THESE MOBILE
SERVICE. LET'S HAS A NUMEROUS
THE FROM ACTS TO MY DAY FOR NOT
ADVOCACY. TRANSPORTATION FOR
AND PERFECT PROFESSORS PER THE
REQUEST OF OUR CITY CUSTOMERS
AND WITH THE PERMISSION OF
MOBILITY OPERATORS LET ME
ILLUSTRATE A FEW DIFFERENT USE
CASES AND THE REQUIRED LEVEL OF
DATA GRANULARITY AND REQUIRED
AND SEE- FOR THOSE SPECIFIC USE
CASES TO BE FEASIBLE. AND MY
WORK LET WE FIND THAT THE
MAJORITY OF CITIES WERE BILLY
OPERATORS TO ABIDE BY POLICIES
THAT PRIMARILY IMPACT
STATIONARY VEHICLES PARKED
VEHICLES SUCH AS PREFERRED-
RESTRICTED PARKING AREAS CAPS
LIMITING THE NUMBER OF VEHICLES
ON A CENTRAL IN A CENTRAL
BUSINESS DISTRICT OR PLACING A
MINIMUM NUMBER OF YOU. THE
EQUITIES OWNS REAL TIME AND FOR
ME. VEHICLES FOR DATA
VALIDATION SAYS IS SOMETHING WE
WERE. HOW PACKED SPEAKING WE DO
FIND THAT MOST CITIES AND FORCE
THESE POLICIES ON MORE OF A
MONTHLY OR QUARTERLY BASIS- THE
MOBILITY DATA SPECIFICATION
HASN'T BEEN PARTICULARLY WELL
SUITED TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ABOUT STATIONARY VEHICLES. AS
HAS BEEN RECENTLY DESCRIBED IN
SOME CITY REPORTS THAT HAVE
UTILIZED THESE- DATA FEEDS AND
A COUPLE OF OTHER JURISDICTIONS
AROUND THE UNITED STATES. SOME
CITIES ENVISION A FUTURE WHERE.
DATA COULD BE USED IN REAL TIME
TO MORE ACTIVELY MANAGE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM FOR
EXAMPLE THE REAL TIME ROUTING
OR READ TIME THING OF. HOWEVER
CAN. THAT THE BORDER CALL UPON
AGENT HAS ON THE TRACK. SYSTEM
THE MORE RISK IN LIABILITY THEY
ALSO HAVE TO BE WILLING TO
ASSUME. ONE EXAMPLE IN THE
CONTEXT OF STUDENTS SCOOTERS
THAT WE SEE TODAY IS THAT THERE
ARE NUMBER OF CITIES THAT
ADOPTED LOW SPEED ZONES FIRST.
BY RICK OPERATORS AUTOMATICALLY
READ SPEED OF THEIR VEHICLES
WITHIN A SPECIFIED GEO FENCE.
WITHOUT PROPER NOTICE TO
WRITERS HOWEVER THIS CAN
POTENTIALLY COMPOUND SAFETY
ISSUES FOR EXAMPLE A WOMAN IN
SANTA MONICA BADLY INJURED WHEN
HER HUSBAND SCOOTER SUDDENLY
ACCELERATED. UPON LEAVING ALONE
IT'S OUT AND SLAMMED INTO HER
LEAVING HER WITH THREE BROKEN
BONES AND LIKE REQUIRING
SURGERY. POLICIES THAT ARE
IMPLEMENTED DIGITALLY WITHOUT
PHYSICAL SIGNAGE OR
COMMUNICATION TO WRITERS ABOUT
AUTOMATIC WRIST. THE INCREASE
ABILITY FOR IS IMPOSING. CITIES
MUST HAVE AN TO MOBILITY DATA
AS PUBLIC OF TRANSFER FOR. WELL
PRIVATE MOBILITY COMPANIES MAY
SPELLS TO SOLVE CONGESTION
REDUCE TRAFFIC FATALITIES AND
EXPAND EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
SERVICES I BELIEVE IT IS PUBLIC
AGENCIES PRIMARILY THAT HAVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO STEER
PROGRESS TOWARDS THESE GOALS
THE AVAILABILITY DATA HAS
CHANGED SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE
PAST TWO YEARS AND I AM
OPTIMISTIC WE CAN FIND WAYS OF
BEING THAT AGENCIES HAVE. FULL
AND KATE AT THE MOBILITY DATA.
FOR THE NEW VALUES QUE WHILE
ALSO ENSURING THE DATA NOT MISS
USE OR EITHER INTENTIONAL OR
UNINTENTIONALLY. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY ON THIS TOPIC I
HAVE A NUMBER OF SITES THAT
PROVIDE THE TEAM ON. THE
DISPLAY INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
SERVICE IS ACTUALLY VISUAL I
NOODLE BY PUBLIC A- TO MANAGE
PUBLIC RIGHT OF WAY. TOP TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT YOU. IF
YOUR HOUSE SO TARA SEAVER FROM
YOU EAT OF UBER. A HAD A SIX
POLICIES SO WELCOME AND- YOU
HAVE THE FLOOR THANK YOU CHAIRS
BELL IN JACKSON MY NAME IS A
TARA SEVERAL AND I LEAD PRIVACY
AND SECURITY POLICY GLOBALLY
BROUGH BURKE. I'M GRATEFUL TO
DROP THE LEGISLATURE ON ISSUE
WE ARE DEEPLY PASSIONATE ABOUT
PROTECTING LOCATION DATA AND
CONCERT PRIVATE PARTNERING WITH
CITIES TO ACHIEVE PAUL POSITIVE
POLICY COMES IN TREPIDATION.
TODAY I WANT TO. FRIEND OF
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES DEMANDING
ACCESS TO PRECISE AN INDIVIDUAL
LOCATION DATA COLLECTED BY
MOBILITY COMPANIES LIKE UBER
WITHOUT SEEKING A COURT ORDER
OR SEARCH WARRANT AS IS
REQUIRED BY STATE LAW. YOUR
PATIENT DATA IS DEEPLY PERSONAL
WHERE YOU LIVE WHERE YOU WORK
FOR YOUR CHILDREN GO TO SCHOOL.
ALL SPEAK VOLUMES ABOUT WHO YOU
ARE AND WHAT YOU CARE ABOUT.
SINCE JOINING UBER AND
DEDICATED TO PROTECTING
CONSUMER PRIVACY BY PROTECTING
CONSUMER DATA. AND NOT JUST
NAMES AND EMAIL ADDRESSES BUT
ALSO THE PLACES ARE USERS GO
AND THE PEOPLE THEY TRAVEL
WITH. CITIES ARE NEGLECTING THE
INHERENTLY SENSITIVE NATURE OF
LOCATION DATA AND IT'S
CONSUMERS WHO PAY THE PRICE.
CALIFORNIA RAISE THE BAR AND
PROXY PASSING THE COUNTRY'S
MOST COMPREHENSIVE AND
PROGRESSIVE PIPE PRIVACY LAW
OVER TWO YEARS AGO. THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
SPECIFICALLY INTENDED TO
PROTECT USERS FROM THE MISUSE
AND RAMPANT DISTRIBUTION OF
THEIR DATA ACROSS THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. BUT IN PARALLEL THE
REPORTS OF DATA BREACHES AT THE
CITY STATE AND FEDERAL LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT. THEREFORE WE CAN
NO LONGER AFFORD EXCEPTIONS TO
THE RULE FOR PUBLIC SECTOR
ACTORS WHEN IT COMES TO PRIVACY.
THE LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL ISSUED
A FORMAL WRITTEN OPINION WHICH
STATED THAT THE COMPELLED
SHARING OF REAL TIME PRECISE
GEO LOCATION DATA TO THE
GOVERNMENT. REQUIRES A VALID
WARRANT OR OTHER DUE PROCESS.
TODAY WE ARE ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO RE ASSERT TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS LAW TO
PROTECTING CONSUMER PRIVACY IN
THE CONTEXT OF TRANSPORTATION
AND MOBILITY DATA. THIS AREA A
PUBLIC POLICY HAS NOT GOTTEN
ENOUGH ATTENTION DURING A TIME
WHEN CONSEQUENTIAL DECISIONS
ABOUT DATA PROTECTION AND
PRIVACY ARE BEING MADE. TO VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PARTICIPATE AND TODAY'S
CONVERSATION. UBER DEEPLY
BELIEVES IN THE POWER OF USING
DATA IN ORDER TO IMPROVE AND
INFORM PUBLIC POLICY. HELPING
TO MAKE TRANSPORTATION SAFE
SUSTAINABLE AND ACCESSIBLE. FOR
THE MAJORITY OF POLICY
OBJECTIVES SECURING HISTORICAL
AN AGGREGATED DATA IS NOT ONLY
SAFER THAN SHARING INDIVIDUAL
LEVEL DATA IT'S ALSO MORE
USEFUL. FOR EXAMPLE IF THE CITY
WANTS TO INSURE UNDERSERVED
AREAS HAVE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
SERVICES LIKE UBER THEY NEED TO
KNOW THE RELATIVE VOLUMES OF
TRIPS STARTING AND ENDING IN
THOSE AREAS NOT THE REAL TIME
LOCATION OF EVERY INDIVIDUAL
THAT'S ON OUR PLATFORM. UBER
ITSELF YOU AGGREGATED DATA TO
MAKE CRITICAL BUSINESS
DECISIONS. INDIVIDUAL LOCATION
DATA CAN PROVE USEFUL WHEN
INVESTIGATING A SAFETY
INCIDENT. BUT THERE ARE LEGAL
PROTOCOLS AND PROCESSES FOR
SHARING THIS INFORMATION WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT. WE ARE NOT TO
HIDE BEHIND PRIVACY IN FACT
EVERY YEAR WE PUBLISH A
TRANSPARENCY REPORT ABOUT THE
DATA WE SHARE. WE ARE DEEPLY
INVESTED AND SHARING DATA AND
WHERE POSSIBLE WE ASKED TO
AGGREGATE AND ANONYMIZE DATA
ESPECIALLY LOCATION DATA SO
THAT CITIES CAN BE FULLY
TRANSPARENT WITH THE PUBLIC AND
RELEASE PROPERLY ANONYMOUS DATA
WHEN THEY GET A PUBLIC RECORDS
ACCESS REQUEST. HOWEVER
GOVERNMENT APPETITE FOR FAR
MORE PERSONAL DATA AND
INTRUSIVE DATA IS GROWING. MOST
RECENTLY WE WERE ASKED TO
EXPOSE THE MOVEMENTS OF OUR
DOCTORS BIKE AND SCOOTER USERS
IN REAL TIME. NOT JUST FOR THE
CITY TO USE BUT ALSO FOR THEIR
THIRD PARTY CONTRACTORS TO USE
AS WELL. THIS REQUIREMENT
CALLED CALLED THE MOBILITY DATA
SPECIFICATION OR MDS CROSSED
THE LINE WE HAVE HELD AS A
COMPANY SERVING MILLIONS OF
USERS AROUND THE WORLD TRUSTED
TO KEEP THEIR WHEREABOUTS
PRIVATE. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
SAFE FROM SURVEILLANCE. THE MTS
IS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW FREQUENTLY
LOCATION DATA IS MIS
CHARACTERIZED AS JUST TRIP
DATA. ACTUALLY THE MDS REVEALS
THE PRECISE GPS COORDINATES OF
WHERE AND WHEN OUR WRITERS
START THEIR JOURNEY. WHERE THEY
END UP AND WHAT ROUTE THEY TOOK.
THIS IS FOR DATA BUT IT'S ALSO
PERSONAL DATA THEY ARE ONE AND
THE SAME GIVING TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES ACCESS TO THE LOCATION
DATA OF OUR USERS IN REAL TIME
IS A CAN TO PLACING A TRACKING
DEVICE IN THEIR POCKETS AND IN
THIS CASE. THEY CAN'T REMOVE IT.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHERE THEIR
DATA IS GOING OR HOW THEIR DATA
PRECISE LOCATION OF AN
INDIVIDUAL WHETHER THEY'RE IN
THEIR PERSONAL VEHICLE ON A
BIKE ON A TROLLEY OR SIMPLY
WALKING ON THE STREET IS DEEPLY
PERSONAL EVEN IF SPECIFIC NAMES
HAVE BEEN REMOVED. TRANSIT AND
MOBILITY DATA IS ESPECIALLY
SENSITIVE BECAUSE IT CAN
INCLUDE AN INDIVIDUAL'S HOME
AND THE LOCATIONS THEY VISIT.
SUCH AS HOUSE OF WORSHIP.
EMPLOYMENT LOCATIONS AND DOCTOR
SUPPORT. THE NEW YORK TIMES
RECENTLY REPORTED THAT DNA IS
PROBABLY THE ONLY THING THAT'S
HARD TO ANONYMOUS. BEEN PRECISE
LOCATION INFORMATION. THESE
MONUMENTAL RISKS ARE THE REASON
WHY THIS LEGISLATURE ENACTED
THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATIONS PRIVACY ACT. THE
ORGANIZATIONS PIVOTAL TO
DEVELOPING THAT LAW SOME OF
WHOM ARE REPRESENTED HERE TODAY
HAVE BEEN ARGUING THAT THE MDS
AND OTHER REAL TIME DATA
SHARING STANDARDS VIOLATE THE
STATUTE. MICROBIOLOGY MIGHT BE
THE REASON WE'RE ALL HERE
TODAY. BUT AS WE CONSIDER OTHER
MODES OF POINT TO POINT TRAVEL
DATA FROM A RIDE SHARING
VEHICLE TO A PERSONAL VEHICLE
WE FACE AN UNPRECEDENTED RISK
TO USER PRIVACY THROUGH THE
CONSTANT AND PERSISTENT
SURVEILLANCE OF INDIVIDUALS BY
THE- GOVERNMENTS. INDEED THE
CPUC HAS BEEN COLLECTING
PERSONAL DATA ABOUT OUR DRIVERS
AND WRITERS FOR YEARS WITHOUT
PRESSING THE REST VISUAL
PRIVACY. WE HAVE YET TO SEE ANY
ANALYSIS OR INSIGHTS FROM THE
CPUC THAT EXPLAINS THE IMPACT
OF TMZ'S WHICH IS WHY THEY
COLLECTED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AND IF THIS IS LIKELY BECAUSE
THE DATA IS TO GRANULAR AND
UNWIELDY. WITHOUT ANY STANDARD
METHODOLOGIES FOR USING THIS
DATA IT LIES ON USED ON A
SERVER SOMEWHERE AND NOW THE
CPC PROPOSES TO MAKE THE STATE
A PUBLIC WHICH WE ALREADY KNOW
COULD BE USED BY UNSCRUPULOUS
ACTORS. TO TARGET STOCK OR
HARASS INDIVIDUALS. THIS IS THE
UNFORTUNATE CONSEQUENCE OF
MAKING PRIVACY AN AFTER THOUGHT
FOR IMPORTANT AND LASTING
DECISIONS. TODAY CONSUMER
EXPECTATIONS OF TRANSPARENCY
AND PRIVACY ARE GROWING AND
THIS REPRESENTS A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY BETWEEN THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTORS AS
DATA CONTINUES TO FLOW BETWEEN
US. SMART CITY PLANNING DOES
NOT HAVE TO COME AT THE EXPENSE
OF CONSUMER PRIVACY AND WE ARE
DEDICATED TO WORKING WITH
CITIES AND OTHER MOBILITY
OPERATORS TO DEVELOP SMART
EFFECTIVE AND DATA RICH
SOLUTIONS IN THIS SPACE. IN
PARALLEL WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAN
CONTINUE TO LEAD ON THIS ISSUE
BY REAFFIRMING THE LAWS THAT
GOVERN BOTH THE PRIVATE AND THE
PUBLIC SECTORS USE OF PATIENT
DATA THE LAWS ENACTED BY THIS
VERY. WHEN BOTH ARE HELD TO THE
SAME HIGH BAR OF CONSUMER
PRIVACY AND PROTECTION WE ARE
CONFIDENT THAT THIS DATA CAN BE
SHARED SAFELY. RESPONSIBLY AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY UTILIZED FOR
THE BENEFIT OF OUR USERS AND
YOUR CONSTITUENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A WILL NEXT YEAR
FROM- DOUG ITO HE'S THE
DIRECTOR OF. TECH BEEN
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
BUT AFTER CHAIR SENATE YEAH
YOU'RE UP AROUND OKAY GREAT
HERE. THANK YOU FOR HOSTING
THIS INFORMATION IT WAS JUST
YOU KNOW ACTUALLY WANTS TO STOP
SO THE- WE HAVE AUDIENCE THAT
ARE WATCH. HELLO THE STATE HERE
SO. THAT MY BE. I'LL CHANGE THE
RULE HERE AS WE GO ALONG OUR
THOUGH WHICH NERO I DO ONCE IN
AWHILE IN A- OKAY GO AHEAD SIR
DOT YOUR THE FOR. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND MEMBERS. THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR LOW MULLIN
LOOKS MUCH BETTER SEE.
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY- AS YOU MENTION MY
NAME IS DOUG ITO I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION AT THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
THE COMMISSION HAS JURISDICTION
OVER FOR HIGHER PASSENGER
CARRIERS SUCH AS LIMOUSINES
AIRPORT SHUTTLES CHARTER BUS
OPERATE IN TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK COMPANIES LIKE UBER AND
LEFT. MY COMMENTS TODAY WILL
FOCUS ON DATA WE COLLECT FROM
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES OR TNCS. AS PART OF
THE COMMISSION'S OBLIGATION TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS AND PROMOTE
PUBLIC SAFETY WE COLLECT
VARIOUS TYPES OF DATA TO AND
FOR STATE LAW AND GUIDE OUR
REGULATION OF THE RAPIDLY
EVOLVING TNC INDUSTRY.
SPECIFICALLY THERE ARE TWO
COMMISSION DECISIONS THAT ARE
THE BASIS FOR THE DATA SI PC
COLLECTS. DECISION THIRTEEN
NINE FORTY FIVE FROM TWENTY
THIRTEEN. AND DECISION SIXTEEN
FOR FORTY ONE FROM TWENTY
SIXTEEN. THESE DECISIONS
ADOPTED SPECIFIC SAFETY AND
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS THAT
TNC IS FOLLOW AND REQUIRE TNC
IS TO FILE ANNUAL REPORTS WITH
THE COMMISSION. EXAMPLES OF DAY
CATEGORIES IN THE ANNUAL
REPORTS INCLUDE INFORMATION
SPECIFIC TO TNC DRIVERS TRIP
INFORMATION THAT INCLUDE SHARED
OR PULLED RIGHTS. TRAFFIC
INCIDENTS AND ACCIDENTS ZERO
TOLERANCE COMPLAINTS INVOLVING
INTOXICATING SUBSTANCES.
INCIDENTS OF ASSAULT AND
HARASSMENT BY PASSENGERS AND
DRIVERS AND ACCESSIBILITY DATA.
IN ADDITION TO THE ANNUAL
REPORTS THE COMMISSION MAY ALSO
COLLECT DATA FROM TEEN SEES
THROUGH INDIVIDUAL REQUESTS.
THE INFORMATION OBTAINED BY THE
COMMISSION IS USED FOR BOTH
ADVISORY AND ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSES. FOR EXAMPLE IN AN
ONGOING RULE MAKING OUR
NINETEEN TO TWELVE THE
COMMISSION IS IMPLEMENTING
SENATOR HILLS TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BILL SB THREE SEVENTY SIX
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX WHICH
REQUIRES THE COMMISSION TO
DEVELOP PROGRAMS THAT IMPROVES
TNC ACCESSIBILITY FOR PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES. USING THE
ANNUAL REPORT DATA COMMISSION
STAFF CALCULATED THE TIME
NINETEEN SEIZE TOOK TO PICK UP
PASSENGERS IN EACH CALIFORNIA
COUNTY. THIS INFORMATION IS NOW
BEING USED TO GUIDE
COMMISSIONERS IN ASSESSING WHAT
MIGHT BE REASONABLE RESPONSE
TIMES FOURTEEN SEES THAT
PROVIDE SERVICE USING
WHEELCHAIR ACCESSIBLE VEHICLES.
AS ANOTHER EXAMPLE THE ANNUAL
REPORT DATA ALSO HELPS GUIDE
INVESTIGATIVE EFFORTS. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS A RESULT OF
AN INVESTIGATION BASED ON
HOOPER'S REPORTED ZERO
TOLERANCE COMPLAIN DATA. THE
COMMISSION ISSUED A SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
FINE AND REQUIRED OVER TO
IMPLEMENT PROTOCOLS TO IMPROVE
ZERO TOLERANCE COMPLIANCE. I
WILL NOT DISCUSS THE
COMMISSION'S APPROACH TO DATE
ACCOUNT CONFIDENTIALITY.
PURSUANT TO THE DECISION
ADOPTED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN. TNC
ANNUAL REPORTS ARE PRESUMED TO
BE CONFIDENTIAL BY THE
COMMISSION. TODAY THESE HAVE
NOT BEEN SHARED WITH ANY OTHER
STATE OR LOCAL AGENCY OR
DISCLOSED TO THE PUBLIC.
HOWEVER LAST WEEK WE RECEIVED A
LETTER FROM THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD REQUESTING.
TRIP LEVEL DATA CONTAINED IN
THE REPORTS. CAR REQUEST IS PAR
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
SENATOR SKINNER'S TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BILL SB TEN FOURTEEN
THE CLEAN MILE STANDARD. WE
INTEND TO COMPLY WITH THE
REQUEST WITHIN AN INTER AGENCY
INFORMATION SHARING AGREEMENT
EXECUTED BETWEEN SI PC AND CARP
IN TWENTY NINETEEN. AT THE SAME
TIME WE ARE ALSO AWARE OF THE
INCREASING INTEREST THE PUBLIC
AND LOCAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES HAVE IN THE
AVAILABILITY OF TNC DATA. ON
THIS ISSUE LAST YEAR AS PART OF
AN ONGOING PRECEDING THE
ASSIGNED COMMISSIONER ASKED
WHETHER THE PRESUMPTION OF
CONFIDENTIALITY IN THE TWENTY
THIRTEEN DECISION SHOULD BE
AMENDED OR REVERSED. EARLIER
THIS MONTH FOLLOWING. PUBLIC
AND STAKEHOLDER INPUT THESE
COMMISSION ISSUE PROPOSE
DECISION. IF IT IS ADOPTED
FUTURE TNC ANNUAL REPORTS WILL
NO LONGER BE PRESUMED TO BE
CONFIDENTIAL. INSTEAD TNC WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO ESTABLISH A
BASIS FOR CONFIDENTIAL
TREATMENT BY THE COMMISSION FOR
EACH PAGE SECTION OR FIELD OF
DATA THAT THEY SUBMIT. THEY
WILL BE ALSO BE REQUIRED TO
SPECIFY THE STATUTORY BASIS FOR
EACH CLAIM AND PROVIDES A PACK-
FAXES SUPPORTING THEIR CLAIMS.
THE COMMISSION IS CURRENTLY
RECEIVING PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THAT PROPOSED DECISION. AT THE
STATE AGENCY THE COMMISSION
TAKES RESPONSIBILITY FOR
HANDLING SENSITIVE DATA VERY
SERIOUSLY. WE HAVE A DUTY TO
PROTECT CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION INCLUDING
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION AND CONFIDENTIAL
BUSINESS INFORMATION. IN ORDER
TO MANAGE CONFIDENTIAL DATA THE
COMMISSION MAINTAIN SEPARATE
CYBERSECURITY ENCRYPTION AND
DATA SECURITY POLICIES. THESE
POLICIES ARE IMPLEMENTED
COMMISSION WIDE AND ARE BASED
ON A TEMPLATE PROVIDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY WHICH CONFORMS
REQUIREMENTS FOR ALL STATE
AGENCIES. IN CLOSING I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PREVENT PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITY COMMISSIONS ROLE
IN TNC DATA COLLECTION AND USE.
OF A HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR
QUESTIONS DURING THE COMMENT
PERIOD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
WILL NOW TURN TO JACOB SNOW
JACOB AND HE'S THE TECHNOLOGY
AND CIVIL LIBERTIES ATTORNEY
FROM THE AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WELCOME THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY MY NAME IS JACOB SNOW I'M
A TECHNOLOGY DELIVERS ATTORNEY
AT THE ACLU OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND LIKE YOU TO
TAKE THREE MESSAGES FROM MY
TESTIMONY TODAY. FIRST DETAILED
LOCATION INFORMATION PUTS
PEOPLE AT RISK WHETHER IT'S IN
THE HANDS OF PRIVATE ENTITIES
OR ENHANCE THE GOVERNMENT.
SECOND CITIES AND COUNTIES
DESPITE. THE BEST INTENTIONS
HAVE NOT PROVEN THEMSELVES TO
BE GOOD STEWARDS OF PEOPLE'S
MOST PRIVATE INFORMATION. AND
THIRD IT IS THESE PRECISE
CONCERNS THAT MOTIVATE LAWS
LIKE THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATIONS PRIVACY ACT AND
THE CALIFORNIA BORN YOUR
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT AND THOSE
LAWS SHOULD NOT BE CREE HAVE
ACCEPTANCE OF THEM CREATED-
WE'RE JUSTIFIED BY POSSIBLE
INNOVATION IN THE MOVE MOBILITY
SPACE. FOR BY THE NECESSITY OF
PROVIDING AND ACCESSIBLE AND
SAFE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE. PRIVACY IS
COMPATIBLE WITH INNOVATION
ACCESS AND SAFETY. NDS IN JUST
A WIDE VARIETY OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION INCLUDING THE
PROVIDERS NAME IDENTIFIER FOR
THE VEHICLE OF THE VEHICLE TYPE
THE TRIP PLAINTIFF AND THE
VEHICLE ROUTE. OF THESE THE
MOST CONCERNING IS THE PRECISE
AND POTENTIALLY REAL TIME ROUTE
INFORMATION- SUBMITTED THROUGH
THAT SYSTEM. LOCATION
INFORMATION OF THIS KIND EVEN
IF IT LACKS- IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION OF A PERSON'S NAME
OR OR OTHER NUMBER- TO BE
DEEPLY REVEALING. AS UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT RECOGNIZED
IN CARPENTER VERSES UNITED
STATES TIME STAMP LOCATION
INFORMATION. PROVIDES AN
INTIMATE WINDOW INTO A PERSON'S
PRIVATE LIFE REVEALING NOT ONLY
THEIR PERSONAL- THE PARTICULAR
MOVEMENTS BUT THEIR FAMILIAL.
POLITICAL PROFESSIONAL
RELIGIOUS AND SEXUAL
ASSOCIATIONS. TODAY YOU'VE
HEARD THIS DETAILED LOCATION
INFORMATION CALLED PRIVATE OR
NOT PERSONAL THE TRUTH IS
ANONYMIZING THIS KIND OF
DETAILED INFORMATION IS A
POSSIBLE. IN DECEMBER THE NEW
YORK TIMES RELEASED AN ANALYSIS
OF LOCATION DATA IN WHICH
NUMEROUS PEOPLE WERE
IDENTIFIED. AND THAT WAS DONE
BY KNOWING THEIR LOCATION AT
ONE POINT IN TIME BUT THERE
WERE A HOME ADDRESS OR WORK
ADDRESS OR A PLACE WHERE THEY
WERE PHOTOGRAPHED. AND THEN
TAKING THAT ONE POINT. OPENING
IT INTO A ROUTE TO FIND OUT.
WHERE THAT PERSON RIGHT RESIDES
IN THE INFORMATION. BUT ALL IT
TAKES TO PICK A PERSON. OUT OF
A SO CALLED ANONYMOUS STATUS AT.
REDEDICATION CAN EXACERBATE
PERSECUTION BUT BY AND BYPASS
THE TARGETS PEOPLE AT THE
FRINGES. THIS INCLUDES POLICE
ENCOUNTERS IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT ALMOST A SWEEPS OR
PROBATION CONDITIONS TO NAME A
FEW. FOR THIS UNFORTUNATELY IS
NOT HYPOTHETICAL WE'VE ALREADY
SEEN FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
AUTHORITIES USING LOCATION
INFORMATION FROM LICENSE PLATE
CAMERAS TO TRACK PEOPLE FIND
THEM AND TARGET THEM FOR
DEPORTATION. IMAGINE HOW THE
DETAILED REAL TIME LOCATION
INFORMATION OF EVERYONE LEAVING
A MOSQUE WOULD AFFECT WRITERS
IN THE MUSLIM COMMUNITY. THESE
CONSIDERATIONS MUST BE
ADDRESSED AT THE OUTSET.
BUILDING PRIVACY IN FROM THE
BEGINNING MEANS ARTICULATING A
COMPELLING NEED FOR INFORMATION
FOR SELECTED LIMITING
COLLECTION RETENTION AND USE
SOLELY TO WHAT IS NECESSARY.
THESE KINDS PROTECTIONS- HAVE
NOT BEEN INCORPORATED AND THE
NDS SPECIFICALLY DOESN'T
INCLUDE PROTECTIONS APPROPRIATE
TO THE GRAVE PRIVACY RISKS
POSED BY THIS INFORMATION. EVEN
IF BETTER POLICIES EXISTED
COMPLIANCE IS NOT A SHORT. I
REFER THE COMMITTEE TO THE
RECENT REPORT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
REGARDING LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
USE OF AUTOMATED LICENSE PLATE
READERS BUT REPORT REFLECTS
POORLY ON LAUNCH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ABILITY TO PROTECT
PEOPLE'S PRIVACY AS LOCATION
INFORMATION IS COLLECTED. AND
STORED THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT FOR EXAMPLE HAS NO
POLICY AT ALL DESPITE THE FACT
THATHAVING A POLICIES REQUIRED
BY LAW. PRIVACY LIMITS WERE
RESPECTED IN A HOPE YOUR
LOCATION WAS PART RISK. THESE
TROUBLING RESULTS SHOULD BE THE
TOP OF MIND AS THE COMMITTEES
REFLECT ON WERE EXTENSIVE
COLLECTION LOCATION INFORMATION.
IT'S FOR THESE REASONS BUT CAL
AQABA IMPOSES STRICT LIMITS
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT CAN FORCE
ACCESS TO INFORMATION. FROM
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND FROM THE
VOICES. CALIPERS Y. APPLIES
EXPLICITLY TO CITIES AND
SUBDIVISIONS A MUNICIPAL
GOVERNMENT IN THE GOAL THE
STATUTE. IS TO EXPAND PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS BEYOND THAT WHICH
ARE AVAILABLE. UNDER FEDERAL
STATUTORY OR CONSTITUTIONAL LAW.
THE KIND OF SHARING THE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE ALSO
FRUSTRATES CONSUMER
EXPECTATIONS IN LIGHT OF THE
CAN SCALP FOR THE CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT. PEOPLE HAVE A
RIGHT TO REQUEST DELETION OF
THEIR- WRITING DATA. CONSUMERS
MIGHT DO THAT ARE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS I'VE TALKED ABOUT
TODAY. CONCERNS THEIR
INFORMATION WOULD BE MISUSED
SHARED OR SOLD IN WAYS THEY
DON'T AGREE WITH. THE
COMMISSION IS ALREADY BEEN
SHARED WITH CITIES OR THIRD
PARTIES THOSE DELETION RIGHTS
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT OF LOST THEIR
RELATIVES WITH. IF YOU FEEL
YOU'VE CALIFORNIA OPPOSE THE
COLLECTION OF SENSE OF
INFORMATION ABOUT INDIVIDUALS.
UNTIL REVISIONS ARE MADE TO
PROTECT CIVIL AND PRIVACY
RIGHTS OF INDIVIDUALS WILL BE
IMPACTED BY THAT COLLECTION. MY
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
HEY HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE
QUESTIONS ARE NO SIR DONALD A-
OTHERS- ONE OVER HERE ONE OVER
HERE- WE HAVE THREE MEMBERS
MAYBE SOME MORE SIR JACKSON
MYSELF OF ALL START OFF WITH
THE QUESTION. IN TERMS OF. CAN
RESEARCH BE DONE WITH
AGGREGATED DATA DOCTOR GIULIANO
IS THAT. GIVE IT GIVE A
PERSPECTIVE ABOUT. THE WORK
I'VE DONE OVER FORTY YEARS ON
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING IN IN
TRYING TO GET MOR PEOPLE TO
WRITE TRANSIT TRYING TO DEVISE
THE MOST EFFICIENT
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM TRY TO
DEALING WITH LAND USE
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES. AIR
POLLUTION AND TRYING TO REDUCE
AIR POLLUTION. OUR TOP WITH ALL
THE FEDERAL MANDATES THAT WE
HAVE YOU KNOW AND THE CHANGING
SOCIETY A CULTURAL. OF OTHER
NEEDS. OF CAN YOU CAN WE. IN A
WORLD GET MORE COMPLICATED AS
WE GO ALONG AND YOU KNOW WE'LL
WE'LL KNOW THAT. UNDER HAN
PRIVACY PROTECTION IS. PEOPLE
FEEL IS GETTING WORSE NOT
BETTER. I WOULD SAY. OKAY THIS
IS THE FACT ELECTION. OF SO HOW
DO WE DO THE GOOD THINGS W
NEED TO DO TO MAKE OUR CITIES
BEAUTIFUL PLACES TO LIVE. AT
THE SAME TIME. PROTECT THE
PRIVACY PEOPLE OF. IN IN TERMS
OF THE RESEARCH THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO TO MAKE OR THE
WORLD A BETTER PLACE TO LIVE
THANKS AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
DOING. SO MAYBE SOME OF THE
OTHER PANELISTS CAN COMMENT
ALSO MINOR QUESTION IS A MINOR
QUESTION BUT I THINK IT'S A NO
IT'S A PUBLIC POLICY QUESTION I
MEAN I ALSO WANT TO THROW IN
THIS THERE'S A LOT OF FEDERAL
MANDATES THEY TELL US TO DEUCE
YEAH WE HAVE ALL THE YOU KNOW
WE HAVE A CIVIL RIGHTS MANDATES.
WE ARE THERE FOR. MANDATES THE
ENVIRONMENTAL MANDATES. WE HAVE
THE AMERICAN DISABILITIES ACT
MANDATES. WE HAVE CONDITIONS
THAT THEY IMPOSE US ON EVERY
SINGLE NICKEL OF ANY KIND OF
FEDERAL MONEY WE GET FROM.
YELLOW SO YOU HAVE TO DO THE
SYSTEM THIS SHIP TO FILE THIS
REPORT YOU HAVE TO DO A SEQUEL
YOU HAVE TO DO. NEED ALL THIS
STUFF OKAY SO TO GET THE MONEY
TO BUILD THE TRANSIT SYSTEMS TO
BUILD VARIOUS THINGS. SO MAYBE
MAYBE THAT WOULD BE THE
QUESTION FOR EVERYBODY. OKAY
I'LL I'LL START OFF- AND LET'S
TALK ABOUT KIND OF THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT WE CAN
DO WITH AGGREGATE AND
DISAGGREGATED DATA YEAH THAT'S
AND IF YOU'RE BEGINNING POINT
PLEASE- AND LET'S USE THE
EXAMPLE OF TRANSIT- BECAUSE I
THINK- THAT SOMETHING THAT WE
ALL ARE FAMILIAR WITH- AND
DETERMINE. WE CAN WE CAN LEARN
A LOT FROM. THE AGGREGATE
BEHAVIORS LET'S SAY THE
BOARDINGS AT ALIGHTINGS AT
TRANSIT STOPS AND WE CAN LEARN
A LOT ABOUT DEMAND ON A TRANSIT
pSAID ALIGHTINGS ON THOSE STOPS
FOR EXAMPLE WE DON'T HAVE. BUT
THAT'S ALL WE CAN DO WITH THAT
DATA WE DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA OF.
WHAT THE COLLECTION OF PEOPLE
TOGETHER ACTUALLY WE DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THE COLLECTION
OF PEOPLE TOGETHER SO WITH
THEREFORE DON'T KNOWS THAT IF
WE WERE TO MAKE A CHANGE HOW
THAT CHANGE MIGHT- HAVE WHAT
KIND OF REACTION THERE MIGHT BE
TO A CHANGE IN SERVICE BECAUSE
WE DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE ENOUGH
AND INFORMATION ABOUT PEOPLE'S
PARTICULAR PREFERENCE SO IF WE
HAVE SOME INFORMATION ON
INTERVIEWS OF PEOPLE OVER ON
THE REAL ACTIVITIES EACH PERSON
IS DOING IN TERMS OF THEIR
TRAVEL BEHAVIOR WHICH IS WHAT
WE DO IN TRAVEL DIARIES THAN
HAVE DONE- THAT YOU CAN LOOK AT
HOW THAT DATA ARE HOW THOSE IN
THE TOOLS AND THE-
CHARACTERISTICS. REACT. TO
THREE ARE TO REALIZE BILLET THE
REVISED TO SERVE CALL AND SO.
AND FROM THAT INFORMATION WE
CAN THEN BUILD UP THE MODELS
THAT WE NEED TO PREDICT ON A
MORE AGGREGATE BASIS ACT SO
WITH THE BOTTOM OF THIS WE
ALWAYS NEED TO HAVE SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT. ABOUT THE
INDIVIDUALS THANKS- I THINK I
WOULD WHAT I'D LIKE TO MAKE A
POINT ABOUT REAL TIME VERSUS
NOT REAL TIME DATA- WHEN WE'RE
DOING RESEARCH WE'RE DOING
RESEARCH ON HISTORICAL DATA-
WE'RE NOT. GENERALLY IN THIS
TYPE OF RESEARCH WE'RE NOT
GOING OUT TO WATCH PEOPLE WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AT THE AT THE
MOMENT. WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
LOOK AT X. POST- WHAT IS THAT
BEHAVIOR SO THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND. SO FOR US
HISTORICAL DATA IS ACTUALLY
MORE WORTHWHILE THAN REAL TIME
DATA. NOW YOU HAD A SECOND PART
OF YOUR QUESTION JULY JUST- I
THINK. OKAY GIVE YOU ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OKAY I AM. I PERPLEXED
BY OF THE AIR POLLUTION IN THE
MONEY CENTRAL CITY SO THE SAN
FRANCISCO OKAY SO THEY WANT ME
TO PROVE CONGESTION PRICING
MECHANISM AS ALTERNATIVE WELL
SECOND WORK CAMINO AYE AYE AYE
WHO ARE WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE
THEY'RE CAUSING ALL THE
CONGESTION WHERE THE COMING
FROM- WHAT'S WHAT YOU KNOW IT'S
A LOT POLLUTION AND I'VE BEEN
TOLD BY THE FROM GOVERNMENT.
RID OF THIS POLLUTION. OF I'M
GOING TO GET PENALIZED IF I
DON'T GET A REAL GONNA HAVE
SOME CORPS WERE SOMETHING THIS
IS A HAVE TO GIVE OF THE PULL.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO IMPOSE ON
PEOPLE'S. PRIVATE INFORMATION
SO WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENS ON AT
THE READER THAT'S THAT'S AN
EXIT IS THE- IS THE- SAN
FRANCISCO ACTUALLY CONDUCTS
THEIR OWN TRAVEL SERVICE YEAH-
AND THEN THEY GET INFORMATION-
WELL WHERE PEOPLE ARE COMING
FROM AND WHERE THEY'RE GOING ON
AN INDIVIDUAL BASIS. AND THEN
THEY AGGREGATED UP BE ABLE TO
SAY WELL THIS IS WHERE THE
DEMAND IS. THEY ALSO NEED THAT
INFORMATION TO KNOW PEOPLE'S
PRICE SENSITIVITY TO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT HIS CONGESTION
PRICING GOING TO WORK THAT'S A
QUESTION OF PEOPLE'S PRICE
SENSITIVITY SO WE NEED TO KNOW
THAT IN ADVANCE OR WE COULD
PRICE TOO HIGH A PRICE TO LOW
WE CAN HAVE ALL KINDS OF.
CONSEQUENCE AS A RESULT. I ALSO
WANT TO COME DOCTOR COOLEY SHE
STUDY THIS. YES THANK YOU OR
FROM A RESEARCH HAS GOING I DO
I LIVE IN FEAR SCOTT AND WAS
BORED IN SECOND SO A COUPLE I
ACT OF KEY POINTS I'D LIKE TO
MAKE AS A FORMER RESEARCHER I
THINK THAT IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE FIRST DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF AGGREGATION SO IT'S
NOT A BINARY ISSUE OF ACT. ZIG
DISSECTOR GET- VARIOUS LEVELS
OF RADIATION AND QUEEN THAT ARE
VERY YOU BOTH FOR
TRANSPORTATION RESEARCHERS- AND
THEN THE SECOND POINT IS THAT
THERE ARE DIFFERENT SERVE
DISAGGREGATED DATA I. A
TRANSPORTATION RESEARCHER THAT
SPECIFICALLY DID TRAVEL DEMAND
MODELING SO FORECASTING THE
FUTURE OF PROBABLE USING
TRAVEL. RAISING INDEED DIE
WHICH WERE OBTAINED WITH
CONSENT OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
AND OFTEN WITH THE CONSENT OF A
SMALL SAMPLE OF THE VISUAL THAT.
INSTALL AN APP WHEN THERE'S SO
AND I WAS TRACK THEM. REST PER.
OF YOU IT FOR TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING THIS OVER COURSE OF
TIME THAT I BEEN A TRANCE. RE
IT'S ACTUALLY BECOME INCREASE
COMMON FOR OF TRAVEL DEMAND
MODELERS TO PURCHASE THE TYPE
OF DATA THAT NOW IS
INCREASINGLY SEEING A LOT OF
SCRUTINY SO CELLPHONE RACE
DATA CAN TRACK UP TO TWELVE.
MILLION PLUS AMERICANS SOME
COMPANIES CLAIM TO BE ABLE TO
SEE ALL THE CELL PHONE DATA OF
TEN PERCENT. OF THE CANS- IS
VERY VALUABLE DATA FOR
TRANSPORTATION RESEARCH HOWEVER
I WILL SAY THAT IT ALSO STILL
DOESN'T ANSWER A LOT OF THE
BASIC QUESTION. BETTER
IMPORTANT TRANSPORTATION
RESEARCH- WHAT I PRODUCED A
STUDY LOOKING AT. THE MODE
SUBSTITUTION UBER AND LEFT AND
THEN ALL SUBSEQUENTLY THE MODES
STATE USED FOR MICROBIOLOGY.
THE WAY TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION
IS TO WE ASK PEOPLE. PAPER OR
ON BOARD. WHAT ESTRACE DATA
THAT TRACK THE MOVEMENT OF
THEIR TRIP SO I THINK IT'S VERY
TO ME THE YOU CASE TO THE KEY
RE QUESTION AND THE TYPE OF
DATA THAT'S BEEN COLLECTED FOR
THAT PURPOSE AND THEN A FINAL
POINT THAT'LL MAKE IS I SERVE
ON- DIFFERENT STANDING
COMMITTEES OF THE
TRANSPORTATION RESEARCH BOARD
OF THE NATIONAL ACADEMIES I WAS
JUST AT A CONFERENCE IN
WASHINGTON DC THEIR ANNUAL
MEETING WHERE BIKESHARE
RESEARCHERS WERE PRESENTING
WORK. ON AND- ANALYSIS KEY
RESEARCH QUESTIONS RELATED TO
MICROBIOLOGY THEY SPENT
PROBABLY SOMEWHERE ON THE ORDER
OF TWELVE MONTHS COLLECTING
HARVESTING AND CLEAN DATA
SOURCES THAT ARE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE TO PRODUCE ANALYSIS
IS THE AUTOMATED ON A PLATFORM
THAT CAN BE USED SENATE MINUTES
I THINK COLLEGES INCREASE THE
THERE IS MORE ABOUT THE PRIVATE
SECTOR THAT ISN'T BEING MADE
AVAILABLE TO RESEARCHERS AND
THAT'S A PROBLEM THAT WE WANT
TO SOLVE AT POPULOUS AND THERE
IS TO GET THE DATA SO THAT
RESEARCH. ACT TO KEEP A CHAT
PUT UPON A ROAD OR GESTURE
THING DOES THE GET YOU TO THE
GOAL THANK YOU AIMED TO STRIVE
FOR IN A MATTER OF MY. SO THAT
IS NECESSARY TO DO GOOD
PLANNING SO YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
BUT. WE GOT SOME BIG PROBLEMS
WE HAVE A TRANSIT RIDERSHIP
GOING DOWN. AND WE DON'T WE
DON'T KNOW HOW YOU KNOW WE ARE
THE GLOBAL WARMING CRISIS SOME
PEOPLE WANT TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT. SO WE GOT OF REALLY
GOOD INFORMATION TO. TOGETHER
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND. OUR IS
OUR INFORMATION THERE WERE NOT
A REALLY EVEN LOOKING AT RIGHT
NOW THAT'S AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW.
IS THERE INFORMATION THAT WE
COULD USE RIGHT NOW THAT'S JUST
THERE THERE WERE NOT USING TO
MAKE THESE DETERMINATION I WENT
TO THE I SIT ON- VISOR
COMMITTEE OF THE- UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA- TRANSPORTATION
RESEARCH INSTITUTE. AND WE HAD
OUR MEETING LAST LAST WEEK. AND
THEY ASKED ME WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE MOST SO I SAID WE GOTTA
START WE GOT TO DO WITH THIS
CLIMATE CHANGE THING AND YOU
GUYS HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHY
WE'RE HAVING A DROP IN TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP. AND WE NEED IT NOW
WE CAN'T WE UP WE HAVE TO DO
RESEARCH. SO. THERE'S PRESSING
ISSUES IS WHAT I'M SAYING SO TO
CONNECT FOR A YES SIR JACKSON
WE HEARD BRIAN DAHLE THE WE
HAVE- CENTER RUBIO AND CENTER
DRAWS ON ON THIS YEAR- SKINNER
AND ON THIS ISSUE SO I THINK
WE'RE ALL IN AGREEMENT THAT WE
NEED TO ADD A TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT'S GOING ON THE
QUESTION IS WHAT DATA DO WE
NEED. BECAUSE THERE IS SO MUCH
DATA THAT WE COULD COLLECT AND
FRANKLY I THINK IS BEING
COLLECTED THAT ISN'T.
NECESSARILY NECESSARY TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION OF WHY ARE WE
HAVING THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
HAVING. BUT THE ABILITY TO
COLLECT DATA AND TO GET AS
GRANULAR AS KNOWING WHAT TIME
IN THE MORNING A PERSON LEAVES.
TO GO TO WORK IF THEY MAKE
STOPS ON THE WAY IF THEY MAKE
STOPS ON THE WAY BACK OR IF
THEY MEET PEOPLE IN. THANKS TO
TRULY ARE ALMOST VOYEURISTIC.
SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS TO
MISS- SIVARAMAN I DO WANT TO
SAY I FIND IT REALLY
INTERESTING APPRECIATE YOUR
CONCERN ABOUT THE PUBLIC
SECTOR- PERHAPS THIS IS A TURN
OF EVENTS FOR UBER WHICH IS NOT
NECESSARILY BEEN. THE BEST
STEWARD AND THE MOST
RESPONSIBLE- COLLECTOR OF
INFORMATION OR COMPANY BUT I'M
I'M DELIGHTED THAT DID IF AT
LEAST FROM THE SOUNDS OF IT
THERE'S BEEN A- A TURN AROUND
AS FAR AS- RECOGNIZING. THAT
WHAT IS AND IS NOT APPROPRIATE-
AND ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
REGULATION SO PART OF WHAT I
THINK WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE.
IS TO CREATE SOME REGULATION
THAT WILL GIVE US INFORMATION
THAT'S NEEDED WHICH WILL ALSO
AT THE SAME TIME TELL PEOPLE
THAT THIS INFORMATION IS BEING
COLLECTED ABOUT THEM MOST
PEOPLE GET ON A SCOOTER AND
THEY THINK THEY'RE TRUST TAKEN.
SOMEWHERE AND THAT'S THE END OF
IT BUT IN FACT ALL SORTS OF
PERSONAL DATA IS BEING
COLLECTED AND THEY DON'T EVEN
KNOW IT. SO IF YOU DO A SURVEY
YOU ASKED PEOPLE TO TELL YOU
SOMETHING THEY WILL PARTICIPATE
IF THEY KNOW AND IF THEY ARE
OKAY WITH THAT. NOW WERE
ESSENTIALLY SERVING PEOPLE AND
SURVEILLING THEM AT THE SAME
TIME SO. DO YOU HAVE ANY
SUGGESTIONS BASED UPON. MISTER
SNOW'S COMMENT WHICH I THREE
TWO WEEKS WE SHOULD WE NEED TO
NARAL WHAT IT IS WE'RE LOOKING
FOR. AND WE NEED TO GET
PERMISSION OR AT LEAST GIVE
PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
AWARE OF THIS AND MAKE CHOICE
WITH A ONE. INFORMATION IN.
THIS GROUP DID ARE BEFORE WE GO
AHEAD AND DO IT SO ANY THOUGHTS
ON THAT. DO YOU AGREE DISAGREE
WITH HOW DO WE GET TO WHAT WE
NEED TO DO FOR POLICY WILL AT
THE SAME TIME BALANCING THE
PRIVACY RIGHTS OF INDIVIDUALS
INFORMATION WE'RE TAKING.
ABSOLUTELY AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE QUESTION- I THINK
THAT- THE QUESTION OF WHAT
GOALS WE ARE TRYING TO SOLVE
AND WHAT WHAT PROBLEMS WE'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE CONCRETELY
THAT'S HAT WE EED TO
DETERMINE FIRST BECAUSE FROM
THERE WE CAN DETERMINE WHAT
DATA IS APPROPRIATE. ACTUALLY
SOLVING THOSE GOALS NOW THERE
ARE SOME GOALS- THAT CAN USE
AGGREGATED DATA AND DOCTOR
GIULIANI ROUTE WOULD BE ON A
ROCK RAN THROUGH SOME OF THOSE
BUT THERE ARE SOME THAT WILL
REQUIRE DISAGGREGATED DATA AND
WHEN IT COMES TO THOSE IT'S
RICK IT'S ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT.
THAT WOULD ALLOW USERS TO OPT
OUT OF THEIR PERSONAL DATA IF
THEY SO CHOOSE RIGHT AN EXAMPLE
THAT I TYPICALLY GIVES YOU
ACTUALLY TO SHARE YOUR TIME
LOCATE AND I IN ORDER. OVER YOU
CAN ACROSS STREET IF YOU DON'T
FEEL LIKE YOU'RE COMFORTABLE
SHARING YOUR REAL TIME. WITH
YOU CAN CROSS AND SEND A ARE.
I'M USE TO OPT OUT OF SHARE
THEIR LOOK DATA WHETHER IT'S
FOR PER ENTITY OR A PUBLIC
ENTITY IS ABSOLUTELY KEY AND
MORE BROADLY SPEAKING GIVING
USERS MORE CONTROL OVER WHAT
DATA THEY CHOOSE TO SHARE AGAIN
WITH ANY ENTITY AND THE PUBLIC
SECTOR AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR
THE NONPROFIT SPACE IS
ABSOLUTELY KEY AND SO AGAIN
FIGURING OUT THE USE CASES FOR
SOLVING THE CRITICAL GOALS MANY
OF WHICH ARE SENATOR BELL
REFERENCED FIGURING OUT
CONCRETE USE CASES AND WORKING
BACKWARDS TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IT
AS REQUIRED FOR THOSE USE CASES
IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AND
GIVING USED TOYS AND BOOKS
ABILITY. IS ALSO CRITICAL. THE
SERVER JACKSON FINISHED- YES
JUST WANTED COMMISSIONER
SANTIAGO OVERCOME AS WELL- YOU
KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN SOME
COMMENT ABOUT THE USEFULNESS OF
SURVEY DATA- I THINK SUPPORT TO
DRAW A DISTINCTION BETWEEN
DISAGGREGATED INFORMATION FROM
A SURVEY WHERE- IT'S COLLECTED
FROM PARTICULAR INDIVIDUALS
WHO'VE DECIDED TO PUT IN A
SURVEY IN DISAGGREGATED
INFORMATION THAT'S COLLECTED
FROM LITERALLY EVERY SINGLE
PERSON WHO MIGHT MAKE USE OF A
PRODUCT- THE THIS DISAGGREGATED
INFORMATION- PARTICULARIZED- IT
INDIVIDUAL INFORMATION SHOULD
NOT BE COLLECTED- IN A AND A
DRAGNET WAY OR WAY WHICH-
INCLUDES EVERY SINGLE PERSON-
AND TO KNOW A FOR ITS FOR THE
CONSENT OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING. BUT AS OF.
CENTER DOLLY. THANK YOU CO
CHAIR SO I AM SUPER EXCITED TO
BE IN THIS HEARING I HAVE. TWO
QUESTIONS MAYBE A THIRD ONE BUT
MY FIRST ONE IS HOW DOES THE-
LA DOT USE REAL TIME LOCATION
DATA. WHEN A DEVICE ON A RIDER
IS ON A TRIP. SO THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION WE DON'T GET THE
ROUTE DATA UNTIL TWENTY FOUR
HOURS AFTER THE TRIP IS DONE.
SO WHEN YOU'RE ACTUALLY ON THE
SCOOTER- THE PIECE OF
INFORMATION THAT WE MAY HAVE
WHILE YOU'RE ON THE RIDE IS
WHERE THE RIDE BEGAN. AND
THAT'S IT AND THE WAY THAT WE
USE THAT I'LL GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE- IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
VENICE WHICH WAS AN INCREDIBLY
ATTRACTIVE NEIGHBORHOOD FOR A
LOT OF SCOOTER COMPANIES TO
DEPLOY ITS NEAR THEIR
HEADQUARTERS. HIGHLY
COMPETITIVE MARKET EVERYBODY'S
TRYING TO GET MARKET. WE HAD
ABOUT THREE THOUSAND VEHICLES
DEPLOYED IN ABOUT A ONE SQUARE
MILE AREA WHICH IS AN
OVERSATURATION SO WE HAD OUR
STAFF GO OUT AND ACTUALLY
MEASURE HOW MUCH HIDE WALK AREA
IS ACTUALLY AVAILABLE FOR THE
SAFE STORAGE OF THESE THINGS.
OUT OF THE SENSIBLE RIGHT BY.
THE BILL. FOR OLDER FOR FOLKS
ARE USING THIS. AND WE HAVE
VERY RULES ABOUT HOW MANY
SCOOTERS EACH COMPANY CAN
DEPLOY BY A SPECIFIC TIME EVERY
DAY. SO WE HAVE TO GO OUT THERE
AND SPOT CHECK THAT BUT WE'RE
ABLE AND WHEN WE VERIFY THE
DATA IS LEGITIMATE AND WE SEE
THE DIPLOMA ENDS AND THE
NOTIFICATIONS ARE HAPPENING.
THEN WE CAN THAT FROM DOWNTOWN
AND WE CAN TELL COMPANIES. YOU
WERE ALLOWED TO DEPLOY FIVE
SCOOTERS ON THIS CORNER AT NINE
AM NOT SIX NOT SEVEN BUT FIVE.
AND YOU WERE COMPLAIN THAT
REGULATION AND SO NOW YOU HAVE
A TWENTY FOUR HOUR. HOLD
BILLETED TO BE IN THE VENICE
AREA AT ALL. SO I KIND OF
INFORMATION AND BEING ABLE TO
GO OUT WHEN I HAVE A VERY SMALL
TEAM TO HAVE. AN EDGE TO BE
EIGHT THOUSAND SCOOTERS THAT
CAN GO OUT. THE GET ON A
VEHICLE. AND I CAN SEE IN REAL
TIME DID THE COMPANY SEND AND
BECAME AS THE- THEY WERE. AND A
THEY DO. WHEN WE TRY ALL OF THE
DATA THAT HAVE FOR THEM. SO IT
IF IT'S REAL TIME IN ONLY DOING
IT. YOU'RE NOT DOING IT I'M- IT
IT'S- GETTING THE MEASURE FOR
MEASURE AFTER THE RIGHT. ON THE
ROUTE THE ROUTE ITSELF SO I
DON'T KNOW. IF YOU PICKED UP A
SCHOOL AT ONE LOOK. IN DROPPED
OFFPOR EL I DON'T KNOW WHY
ROUTE TOOK IN THE- OR IF STOP.
UNTIL OUR YOU OFF VEHICLE SO
WHEN THE WHEN THE VEHICLES
PARKED YOU KNOW THIS PARK THERE
THAN ANY OF YOU CAN YOU CAN
MONITOR THAT AS WELL THAT'S
RIGHT SO WE HAD FOR EXAMPLE- A
COUPLE OF EMERGENCIES WHERE WE
NEEDED TO LET COMPANIES KNOW.
HEY WE GOT A FIRE HAPPENING WE
NEED WE NEED TO MAKE THAT YOU
AS WELL ARE YOU HERE ARE
EVACUATION ROUTES- CAN SKI IF
THERE ARE. OTHER CLEAR FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS AND ALL THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS THEY ALSO HAVE
CAPS ON THE NUMBER OF VEHICLES
THAT ALLOWED TO HAPPEN SPECIFIC
NEIGHBORHOODS- AND SO WE'RE
ABLE TO SEE ON A DAY TO DAY
BASIS. ARE THERE A- TO POINT
WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO AND
THEY PAYING US THE- THE FEE FOR
THAT. OR ARE THEY NOT. I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE EXAMPLES ARE. USE CASE IS
IT. THIS TO ME SURE THE COME.
ARE HONEST WITH US ABOUT THE
DATA THEY'RE PROVIDING. RIGHT
BUT YOU KNOW THE START AND THE
STOP TIME SO THAT'S THE YOU CAN
TELL WE'RE SOMEBODY'S GOING
THEN. BUT BY THAT DATE IT
CRACKED. WELL I CAN TELL WHERE
A SCOOTER START WHERE SCOOTER
STRIP THAT UNLOCKED AND WE'RE
SCOOTER GOT RE LOCKED THAT'S
RIGHT. SO WORD REAL QUICK I
HAVE JUST A COUPLE MORE ONE AS
THE POPULOUS FOLKS FROM. DR
COOLER. YES SO DO YOU DO YOU
GET DOES LAW ENFORCEMENT ASK
YOU FOR INFORMATION. ARE WE
HAVE NEVER HAD LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASK US DIRECTLY FOR INFORMATION
BUT WE ARE AWARE OF AT LEAST
TWO CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE CITIES
THAT WERE OUR CUSTOMERS WERE
ASKED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR
SPECIFIC TRIP INFORMATION.
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA. OKAY
BECAUSE I HEARD- THE PERSON
FROM UBER SAY THAT THAT'S
PRIVATE INFORMATION IT NEEDS TO
BE DONE BY SUBPOENA. SO I AM
VERY MUCH INTERESTED IN THIS
AREA ACTUALLY I'M DOING A BILL
THIS YEAR BECAUSE THE DMV'S
ACTUALLY SELLING OUR
INFORMATION. AND I DON'T THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT- MOST OF
CALIFORNIANS WOULD AGREE WITH-
AND THEY'RE DOING IT WITHOUT A
SUBPOENA THEY'RE SELLING MY
DRIVER'S LICENSE WHAT KIND OF
VEHICLE I HAVE. AND SO I HAVE A
BILL ON THAT SO MY LAST
QUESTION AND THEN I TAKE THE
CHAIRS FOR THIS COMMITTEE I
THINK THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
CALIFORNIA'S NEED TO BE
WEIGHING IN HEAVILY ON ABOUT.
OUR RIVER. AND THE GETS. WORK
ON DRONE TOGETHER ABOUT WHAT
PEOPLE MONITORING- US WITH
THEIR DRONES AND TAKING
PICTURES IN OUR BACKYARDS. FOR
THE P. C. R. C. P. YOU SEE. IN
IN YOUR RECENT OF PROPOSED
RULEMAKING YOU STATED THAT THE
INTENT OF RELEASING INDIVIDUAL
DRIVER INFORMATION INCLUDING
NAMES AND LICENSE PLATES. DO
YOU BELIEVE THE DRIVER- PRIVACY
FROM THE PUBLIC KNOWING THEIR
WORK HABITS OR RIGHTS- TRAVEL
PATTERNS. YES ABSOLUTELY- THE
COMMISSION DOES BELIEVE IN THE
PRIVACY OF THE INDIVIDUAL I
THINK THE QUESTIONS THAT ARE
BEING RAISED IN THIS HEARING
ARE ABSOLUTELY PERTINENT. THE
PROPOSED DECISION- DOES ALLOW
FOR THE RELEASE OF INFORMATION
CONTAINED IN THE ANNUAL REPORT
HOWEVER WE STILL DO HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY WITH RESPECT TO
THE PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
FROM DIRECT AND IT PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION. AND
THE C. B. EITHER THE
CONFIDENTIAL BUSINESS
INFORMATION. THANK YOU. IF I
MAY- YEAH GO RIGHT AHEAD
LIBRARIES ON THE LAWN FORCING
QUESTION I DO THINK THAT ONE OF
THE KEY VALUES BECAUSE ONE OF
THE KEY CHALLENGES THAT I SAW
WITH MANY PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT
WERE- SEEKING TO OBTAIN
INFORMATION ABOUT UBER AND LIFT
RIDES THROUGH PARTNERSHIPS THAT
WERE LARGELY FUNDED BY THE
FEDERAL TRANSIT ADMINISTRATION
WISE KALENJIN WITH OPEN RECORDS
REQUESTS FROM THE PUBLIC MEDIA
GENERAL PUBLIC COMPETITOR. AND
THEN ALSO THE ISSUE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT- ONE PERSON FALLS
WITHIN I THINK A SPECIAL
CATEGORY AND ONE OF THE KEY
CHALLENGES WE SEEN IS THAT IN
MANY CIRCUMSTANCES OUR CUSTOMER
IS THE CITIES SO THE CITY OF
WHICH I ALSO CAN IN THE
DEPARTMENT- UNFORCED AND- GOLD.
THOSE REQUESTS BEEN IN A-
REQUEST. WE HAVE SEEN IN RICK.
FROM LAW. WELL THERE WAS
ACTUALLY A CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE
THERE WAS A HOMICIDE IN A CITY
WHERE. APPARENTLY TO SCORE TWO
YEARS WERE SEEN AT THE SCENE OF
THE CRIME AND WERE THOUGHT TO
BE THE GETAWAY VEHICLES. ARE
ACTIVE THEN ASKED THE BIKES
YOUR PLANNER SO IN OUR
CIRCUMSTANCE BECAUSE WERE
HANDLING LOTS A LOT OF SCOOTER
AND DATA IT'S ACTUALLY THE NEXT
YEAR PLANNER THAT'S BEING ASKED
BY LAW ENFORCED. AND FROM WHAT
WE CAN TELL MIKE SURE PLANNERS
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE A LOT OF
TRAINING AND HOW TO DEAL WITH
THESE PARTICULAR TYPES OF
REQUIRE. AND I THINK THAT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE KNOW
THAT IT'S OBVIOUS THAT NAMES
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER IS. IT
DRESS PERSON STATION I THINK IF
YOU'RE WHO BACK THE SENSITIVE
NATURE OF TO LOOK DATA AND SO
IT IS A CHAO SUCH FOR THAT
REASON WE ARE OF A NUMBER OF
INDUSTRY AND CITY ORGANIZED
GROUPS TO HELP DEVELOP BEST
PRACTICES AROUND HOW TO DEAL
WITH THESE TYPES OF REQUESTS.
TO MON APOLOGIZE FOR AGNES WAS
I REALLY DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT YOU ARE YOU YOU ARE A
PRIVATE OR YOUR NONPROFIT OR
WHAT WHAT ARE YOU ARE YOU
PUBLIC AGENCY BUT WHAT DO YOU
DO WE ARE PRIVATE COMPANY OUR
CUSTOMERS. ARE CITIES. SO HOW
CAN THE PUBLIC RECORDS REQUEST
CAN'T COME TO YOU FOR YOUR
PRIVATE COMPANY YOU DO YOU.
WOULD HAVE TO HAVE A SUBPOENA
FOR THAT INFORMATION CORRECT-
WITH THE CASE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WHICH HAVE BEEN
LARGELY INTERNAL REQUESTS TO
OUR CITY CUSTOMERS THE CITY
CUSTOMERS THAT WE WORK WITHIN
BOTH OF THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES DID
NOT ACTUALLY HAVE THE
DISAGGREGATED ROCKCHIP
INFORMATION WE DID. AND WE ARE
NOT AN INTERNAL REQUEST. AND SO
WE'VE CREATED ESSENTIALLY A
BUFFER FOR THE CITY THEN TO
MORE EASILY RESPOND TO THAT
REQUEST BECAUSE THEY NEVER HAD
THE RAW DISAGREED INFORMATION
TO BEGIN WITH OKAY LAST
QUESTION AND- ARE YOU. DO YOU
HAVE THE AVAILABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO SELL YOUR THE
INFORMATION YOU GATHER WE DO
NOT. HAVE THE INFORMATION WE
GATHER AND WE AGREED YOU.
BECAUSE WITH OUR CITY COUNCIL
AND ALSO WITH BILLY I. THAT
THAT IS ONLY USED FOR THE
PURPOSES OF TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING AND WEALTHY THANK YOU.
JUST HAD A QUESTION FOR MYSTERY.
THERE WERE A- STATE MADE
SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT I
THINK- QUALITY. DR CLEVELAND
ABOUT THE THREE APPROACHES AND
HOW THE CITY'S. IT'S THE IT'S
BETTER TO HAVE A THIRD PARTY
THIS IS WHAT I UNDERSTOOD TO
HAVE A THIRD PARTY RATHER THAN
A CITY DIRECTLY GET INVOLVED
AND GET THE INFORMATION THINGS
LIKE RESOURCES THEY MIGHT NOT
HAVE RESOURCES OR TAKE RISK AND
LIABILITY- HOW WOULD YOU
RESPOND. TO THAT IN TERMS OF
WHICH WOULD BE A BETTER WAY TO
GO I THINK THAT THERE'S
PROBABLY PROS AND CONS
ASSOCIATED WITH EACH APPROACH
AND FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IT'S
REALLY VALUABLE FORCE TO BE
ABLE TO. HOW LIKE TO WOULD LIKE
TO HANDLE THAT DATA FOR A CITY
LIKE LOS ANGELES YOU KNOW WE
STORE THE TUTOR DATA IN THE
SAME WAY THAT WE HANDLE THE
NAME AND ADDRESS OF EVERY
VICTIM OF DOMESTIC SINCE SANDRA
BECAUSE DELIVER THE SORT. THE
AND UNITY AND SO FOR US BEING
TO HOW DINNER TAX TO THE DATA
IT'S REALLY COLD FOR A VARIETY
RE. AND HOW A THIRD PARTY
INTERMEDIARY BETWEEN US-
DOESN'TALWAYS GIVE US THE SAME
LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE IN THE IN
THE VERACITY OF THE DATA- THAT
WE HAVE WHEN WE GET IT DIRECT
AND THE VERACITY OF THE DATA.
IS CRITICAL TO AS YOU KNOW
AGGREGATED DATA. CAN IS
ABSOLUTELY USABLE AND FINE FOR
PLANNING PURPOSES OR TO DECIDE
WHERE TO PUT A BIKE LANE OR
DECIDE. WHETHER OR NOT WE PUT A
BIKE LANE- WHETHER IT WORKED OR
NOT- BUT ONLY IF WE CAN TRUST
THAT DATA WHERE WHERE ACT IT
DATED. HARPER US IS NOW RIGHT
DELAY IN. REYES IN. AN ENFORCE
AN OF. OUR WAS RIGHT. TO
CREATE- A VALUABLE TOOLS FOR
PLANNERS TO USE IN OUR AGENCY
TO CREATE VISUALISATIONS TO BE
ABLE TO DO KIND OF AT A GLANCE
A LOOK AT YOU KNOW IF THERE'S A
PROBLEM OR WHERE THINGS ARE ARE
PILING UP FOR EXAMPLE LAST
WEEKEND. THERE WAS A SICK LIVIA
AN OPEN STREETS EVENT IN SOUTH
LA SCOOTERS ARE NOT ALLOWED ON
OPEN STREETS OFFENSE- IN LOS
ANGELES AND SO WE NEEDED. OUR
PLANNERS TO BE ABLE TO SEE OUR
ANY COMPANIES DEPLOYING ON THE
ROUTE- BECAUSE THEY HAVE MOTORS
AND THEY GO FAST AND SEGOVIA'S
WHERE LITTLE KIDS LEARN HOW TO
RIDE BIKES SO- WE'RE ABLE TO DO
THAT WORKS. THIRD PARTIES BUT
FOR US WE DON'T WE WOULD PREFER
TO HAVE DIRECT ACCESS TO THE
DATA AND AS I'M DOCTOR CLOSER
THERE ARE ALL. SIT THAT WOULD
PREFER NOT TO ADD OR WOULD.
DOCTOR WITH THE COMPANY LIKE
POPPY OR ANOTHER IN ORDER TO
SERVE THAT FUNCTION- AND CAN BE
A FINE SOLUTION FOR SMALLER SEE
AGENCIES THAT ARE MANAGING SORT
OF. LIKE THE PATIENT. I'M
SORRY. ONE MORE. IT'S JUST
KNOW. FIRST TO TELL YOU PROTECT
MYCIVIL LIBERTIES. BUT THIS IS.
A SEEMS LIKE A WERE COMING DOWN
PRETTY HARD. ON THE KIND OF IN
FOR. THAT COULD BE GATHERED IS
FOR BY UGH. THANK WHAT. IS WHY
DO YOU WHERE DO YOU ARE AND HOW
DO YOU DRAW THE- AS FAR AS WHAT
WE NEED IS COVER. THE RELIES ON
GOV. FOR MANY FOR. THEY'RE SAFE
IS. OUT A THIS PANEL OUT ON
THIS AN I HEAR COMPLAINTS ALL
THE TIME WHEN THERE'S- A- LEFT
THIS WHERE AND- SO THEY LOOK TO
GOV. WHENEVER THEE'S A CRY OR-
THE LOW THE GOVERNMENT LIKE A
YOU HAVE AG TO THE HOT IT INTO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT I NEED TO
PREVENT THE PROBLEM FROM HAVE.
SO HOW DO YOU. DRAW THE LINE
HERE AS- A PROTECT OF CIVIL.
BUT IT DETAILED. OKAY YEAH I
DID LOCATION DATA IS WAY ON THE
SIDE OF THE LINE AND THE WAY
THAT YOU DRAW THE LINE IS BY GO
THROUGH SOME OF AWFUL THAT
WE'VE HEARD TODAY HAVING A GOAL
AND ARCTIC EXACTLY WHAT THE GO
IS THE REQUIRES DETAILED IN. OR
IF IT DOESN'T WORK DETAILED
INFORMATION. A YOU DON'T HAVE
TO CALL I AM. WERE OR YOU THAT
DETAIL IN ALSO UNDER THE TECH.
TO AND UNDERSTAND HOW TO DEPLOY
IT IN IN EFFECT WAY BUT ALL. IN
THE LIMITED. TO ACHIEVE THE
GOAL THE NEED AND THEN WE'LL
YOU HAVE A GOAL. MANY THE COLOR.
OF INFORMATION THE RETURN. THE
USE THE STORES IN THE- OF ITS-
YOU ACHIEVE THE GOAL BUT YOU
DON'T DO A- ELSE AND IN THIS
CASE YOU KNOW THE REASON WHY IN
YOUR WORDS I. DOWN ON THE
SHARING OF INFORMATION WHEN
IT'S DUE TO LOCATION DATA IS
THAT OTHER HAS BEEN. I SAW A GO
AT UNIFIED BE REQUIRED THAT
LEVEL OF INDIVIDUAL. DO YOU. I
RISK AND- THAT'S THAT'S WHERE
THE OTHER SIDE OF ONE. THANK
REQUEST THANK. OF WE- ASSEMBLY
WOMAN. YOUR QUESTION. SEVEN ONE
FRIEDMAN. THANKS I AM A CO FOR
THE RIVER FROM UBER AND FORGIVE
ME I AM NOT. AS FIRST IN THE
LAWS MAYBE PEOPLE WHO SAID ON
JUDICIARY OR PRIVACY SO MY
QUESTION IS NOT ABOUT WHAT UBER
DOES WITH ITS DATA THAT'S KIND
OF A RELEVANT TO MY QUESTION
I'M WONDERING IN YOUR MIND WHAT
THE LAW WOULD ALLOW YOU TO DO
WITH THE DATA THAT YOU'RE
COLLECTING. FROM YOUR USERS. AT
I'M WONDERING WHAT YOU BELIEVE
YOUR RESTRICTIONS ARE- BECAUSE
IT OCCURS TO ME THAT EVERYTHING
THAT. THE ACLU BROUGHT UP AS
CONCERNS APPLY DIRECTLY TO YOU
YOU KNOW YOU'RE COLLECTING ALL
THIS DATA YOURSELF YOU'RE
OUTSIDE OF THE- I OF THE PUBLIC
IN TERMS OF ANY PUBLIC RECORDS
REQUESTS OUTSIDE ANY
TRANSPARENCY. YOU HAVE A AN
AMOUNT OF FREEDOM TO DO WITH
THE INFORMATION AS YOU WISH AND
EVEN THOUGH PEOPLE ARE OPTING
IN TO USE YOUR DEVICES. THEY
MAY OR MAY NOT UNDERSTAND THE
EXTENT OF WHAT CAN BE DONE WITH
THE DATA THE SAME WAY. THAT
THEY MAY NOT UNDERSTAND WHAT
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT OR ANY
PUBLIC AGENCY COULD DO ANTI I
WOULD ARGUE THAT THIS STATION
HAVING THAT SEEMS TO BE READING
GOVERNMENT. DID THAN ITS FOR
INTO IS A. BROUGHT THERE SHOULD
BE A- THAT A OF. YOU KNOW YOU
WE ALLOW THE COLLECTION IN THE
STE OF DATA OR DON'T GIVEN THE
COMPANIES THAT OWN THE TECH BY
NOW HAVE TO KNOW A LOT OF IN
ABOUT USER I DON'T KNOW THAT
WOULD BE KIND OF PHYLLIS ARE
LEGALLY DIFFERENT THAN WHAT A
WHY IT MIGHT WANT TO ALSO UNDER
I AM I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE
SOME LIMITS TO THE- BUT I'M-
UBER WHERE FEEL THAT YOUR KIND
OF OWNERS OR EXPLOIT. OF THE
DAY IT COLLECTS U. N.'S AN
ARTIST GIVE AN EXAM. YOU MIGHT
VERY WELL. COME TO THE SAME.
ABOUT USER PRESS. BY WAY OF
WHERE THEY'RE STOPPING ALONG
THE ROUTE. AND I'M WONDERING IF
NOT THAT WHETHER YOU WOULD DO
THIS BUT WHETHER YOU COULD IF
YOU CHOSE. MARKET PRODUCTS TO
THOSE USERS BASED ON WHETHER
STOPPING ALONG THE WAY- IF YOU
BELIEVE THAT YOU. THE LEGAL
ABILITY TO COLLECTED TO START
BUILDING PROFILES OF THEIR
CONSUMER PREFERENCES UP THEIR
TRAVEL HABITS- EVEN IF IT'S A-
GATED DATA BASED ON ZIP CODE.
SO I'M WONDERING NOW WHAT YOU
DO DO BUT WHAT YOU BELIEVE
LEGALLY YOU WOULD BE ENTITLED
TO DO WITH THE DATA THAT YOU'RE
COLLECTING. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I THINK ONE KEY
DIFFERENCE IS THAT WE ARE
REGULATED BY PRIVACY LAWS NOW
WHETHER THAT CC PA- CCPA
APPLIES TO ONLY PRIVATE SECTOR
BODIES AND THAT'S- QUITE A
DISTINCTION FROM A LAW LIKE
JEEP. FOR EXAMPLE IN THE U.
THAT APPLIES TO BOTH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND PUBLIC
SECTOR ENTITIES I THINK A LAW
LIKE THAT IS USEFUL BECAUSE- IT
ACTUALLY UNLOCKS DATA SHARING
BETWEEN THE PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
SECTORS IF WE FEEL THAT. OUR
DATA IS BEING PROTECTED NO
MATTER WHERE IT'S ORIGINATING
AND WHERE IT'S LANDING- THAN
THAT UNLOCKS A LOT OF DATA
SHARING THAT COULD BE HELPFUL
IN THE UNITED STATES BUT I BUT
AGAIN I THINK THE KEY DISTINCT.
AND IS THAT THE CZ A. N. OPERA.
A FORTHCOMING PRICE LAW MY TO
BE USED APPLET TO THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AND I THINK THAT. WE
HAVE REAL LEGAL LIABILITY. WE
MISSED YOU OR I SHOULD ARE THE
BRIDGE. NAPA I THINK THAT IN
GENERAL THERE'S AT THEIR A
SHORTCUT PRIVACY IN THE U.
STATES. TO THIS. INTO WE HAVE
OUR OWN. PRINCIPLES THAT WE
HOLD IS FOR ANY OF OUR- RECALL.
THAT THERE BE A FAIR
INFORMATION. PRINCIPLE SOME
THOSE SUPPOSING. CAN CAN TO
KNOW IT ON NOT ASKING WHAT YOU
DO. I GONNA PUT ASIDE FOR A
MINUTE. ALL OF YOUR INTERNAL.
AND WERE YOU ABLE. YOU DO. THIS
YOUR- COMPANY. TECH YOUR CUST.
CUSTOMER I WERE BRENT MY MICRO
MOBILITY DEVICE. PUTTING ASIDE
ANY SHARING OF DATA WHAT WHAT
WHAT ARE THE LIMITS OF WHAT I
AS THAT COMPANY COULD DO WITH
THAT DATA COULD I DIRECT
MARKET. COULD I. GIVE YOU A
LONER OFFER YOU A LOAN BASED ON
WHAT I THINK YOU'RE PURCHASING
PROTECT WAS BASED ON WHAT
RESTAURANTS YOU'RE ATING AT
WHAT COULD I WHERE DO YOU THINK
THE LEGAL LIMIT IS A- BAD IDEA
TO BE IS. WHAT WE CAN DO IS
WHAT WE CAN OKAY TO USERS AND
THAT'S REQUIRED B THE LAW. HI
PURPOSE LIMITATION IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND WHAT I
MEAN BY THAT IS WE CAN ONLY USE
DATA FOR THE REASON IT WAS
COLLECTED IN THE FIRST PLACE IF
WE COLLECT YOUR LOCATION DATA
IN ORDER TO SEND YOU A CALL
OUR- TRANSPORT YOU. I NEED TO
BE IN THAT. PATIENT DATA HAS.
FOR IF. IN THE EXAMPLE PROVIDED
WE WANT TO PROVIDE YOU KNOW WE
WANT TO PROMOTE SOME SORT OF
PRODUCT ON WHERE YOU'RE- WELL
WE BETTER. YOU IF YOU ARE ABLE
WITHOUT USING YOUR DATA FOR
THAT REASON AND IF YOU'RE NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH IT THEN WE
BETTER PROVIDE AN OPT OUT FOR
IT. AND YOU CALL THE DATA EVEN
IF YOU'RE NOT USING IT. FOR ANY
PURPOSE. RIGHT BASED ON DATA
MINIMIZATION AND PURPOSE
LIMITATION PRINCIPLES AND THOSE
INCLUDED IN THE CITY PA NOW IF
WE DON'T HAVE A CONCRETE USE
CASE THAT WE CAN COMMUNICATE TO
OUR USERS. THE NOTE WE CAN'T
COLLECT THAT. THAT'S HELPFUL
THANK YOU JACKSON- I BELIEVE
WE'RE FINISHED WITH THIS PANEL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR VERY MUCH
AND WE'LL MOVE ON SENATOR
JACKSON'S WILL CONVENE THE NEXT
POWER. OBVIOUSLY THERE'S MUCH
MORE WE COULD TALK ABOUT AND-
PERHAPS WE WILL AT SOME POINT-
BUT NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
OUR SECOND PANEL- THIS IS OUR
FINAL PANEL WE'RE GOING TO
DRILL INTO VARIOUS PERSPECTIVES
ON PRIVACY AND WHAT CAN BE DONE
TO ENSURE. THAT ANY INFORMATION
THAT YOU SHARE WITH RESPECT TO
SHARED MOBILITY DEVICE. IS DONE
WITH THE APPROPRIATE GUARD
RAILS AND IS LIMITED TO ONLY
THAT INFORMATION THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY AS WAS
JUST ARTICULATED- BY MISS OF
OUR OWN OF UBER- THAT IS
CERTAINLY THE GOAL OF CCPA.
WILL HEAR A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT HOW THAT'LL WORK AND SO
WITH THAT WE HAVE DOCTOR
MATTHEW BISHOP. JOINING US
DOCTOR BISHOP IS TAKE A
PROFESSOR OF COMPUTER SCIENCE
AND THE CO DIRECTOR. OF THE
COMPUTER SECURITY LABORATORY AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT
DAVIS. AND WE HAVE WITH US
MARIE CO KOTANI WHO IS THE
DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL IN
THE OFFICE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL HERE IN THE CAPITAL AND
I BELIEVE WE WERE JUST HANDED A
LETTER THAT WAS. WRITTEN THAT-
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREES WITH HER
ANALYSIS ON- OF WHAT. HEALTH
THE EXPERTS A PROVIDE TWO DOZEN
PROVIDE PERHAPS WE CAN HEAR HER
TALK A LITTLE ABOUT THAT WE
ALSO HAVE WITH US RAMS SYSTEM-
A DO WHO IS VICE CHAIR OF THE
OPEN MOBILITY FOUNDATION I HOPE
THAT I PRONOUNCE THAT CORRECTLY
THANK YOU SIR AND JENNIFER
DOLE- DONLIN WHY IT TOO IS THE
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING MANAGER
FOR THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO GOOD
AFTERNOON. AND DAVID ALISON
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF DATA
FOR BIRD AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST
JAMIE LEE WILLIAMS A STAFF
ATTORNEY FOR THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION THANK YOU
ALL FOR COMING AND SHARING YOUR
INSIGHTS WE ARE RUNNING A
LITTLE OVER SO I'M GONNA TRY
TO. HAMMER YOU DOWN AFTER FIVE
MINUTES AND WILL- HOPE YOU HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS FOR YOU AT THE
END OF THE PANEL SO WITH THAT-
DOCTOR MATTHEW BISHOP THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE
TODAY- AS YOU'VE HEARD DATA
NEEDS TO BE RELEASED FOR
ANALYSIS BY OTHERS. AND IF YOU
CAN CONTROL WHO HAS ACCESS TO
IT THEN YOU CAN TAKE DR JOHN IS
APPROACHING USE- CYBER SECURITY
CONTROLS. TO BLOCK THE TWO ARE
PROTECTED. BUT IF YOU CAN'T
CONTROL ACCESS OR IF YOU HAVE
REASON TO BELIEVE THAT THE
ACCESS CONTROLS WON'T WORK-
THEN YOU NEED TO USE DATA
ANONYMOUS. SOMETIMES CALLED THE
IDENTIFICATION OF SENSATION.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS IS THAT
OFTEN INTERFERES WITH THE
UTILITYOF THE USEFULNESS OF
THE DATA AND SO YOU HAVE TO
BALANCE THE NEED FOR THE DATA
WITH THE EFFECT IT HAS ON
RELEASING IT MIGHT HAVE ON BOTH
THE OWNER OF THE DATA IN THE
SUBJECT OF THE DATA AND HERE'S
AN EXAMPLE AMERICA ONLINE AT
ONE POINT RELEASED THREE MONTHS
OF SEARCH RECORDS. AND THE VERY
CAREFULLY ANONYMOUS THEM. IT
WAS UP FOR THREE DAYS. DURING
THAT TIME NEW YORK TIMES
REPORTERS WERE ABLE TWENTY
IDENTIFY ONE OF THE USERS AND
THE VALIDATED THIS BY GOING TO
THE LADY AND TALKING TORRENT
SHOWING HER TO SEARCH RECORDS
AND SHE SAID YES THOSE ARE MINE.
SO THERE TWO POINTS FROM THIS
THE FIRST ONE IS THAT
ADVERSARIES CAN USE DATA THAT'S
NOT PART OF WHAT YOU RELEASE.
THE ANONYMIZE THE DATA YOU DO
RELEASE. AND THE SECOND PART IS
A LITTLE BIT MORE INTERESTING
AND WORRISOME NAMELY THAT. EVER
SINCE THE PEOPLE WHO WERE DOING
THE DENOMINATION MAY DRAW
INCORRECT CONCLUSIONS FROM THE
DATA FOR EXAMPLE THE REPORTERS
FROM THE TIMES. I DREW THE
CONCLUSION THAT THIS LADY HAD A
LOT OF MEDICAL PROBLEMS. TURNED
OUT SHE DIDN'T SHE WAS A NURSE
WHO RETIRED NURSE WHO WAS
SEARCHING THE INTERNET FOR HELP
FOR. YOUR FRIEND. THE YOU HEARD
WHAT TIME. TRANSFER DATA
INCLUDE. AND ALSO- EXAMPLES OF
ITS UTILITY FOR EXAMPLE HOW
OFTEN VEHICLES USED HOW TRAFFIC
PATTERNS WORK THINGS LIKE THAT.
SO TO ANONYMIZE THE DATA
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO SUPPRESS THE NAME OF THE
PERSON BUT YOU ALSO IS POINTED
OUT HAVE TO SUPPRESS ITS
RELATIONSHIP WITH OTHER PARTS
OF THE DATA. THAT FOR EXAMPLE
FOR A PICK UP LOCATION AND TIME
OR DROP OFF LOCATION TIME IF I
CAN CORRELATE THE TWO OF
ESPECIALLY FOR IN THE PAST AND
MAY BE ABLE TO GROW WITH THAT
PERSON LEAVES FOR WHERE THAT
PERSON WORKS. IF THIS THING
UNIQUE ABOUT THE RECORD AS WELL
USE THAT. AND ALSO AS WAS
POINTED OUT ON THESE
ASSOCIATIONS MAY NOT BE OBVIOUS
OF FOR EXAMPLE- MASSACHUSETTS A
FEW YEARS BACK RELEASED HEAVILY
ANONYMIZED RECORDS MEDICAL DATA
AMPLE TIME TO SWING HERE
RESEARCHER AT HARVARD WAS ABLE
TO IDENTIFY THE RECORD
BELONGING TO THE GOVERNOR. AND
THE REASON SHE WAS IT. WAS
BECAUSE SHE MATCH THE ZIP CODE
CHEN HIS GENDER AND THE DATE OF
BIRTH WITH THE RECORDS AND IT
TURNED OUT HE WAS THE ONLY ONE
QUICK THOSE THREE QUALITIES. IN
FACT FROM THOSE THREE YOU CAN
IDENTIFY 87% OF THE HOUSEHOLDS
IN THE US ACCORDING TO A TINY
SWEENEY STANFORD SAYS NO IT'S
ONLY 63% IS ANOTHER X. EVEN THE
SO YOU CAN USE WHAT'S CALLED
PEOPLE EARNING YOUR ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE TO FIND A LOT OF
THESE NON OBVIOUS
RELATIONSHIPS. ON NOW ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF DATA WHICH
APPARENTLY IS SEPARATE. AND CAN
BE ANONYMIZED BUT WHEN YOU PUT
THEM TOGETHER YOU OF TROUBLE
CAME OUT OF OHIO- IN OHIO THEY
PUT AN ELECTION THEY HAVE POLL
BOOKS WHERE THEY RECORD THE
NAME OF THE PERSON IN THE TIME
THAT. CAME INTO THE POLICE
STATION. AT THIS TIME THEY WERE
USING ELECTRONIC VOTING
MACHINES WHICH PRINT AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE CAST BALLOTS A
TIME STAMP SAYING ONE IT WAS
CAST. NOW IN OHIO AND I'M SORRY
I DON'T KNOW THE LEAL TERM BUT
IN OHIO BOTH OF THOSE AT THIS
TIME WITH. I THINK PUBLIC
RECORD. WHEN HIS RESEARCHERS
WERE ABLE TO GET BOTH OF THEM.
ONE OF THEM COULD NOT BE THE
AMOUNT OF MICE. SEPARATELY
PUTTING TOGETHER MATCH AT THE
TIME STAMPS AND THEY WERE ABLE
TO. FIGURE OUT HOW AN AWFUL LOT
OF PEOPLE VOTED. ARE YOU ALSO
NEED TO- CONSIDER. THAT IF THE
DATE IS HELD BY MULTIPLE
GROUPS. AND THE GROUP'S
ANONYMIZE THE DATA AND THEN
RELEASE IT. CAN THE DATA BE PUT
TOGETHER AND THE COMBINATION OF
THE DATA STOP THE DATA SETS ON
BE DO NOT BE DEBT. THE AMOUNT
CIVIL SORRY. ALSO IF YOU RECENT
DATA NOW AND LATER ON SOME
OTHER DATA COMES OUT. THOSE TWO
SETS SEPARATELY YOU MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO BE ANONYMIZED THEM PUT
THEM TOGETHER AND YOU MAY BE
ABLE TO DO SO YOU HAVE TO LOOK
THE FUTURE AND WHAT OTHER
PEOPLE ARE DOING AS WELL AS
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO-
THEY'RE BASICALLY THREE WAYS TO
AND ON MY STATE OF THE FIRST
ONES TO GENERALIZE IT THAT'S
WHAT HIP BUT DOES FOR ZIP
CODES- WITH HIPPIE YOU HAVE TO
SUPPRESS THE LAST. DIGIT ZIP
CODE AND IF THE THREE DIGIT
FATHER THREE DIGIT PREFIX HAS
LESS THAN TWENTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN THAT AREA. THE WHOLE
THING. BUT YOU GENERALIZING ON
THOSE NUMBERS. YOU ALSO PUT
DATA THIS IS GETTING. AND SO
YOU MIGHT FOR. ANDERSON SOME
RANDOM NUMBER TWO MIRACLE DATA.
THE WITH THAT IS THATYOU HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ANONYMIZED DATA THE ONE THAT'S-
PER TERM IT'S JUST AS USEFUL AS
THE D. ANONYMOUS THE REGULAR ON
AND OUT OF MY STATE. AND THE
THIRD MESSAGES AGGREGATION
THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE MORE
INTERESTED IN THE STATE'S SIX
OF THE DATA SO YOU PUT
TOGETHER. AND RELEASE THE OILS
THE CENSUS BUREAU DOES A LOT OF
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF WORK IN
THAT AREA. SO WHAT WE DO WELL
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF THINGS
PEOPLE YOU HAVE TO BE AWARE OF.
FIRST YOU HAVE TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE INFORMATION ITS
EXTERNAL. TO THE DAILY OR NOT
I'M ICING. AND THIS USED TO BE
VERY EASY BECAUSE BEFORE THE
INTERNET AND THE WEB. YOU HAD
TO TRAVEL TO PLACES TO GET THIS
DATA. NOW IT'S OFTEN ON THE WEB
AND YOU CAN PULL IT DOWN. AND
IT ALSO ANONYMIZING
SUCCESSFULLY ALSO DEPENDS UPON
WHAT. MAKE WHAT MAY BE A MUST
BE KEPT SECRET NOW BUT ALSO IN
THE FUTURE. BECAUSE THE DATA
MAY NEED TO BE PRESERVED THE
ANONYMITY OF THE DATA MAY BE
PRESERVED FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
YOU ALSO NEED TO WORRY ABOUT
THE THREATS BOTH ONCE IT WOULD
COMPROMISE THE HOLDER OF THE
DATA AND ALSO THE SUBJECT. AND
SOMETIMES PEOPLE WHO'D BE
ANONYMIZED DATA RE INTERESTED
IN THINGS OTHER THAN WHAT YOU
THINK THEY MIGHT BE OUR OTHER
THAN WHAT YOU'RE INTERESTED IN.
SO I GUESS TO SUM UP. THEIR TWO
POINTS YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THE TRADE OFF BETWEEN PRIVACY
AND UTILITY THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL NOT JUST FROM THE
SCIENTIFIC AND ENGINEERING
VIEWPOINT BUT ALSO FROM THE
SOCIAL POLITICAL AND- ECONOMIC
AND GOVERNMENTAL POINT OF VIEW.
AND THE OTHER THING TOO IS-
DESIGN PRIVACY IN AT THE
BEGINNING DON'T TRY TO EDIT IT
THE AFTERWARDS- THAT'S TRUE IS
IT NOT JUST FOR PRIVACY BUT FOR
SECURITY IN GENERAL. A NUMBER
OF SYSTEMS THAT HAVE BEEN
BROKEN. WERE HAD QUITE A BIT OF
SECURITY BUT BECAUSE IT WAS
ADDED AFTERWARDS PEOPLE FOUND
FOSTER. I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING QUESTIONS THINKING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- INTO THAT
WAS A LITTLE LONGER THAN FIVE
MINUTES BUT VERY HELPFUL MUCH
APPRECIATED. OUR NEXT SPEAKER-
IN ADDITION FEEL BAD I PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T MENTION THAT BUT
THANK YOU FOR THE THAT AIM FOR
INTERESTING INFORMATION WE HAVE
NOW. OUR NEXT SPEAKER IS- RICO
COULD CONNIE. OF THE DEPUTY
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL FOR THE
OFFICE OF OUR LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL GOOD AFTERNOON
AFTERNOON SO TODAY WE'VE BEEN
ASKED TWO QUESTIONS RELATING TO
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATIONS PRIVACY ACT
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CAL THAT
BOOK. THE FIRST IS WHETHER
CALIPERS CHECKS THE DEPARTMENT
OF THE CITY ORCOUNTY FROM
IMPOSING A REAL TIME DATA
SHARING PERMITTING REQUIREMENT
ON ADULT DISABILITY PROVIDER
OFFER CONTEXT HELLO BUT
PROHIBITS THE GOVERNMENT ENTITY
FROM ACQUIRING A- NATION A
THROUGH THE PACIFIC MEANS
WITHOUT A WIRE WARRANTS WIRETAP
ORDERS OTHER OUT CLICK
APPLICABLES EXCEPTION. SO THE
BUT IT MEANS THAT THE
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATION
INFORMATION FOR SAYS GOVERNMENT
ENTITY CAN'T COMPEL THE
PRODUCTION OF IRAQ THIS TO THAT
INFORMATION FROM A SERVICE
PROVIDER COLLECTS WAS OTHER TO
PUT PROVISIONS THOSE CONCERNS
ELECTRONIC DEVICE INFORMATION.
ON WHICH COLLECTED DEFINES AS
INFORMATION THAT STORED ON OR
GENERATED THROUGH THE OPERATION
OF AN ELECTRONIC DEVICE WHICH
WOULD INCLUDE DEVICES SUCH AS
THE U. BUT THESE CRITTERS THAT
ARE OFFERED BY DAHLE
INSTABILITY PROVIDERS KELEFA
PROHIBITS A GOVERNMENT ENTITY
FROM EITHER COMPELLING THE OF
THIS TO DO THE AND MAY. FROM
OTHER THAN THE THAT'S RATHER.
AT THE PROHIBITS GOT ENTITIES.
MEN AND XIN BY TO BE IN. THE
DEVICE BIKE A SCOOTER IT'S
UNLESS BERMAN AND EIGHTY HAS
EITHER THE- THIS CONSENTS OF
THE AUTHOR US SIR OR IS THE
BEEN LOS OR STOLEN IT HAS THE
SPECIFIC CONSENT OF. THE OWNER
OF THE DEVICE. ANNE'S ALL OF
THESE THREE PROVISIONS THEY
APPLY TO ACTION TAKEN BY
GOVERNMENT ENTITY SO RETURNING
BACK TO THE QUESTION HAND WHICH
IS WHETHER CAL UP OR STRICT
APARTMENT OF A CITY OR COUNTY
FROM IMPOSING. A REAL TIME TO
GET ENSURING BERMAN
REQUIREMENTS. THE FIRST
QUESTION IS OKAY WITH AS A
DEPARTMENT OF A CITY OR COUNTY
CONSTITUTE A GOVERNMENT ENTITY
FOR THE PURPOSES OF CAL THAT
BUT TO BEGIN WITH AND IN OUR
OPINION IT DOES. CALIBRATE
BROADLY DEFINED GOVERNMENT
ENTITY AS EIGHT DEPARTMENT OR
AGENCY OF THE STATE OR
SUBDIVISION OF THE STATE AND
THAT WOULD INCLUDE CITIES AND
COUNTIES SORT ALSO INCLUDES
DEPARTMENTS THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES. OKAY MOVING ON TO
WHAT'S THE SECOND PART OF THE
QUESTION OF WHICH IS OF.
IMPOSING A REAL TIME DATA
SHARING PERMITTING
REQUIREMENTS. WHAT THE SECOND
QUESTION SECOND PART OF THE
QUESTION IS HE DOES THAT FALL
WITHIN ANY OF THE MEANS OF
COLLECTING. ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATIONS ELECTRONIC
INFORMATION THAT'S PROHIBITED
BY CAL APPLE AND ARGUED DOES IT
VIOLATES THAT SECOND
PROHIBITION WOULD SAYS
GOVERNMENT ENTITY YOU CAN'T.
COMPEL THE PRODUCTION OF OR
ACCESS TO ELECTRONIC DEVICE
INFORMATION FROM ANYONE
DECIDES. THE AUTHORIZES US OR
LET OF ICE AND IT'S ARGUE THAT.
WHEN SOMEONE RENTS ONE OF THESE
SURE IT'S GOOD AS OUR SHARED
BIKES THERE THE AUTHORIZED
POSSESSOR OF THAT SURE IT'S
GOOD OR THAT BIKE. DURING THE
PERIOD OF THAT RENTAL SO TO THE
EXTENT. THAT THE GOVERNMENT
IDEAS REQUIRING FOR VERSION OF
THAT DATA FROM THE- DOCK
DISABILITY PROVIDER AND NOT THE
WRITER DURING THE CURATOR THAT
RENTAL. THAT WOULD IMPLICATE
CALL APPLE. SO IN OTHER WORDS
IT'S ARGUE THAT. STRICT OTHER
FORM OF A CITY OR FROM IMPOSING
A REAL TIME DATA SHARING. MARK
PERMITTING. ON ADULT LIST WILL
YOU PROVIDER. NEXT QUESTION
WHERE ON IS WHETHER IT COLLECT.
IT PROTECTS INFORMATION THAT'S
BEEN THAT'S PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
BUT IT'S BEEN DE IDENTIFIED OR
IS AN AGGREGATED. AND IT'S
ARGUE THAT ALTHOUGH CALIPER
PROTECTS ELECTRONIC INFORMATION
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER IT'S
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE OR DE
AGGREGATED. AND WE'RE NOT AS
TECHNICALLY SAVVY AS DOCTOR
BISHOP SO I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
AT THE SENATE ACT NOT. OF ITS
NEST RICHARDS- ALTHOUGH IT FOR
TAX INFORMATION REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER IT'S BEEN. IT'S PUBLIC
YOU WILL PUBLICLY AVAILABLE OR
GET IN A FIGHT IT. ONLY
PROTECTS AGGREGATED DATA TO THE
EXTENT THAT REVEALING THAT THE
IT WOULD ALSO REVEAL ELECTRONIC
INFORMATION THAT OTHERWISE
PROTECTED BY CAL APPLE. THIS IS
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT SEEING
ANYTHING IN THE TAXES COLLECTED
THAT DISTINGUISHES ON THE BASIS
OF PUBLIC AVAILABILITY OR A
PERSONAL IDENTIFICATION. AND
ALSO. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
AGGREGATED DATA WERE TALKING
ABOUT DATA THAT'S CREATED USING
LIKE THAT UNDERLYING DATA WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SUMMARIES OF DATA
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. IS
COMPILED TO OTHER FORMS SO THAT
WE BELIEVE THAT CAL ACT.
PROTECTS THE UNDERLING THE
UNDERLYING DATA DOESN'T
NECESSARILY PROTECT. OTHER
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN DONE WITH
THAT DATA. AND ALL THE HAVE YOU
TAKE A QUICK LATER. THANK YOU
VERY. OUR NEXT US. IS RAY
SYSTEM A DO. AND HE'S THE VICE
CHAIR OF OPEN MOBILITY
FOUNDATION GOOD AFTERNOON
AFTERNOON CHAIRS- IN JUST TO DO
A DIVISION MANAGER OF PLANNING
POLICY SUSTAINABILITY FOR THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE AND THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE OPEN MOBILITY
FOUNDATION I THINK BOTH ROLES
ARE IMPORTANT HERE. SO WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IN THE ROADWAY IS
CHANGING GREATLY. RIGHT WE'RE
SEEING MORE AND MORE SERVICES
BEING PROVIDED IN THE RIGHT OF
WAY. ON THAT ARE BEING RUN BY
PRIVATE INTELLIGENCE RIGHT BY
DATA SETS A BY ALGORITHMS AND
BY WAYS AND MEANS THAT HAVE-
THAT ARE BECOMING MORE AND MORE
COMPLEX THAN THAT CITIES DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO AT THE MOMENT.
THE PUBLIC NEEDS TOOLS TO BE
ABLE TO STEP INTO THE SPACE AND
BE PART OF GOVERNANCE OF THESE.
DEVICES OF THESE SERVICES.
OTHERWISE WE WILL LOSE THE
ABILITY. TO CONTINUE TO MANAGE
THE RIGHT OF WAY ALL RIGHT. A
LOT OF THIS DISCUSSION FEELS
LIKE A PUBLIC VERSUS PRIVATE
DISCUSSION. AND IT'S NOT THIS
IS A DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW WE AS
A SOCIETY ARE GOING TO STEP
TOGETHER FORD INTO THESE NEW
TOOLS AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO
MANAGE THE PUBLIC GOOD AND
ALLOW BUSINESSES TO THRIVE. AND
WE AT THE OPEN MOBILITY
FOUNDATION ARE SETTING
OURSELVES UP TO. BE THE FORUM
IN WHICH THOSE DISCUSSIONS
HAPPEN AND A FULL OPEN WAY.
THERE'S ACRIMONY AND THERE'S A
LOT OF CONTENTION AROUND THIS.
BUT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT EVEN ONE
OF OUR MOST STRIDENT CRITICS IS
ACTUALLY ONE OF OUR MOST ACTIVE
CONTRIBUTORS. UBER'S JUMP IS
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE MOST ACTIVE
CONTRIBUTORS TO OUR ACTUAL CODE
BASE I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. THE CAMPUS.
THE WAY THAT THE RIGHT OF WAY
HAS BEEN MANAGED- FOR AS LONG
AS WE'VE KIND OF KNOWN WRITER
STOP SIGN STREET LIGHTS GOT A
LITTLE MORE CUTS IF INSTIGATED
THESE WORKS WHEN WE'RE TRYING
TO MANAGE INDIVIDUALS AND
UNSOPHISTICATED BUSINESSES.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH ANYMORE. WE NEED NEW
TOOLS- THAT WORK DIRECTLY WITH
THE SYSTEMS THAT ARE
CONTROLLING DEVICES. A STOP
SIGN IS VISUAL ITEM THE PERSON
OR I A OUR SYSTEM IS
CONTROLLING WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH THAT CAN IMMEDIATELY READ
THAT AND OPERATE WITHOUT. WE
NEED NEW TOOLS AS THE PUBLIC
THAT WORK TOGETHER WITH THE
BUSINESS SYSTEMS. SO THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO OPERATE TOGETHER.
AND TO THAT A FUNDAMENTAL CITY
LEVEL THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
INTERESTED IN. LET'S SEE WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
EXPRESS PUBLIC- THE PUBLIC GOOD
IN THE WAYS THAT ALGORITHMS CAN
CONSUME. SO THAT THE ARGUMENTS
ABOUT THE PATCHWORK OF FIVE
REGULATIONS STARTS FALLING AWAY.
IT'S OKAY IF THERE'S DIFFERENT
REGULATIONS IF WE ARE ABLE TO
SAY IN EACH JURISDICTION THIS
IS WHAT IT IS AND THOSE SYSTEMS
CAN CLEANLY AND EASILY OPERATE
WITHIN THE. THIS NEW LANGUAGE
AND DATA SPECIFICATION- FOR
PUBLIC FOR THE PUBLIC GOOD.
FIRST SORRY. WE NEED TO CREATE
THIS DIGITAL COMMONS- OF NEW
RULES IN A NEW LANGUAGE- TO
EXPRESS THIS AND BE ABLE TO
ALLOW- PRIVATE COMPANIES TO
WORK WITH IT. OVER TIME AND WE
NEED TO ALLOW THIS TO HAPPEN-
AS THE CONVERSATION PROGRESSES.
I HAVE ONE PERSON ON MY TEAM
WHO MANAGES SIX THOUSAND
SCOOTERS. I ONLY EXPECT THAT
NUMBER TO INCREASE. I NEED TO
KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THOSE DEVICES SO THAT I CAN
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE IN
WHEELCHAIRS CAN GET THROUGH MY
CITY. SO I CAN MAKE SURE. THAT
WE ARE- THAT THE- CUT COMPANIES
ARE FOLLOWING OUR EQUITY
CONSIDERATION RULES. RIGHT AND
ONE PERSON HAS TO DO THIS IF I
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO DATA
VERIFIABLE INDIVIDUAL DEVICE
DATA NOT PERSONAL DATA. WE
CAN'T DO THIS. TO THE OPEN
ABILITY FOUNDATION- HAS BEEN
SET ITSELF UP AS A FORM TO
PROGRESS THE STATE OF PRACTICE.
WE DON'T PROFESS TO KNOW THE
ANSWERS BUT WE DO PROFESSED TO
KNOW THAT WE NEED TO FIND THEM
TOGETHER WE UNDERSTAND THAT
PRIVACY IS A CENTRAL COMPONENT
FOR SUCCESS ON ALL SIDES AND AS
SUCH- IN OUR OPENING ACTIONS
FOR OUR FOUNDATION WE SET UP A
PRIVACY COMMITTEE THAT PRIVACY
COMMITTEE- WAS SPECIFICALLY SET
UP TO ADVISE THE FOUNDATION ON
PRINCIPLES AND PRACTICES THAT
ENSURE THE SECURE HANDLING A
MOBILITY DATA. THAT IS ONE OF
OUR MOST ACTIVE COMMITTEES- AND
IS OPEN TO ALL THAT WANT TO
ENGAGE. MOST OF OUR COMMITTEES
ARE LITTLE MORE CLOSE JUST A
MEMBERSHIP BUT THIS ONE
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF THE-
THAT WEIGHT. AND IMPORTANCE OF
THIS- PRICE OF THIS ITEM WE SET
ALL ANYBODY NO AS A MATTER
WHAT. WE INVITE YOU AND YOUR
STAFF TO JOIN IF THAT SO SUITS
YOU THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
COMPLEX FIELD. WE DON'T KNOW
ENOUGH. TO START SAYING LET'S
START PUTTING DOORS DOWN AROUND
THIS YET WE KNOW IT'S
INCREDIBLY SENSITIVE IMPORTANT.
BUT THERE ARE TOO MANY STRIDENT
VOICES ON THAT ARE TRYING TO
GET US TO DO VERY PARTICULAR
THINGS. AND CLAIMING A LOT OF-
FIVE FEAR IN HERE SAY THAT IS
NOT YET TOTALLY SUBSTANTIATED
AND I AM VERY WORRIED THAT WE
CAN GET INTO A SITUATION WE'RE
GONNA SHUT OURSELVES DOWN LIKE
WE DID WITH TEEN SEES. WE HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO PROPERLY
REGULATE OR INTERACT WITH TEENS
HE'S A CITIES BECAUSE WE DO NOT
HAVE DATA ON WHAT THEIR EFFECTS
ARE. AND WHEN THAT DATA DOES
COME TO THE LIGHT. WE LEARN
THINGS LIKE 40% OF NEW TRAFFIC
IN SAN FRANCISCO IT'S FROM TNC
EASE. IT TOOK YEARS FOR THAT
DATA TO COME TO LIGHT AND WE AS
REGULATORS IN THE PUBLIC THAT
THE EXPRESSIONS OF PUBLIC
INTEREST HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE. TO
GET OUR HANDS ON THAT IN A
REGULARIZED WAY THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY I'M
SURE THEY'LL BE SOME QUESTIONS.
OUR NEXT WITNESS HERE IT IS-
JENNIFER DONLIN WHY IT. A WYANT
EXCUSE ME WHO IS THE
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING MANAGER
FOR THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO
WELCOME. AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS ARE JENNIFER DOMINO I
IT'S I WON'T REINTRODUCE MYSELF
BUT- I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
INVITING CITY SACRAMENTO AGAIN
WE ARE THE SCRAPPY MID SIZE
CITY- WHO APPRECIATES AT BEING
THE STATE CAPITOL AND HAVING
YOU HERE- LIKE LOS ANGELES WE
ARE ALSO ACCOUNTABLE TO OUR
RESIDENTS ARE EMPLOYERS OUR
EMPLOYEES AND OUR BUSINESSES.
AND MANAGING TRANSPORTATION IS
LIKE MANAGING UTILITY WE ARE
STEWARDS OF THE RIGHT OF WAY-
IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE GOOD DATA. AND DATA TO
MANAGE- HOW WE HOW WE OPERATE
IT'S- TIME TO GO OVER A COUPLE
OF THINGS ON THE DTA THAT WE
CURRENTLY CURRENTLY COLLECTED
HOW WE USE IT AND THEN THE
IMPORTANCE OF HOW WE HANDLE OUR
PRIVACY. I'M SO WE HAVE WE
COLLECT OUR DATA THROUGH MDS
MOBILITY DATA SPECIFICATIONS AS
WELL AS G. BFS GENERAL BIKES
ARE SPECIFICATION DATA- WE DO
THAT IN TWO WAYS TO MANAGER
SHARE MOBILITY SYSTEMS THAT WE
HAVE HERE IN THE CITY. BOTH HER
BIKE SHARE SCOOTER SHARE- MOST
LIKELY COMING FOR MOPEDS WILL
BE HERE SOON IN THE FUTURE
HOVER BOARDS OR WHATEVER COME
NEXT WE THINK IT'S A REALLY
GOOD FOUNDATION. FOR THE
COLLECTED DATA- WE DO NOT
COLLECT PERSONALLY IT ON ANY OF
OUR USERS SO WE DO NOT COLLECT
REAL TIME DATA AT THIS TIME. WE
COLLECT THE NUMBER OF TRIPS
WHICH IS AGGREGATED WE COLLECT
THE NUMBER OF ACTIVE VEHICLES
WHICH IS AGGREGATED. TOTAL
DISTANCE AGGREGATED AVERAGE
TOOK TIME AGGRAVATED- AND THEN
FOR A COUNCIL MEMBERS WHO ARE
VERY. KEEN ON FIRST AND LAST
MILE TRIPS WE COLLECT THE DATA
ON WHETHER OR NOT IT STARTS OR
ENDS AT TRANSIT. AND THEN
EQUITY IS A BIG PIECE OF OUR
CITY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE 20%
OF OUR DEVICES. TO ACT SO IT
WOULD BE THAT. WE ALSO LIKE TO
BROWN. AND I WAS DESCRIBED
EARLIER THIS IS TRUE BROUGHT
NAY. IS AGGREGATED WE USE
SHARED. WILL MET. WHICH IS A-
NONPROFIT. THAT AGGREGATES THE
DATA FOR US AND THEN OUR OWN
INTERNAL TEAMS HAVE BUILT OR
DATED ASH BOARD I AM INCREDIBLY
PROUD. OF ALREADY IT SEEMS OF
THE CITY SACRAMENTO AGAIN WE
ARE A SMALL SCRAPPY CITY. BUT
THEY DO A LOT WITH WHAT WE
HAVE. SO WE COLLECT TRIP ROUTE
DATA NOT. IDENTIFIED WITH
ANYBODY START POINTER AND POINT
BUT JUST WHERE THE HOT SPOTS
ARE. YOU MIGHT NOT BE SURPRISED
THAT A LOT OF ACTIVITIES AROUND
THE CAPITAL- THOUGH IT'S A GOOD
PLACE TO SKEW AND RIDE. WE ALSO
COLLECT INFORMATION ON REPORTED
ISSUE OR UP ON TRIPS PER BLOCKS
IS HOW IT'S COLLECTED SO YOU
SEE THIS EXAMPLE HERE FOR THOSE
YOU CAN'T SEE BACK THERE. ON
THIS ONE BLOCK SEGMENT WHICH IS
RIGHT HERE NEAR THE CAPITAL WE
HAD NEARLY FIFTEEN HUNDRED
TRIPS OF SURE MOBILITY THIS
TELLS US THAT THERE IS A NEED
FOR SPACE. I NEED FOR A BIKE
WAY OR WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE
MOVING FOR INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
INFORMATION. HI MY- NO IT'S
CLOSED ON ME. TO GO. OUT AND
THEN WE COLLECTED TRIP AND DATA
AS WELL AS TRIPS ARE DATA THEY
ARE NOT RELATED IN ANY WAY TO.
THE TRIP ROUTE DATA AND THE END
AND START ALSO ARE NOT
COLLECTED CONNECTED CONNECTED
WITH EACH OTHER- WE DO THIS FOR
A NUMBER OF REASONS WE NEED TO
KNOW WHERE TO PUT. PARKING AS
THE BIGGEST THING IS ISSUE WITH
SURE ABILITY IS NOT SO MUCH-
THAT CAUSING HAVOC ON CITY WE
ACTUALLY THINK THEY'RE A GREAT
THING THEY'RE GONNA HELP US
SOLVE A LOT OF ROOM ABILITY
CHILD. IS REGROW- SO WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE OUR PARKING IS
NEEDED SO MUCH SO THAT GETS A-
OF WHEN THIS ONE BLOCK SEGMENT
WE KNEW THAT WE HAD THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX PARKING
EVENTS. THERE IS A HIGH NEED
FOR PARKING ACTIVITY HERE THIS
INFORMS US. AND THEN WE USE OUR
OUR FEE STRUCTURE WHICH IS A
TEN CENTS PER TRIP. FEET TO
CREATE THAT PARKING. AB SO
THERE A COUPLE OF THINGS ONE-
THE EFFORT IS FOR US TO BETTER
RESPOND TO OUR RESIDENTS. WE
HAVE HAD ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED
CALLS IN THE LAST FOUR MONTHS
THROUGH OUR THREE ONE ONE
SYSTEM. FOR OF DEVICES THAT ARE
BLOCKING SIDEWALKS THAT WERE
IMPROPERLY PARK THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS- WE HAVE ISSUED
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED CITATIONS AND
WARNINGS IN THE LAST TWO MONTHS
TO OUR OPERATORS FOR. BLOCKED
PASSAGE TRAVEL WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO RESPOND TO THESE
ISSUES. BUT THIS AGAIN AS RAMS
IS POINTED OUT. THIS IS A NEW
WORLD THAT WE ARE WORKING AND
WE STILL DON'T REALLY KNOW.
WHAT THAT WORLD OPENS UP TO US
WE DON'T WANT TO BE HAMPERED IN
TOO MUCH BUT WE DEFINITELY HAVE
PUT FORWARD PROBABLY MOST
IMPORTANTLY. THEY NEED FOR
CONSUMER PRIVACY- IT'S AT THE
FOREFRONT OF WHAT WE DO SO WE-
AGGREGATE THE DATA. THE DATA IS
ON. HOLD THAT IS NOT PUBLIC SO
I. FROM MY I PAD HERE. CONNECT
TO THAT DATA IT'S NOT PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE ITS INTERNAL TO THE
CITY ONLY. A SELECT NUMBER
PEOPLE THE CITY HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT DATA- BUT THE DATE IS
GOING TO HELP US SUPPORT NEW
WAYS MOBILITY OF CITY
SACRAMENTO DOES NOT LIMIT THE
NUMBER OF OPERATORS WE DON'T
LIMIT THE NUMBER OF DEVICES.
AND AT NEW MOBILITY COMES BIRD
WE WELCOME IT WE WENT. RIGID
BECAUSE REALLY. WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TOWARDS A FUTURE WHERE
FEWER PEOPLE ARE DRIVING BY
THE- ELVES. AND FOLKS ARE
TRAVELING BY OTHER MEANS. I'M
SORRY LOOK FORWARD TO YOU CAME
WITH. YOUR CITIES I'M OF.
COURSE. THANK YOU. FOR THOSE US
WHO. HAS IT THE CAP. IN MY WE
COULD TOLL TO THEIR- VISA. HAS
RISEN ALL ON THE ROAD. ALL
RIGHT OUR NEXT SPEAKER IS DAVE
ALICE IN THE HE IS OF THE- VICE.
OF DATA FOR BIRD GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON.
SO IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE
TODAY AND THANK YOU AGAIN VERY
MUCH FOR INVITING US OUT TO THE
PANEL- SO AGAIN I'M DAVID ALSO
THEN THE SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT
OF DATA AND ALSO A PICKLE CITY
SOLUTIONS A BIRD WHICH IS HOW
WE INTERACT WITH CITY
GOVERNMENTS- BIRD REALLY IS THE
BUSINESS THAT FOUNDED THE
MODERN. MICROBIOLOGY SHARED
INDUSTRY AND BIRD IS PROUD TO
CALL THIS GREAT STATE HOME I'M
REALLY PLEASED TO SEE
CALIFORNIA BE BUT NAY ON KEY
POLICY AREAS SUCH LITTLE
PRIVACY AND DATA PRIVACY. AND I
BELIEVE THAT THE REASON THAT WE
ARE ALL HERE TODAY ULTIMATELY
IS BECAUSE OF OUR SHARED VISION
TO PROVIDE CLEAN SAFE
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS TO
RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THIS CHAIRED QUEEN
TRANSPORTATION OFFERING SUCH AS
BIRDS EAST CREATORS HAVE
ALREADY DONE A LOT OF GOOD IN
CALIFORNIA. THE THOUSANDS OF
JOBS THAT HELP MILLIONS OF
RESIDENTS GO TO SCHOOL AND TO
WORK. AND THEY PREVENTED A
MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF CO TWO FROM
ENTERING THE ATMOSPHERE. IN
FACT MORE THAN HALF OF ALL OF
BIRD RIGHTS KANSI TRIPS THAT
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED ON A CAR OR
A RIDE HAILING SERVICE SUCH AS
UBER LEFT. OUR BUSINESS THRIVES
WHEN CITY STILL. AND WE WORK
BEST IN COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
THE SAME SHARED VISION AS WE DO
OF STREETS THAT ARE FILLED WITH
PEDESTRIANS AND BY EX IN EAST
HOOTERS. INSTEAD OF CARS AND
SMOG. AND ULTIMATELY THAT'S WHY
WE'VE PLACED OUR CITY
PARTNERSHIPS AT THE CORE OF OUR
BUSINESS. AS ANY MARRIAGE WOULD
TELL YOU A STRONG PARTNERSHIP
REQUIRES OPEN COMMUNICATION TO
SUCCEED. AND IT'S WHY WE
BELIEVE IN BEING TRANSPARENT
WITH THEIR DATA. SO TO SHOW YOU
HOW SERIOUS WE ARE IN OUR
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING CITIES
IN PURSUING ARCHER POLICY GOALS
WE REALLY ULTIMATELY NEED TO
START FROM THE SAME FACTS AND
MEASURE THE EXACT SAME
OUTCOMES. AND TO BE CANDID THIS
DECISION IS NOT ONE THAT WE
MADE LIGHTLY OUR APPROACH TO
DATA REQUIRES- ENORMOUS
INVESTMENT AND RESOURCES. TO BE
ABLE TO GATHER HANDLE SECURING
PROTECTION DELIVER THAT DATA TO
A CITY PARTNER. WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY PROVIDING THEM
WITH THE TOOLS THAT THEY NEED
TO CROP REGULATIONS AND ENSURE
COMPLIANCE. AND IT'S A
COMMITMENT THE REQUIRES A LOT
OF DEDICATED RESOURCES PEOPLE
AND FINANCIAL. FAN EXPERIENCE
TO DELIVER. AT OUR CORE THOUGH
WE BELIEVE THAT EVERYONE COULD
SEE FOR THEMSELVES THE POSITIVE
SOCIETAL ECOLOGICAL IMPACT OR
MAKING EVERY SINGLE DAY IN OUR
CITY PARTNERS CENTER CITIES-
YOU KNOW THE BAY YOU WOULD SEE
AB EXACT SAME THING THAT WE DO
WHICH IS THE POTENTIAL TO
TRANSFORM CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR
THE BETTER. WE'VE SEEN THIS
PLAY OUT IN OUR HOMETOWN OF
SANTA MONICA WERE BIRD PROVIDES
THE CITY WITH THE DATA THAT IT
NEEDS TO BUILD OUT ITS MAKER
MODEL OF THE NETWORK. AND THIS
IS RESULTED ALREADY IN PARKING
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS AND
MANY OTHER IMPROVEMENTS. SANTA
MONICA HAS A GOAL OF SHIFTING
50% OF ITS URBAN TRIPS. TO
WALKING AND MICRO ABILITY SUCH
AS THESE SCOOTERS. AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE EDFU SAID TO THIS
PANEL SEVERAL MONTHS AGO WHEN
HE ADDRESSED IT- THE KEY
REASONS THAT PEOPLE DON'T USE
MY CREDIBILITY ARE REALLY RUN
INFRASTRUCTURE THE LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE. COST AND
AVAILABILITY. AND DATA SHARING
WITH US CITY PARTNER LIKE SANTA
MONICA. HELPS IS ACTUALLY
ACHIEVE THEIR GOAL OF MODE
SHIFT. SO THAT TO US IS
ULTIMATELY THE PROMISE OF THIS
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP. WE
KNOW THAT UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES NON AYE RELATED
DATA CAN POSE PRIVACY CONCERNS
AND WE THINK THOSE ARE
LEGITIMATE. WE TAKE THE PRIVACY
OF WRITER DATA VERY VERY
SERIOUSLY AND WE INVEST
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF TIME AND
MONEY. INTO DATA MANAGEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN TECHNICAL
SECURITY. WE RESTRICT WHO CAN
SEE WHAT DATA INTERNALLY AND WE
HAVE EXTENSIVE POLICIES ON HOW
WE SURE IT EXTERNALLY. THESE
PRIVACY CONCERNS ARE ONLY
EXACERBATED BY THE UNCLEAR
PATCHWORK OF LAW AROUND THE
COUNTRY THAT MANY OTHERS HAVE
ALREADY REFERRED TO TODAY.
WE'RE PROUD THAT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE IS ADDRESSING
THESE ISSUES AND IS LED THE
NATION PROTECTING THE PRIVACY
OF ITS CITIZENS. AND APPRECIATE
THE LEGISLATURE LOOKING TO
IMPROVE THAT CLARITY OVERTIME.
A BLUNT APPROACH WOULD BE TO
TREAT CITIES LIKE WE TREAT ANY
OTHER DATA PARTNER AND NOT
SHARE THIS REAL TIME NON I
AGREE TO DATE WITH THEM. CITIES
WOULD STILL GET SOME AGGREGATED
DATA FOR RESEARCH IN URBAN
PLANNING PURPOSES PLUS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO ENFORCE COMPLIANCE
WILL GREATLY REDUCING PRIVACY
RESTS. IT IS IN FACT HOW
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING DATA LAWS
APPLY TO MOST TECH COMPANIES.
BUT WE ARE A CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION COMPANY THAT
USES TECHNOLOGY TO DELIVER A
CRITICAL SERVICE FOR
COMMUNITIES MOBILITY. WE THINK
THE RIGHT PATH HERE IS A BIT
MORE NUANCE IT'S A MORE
TARGETED AND FLEXIBLE APPROACH
ONE THE CONSIDERS IMPORTANCE OF
LOCAL AUTONOMY AND LEAVES ROOM
FOR INNOVATION THAT WOULD ALLOW
CITIES AND TRANSPORTATION
COMPANIES LIKE US TO BUILD A
BETTER FUTURE FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA. WITH
THE POWER OF THE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP THAT ARE REFERRED
TO. AND SHOULD THE STATE WANT
TO TAKE A MORE MEASURED
APPROACH YOU CAN DO SO BY
SETTING UP PRINCIPLES IT WANTS
TO ACHIEVE. FOR EXAMPLE NO
PERSONS LOCATION HISTORY SHOULD
BE IDENTIFIABLE FROM ANYTHING
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE. RAW DATA
SHOULD BE TIGHTLY SECURED WITH
RESTRICTIONS ON WHO CAN ACCESS
IT. AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
SHOULDN'T HAVE ACCESS WITHOUT
APPROPRIATE LEGAL PROCESS.
ARMED WITH THOSE PRINCIPLES WE
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN WORK WITH
CITIES ACADEMICS AND THE STATE
TO DEVELOP A SET OF DATA
SHARING STANDARDS. THAT
ULTIMATELY CAN EVOLVE AS THE
SPACE OF BALLS AND APPLY
EQUALLY TO BOTH TRANSPORTATION
OPERATORS AND TO CITIES WE
THINK THAT'S A REALLY REALLY
CRITICAL COMPONENT. IF YOU WANT
TO LOOK OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA
THERE ARE OTHER EXAMPLES MANY
CITIES THAT COULD SERVE AS A
MODEL FOR THIS KIND OF DATA
SHARING BUT CHICAGO AND I'M
HAPPY TO SPEAK TO THAT DURING
QUESTIONING. WE'VE ALSO
PREPARED SOME HANDOUTS. BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS. RATHER
THAN DRAWING A BRIGHT LINE INTO
WHAT CITIES CAN AND CANNOT SEE
AND RECEIVE. WE SUPPORT
FOCUSING ON GOVERNANCE.
PRINCIPLES AND SECURITY THAT
WILL PROTECT RESIDENTS
BUSINESSES AND GOVERNMENTS
ALIKE. AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
DON'T SEE THIS AS AN
ADVERSARIAL PROCESS. WE BELIEVE
A PATH FORWARD. IS CLEAR AND IT
ALLOWS US TO BE TRANSPARENT
WITH OUR CITY PARTNERS AND
ACCOMPLISH OUR SHARED POLICY
GOALS. OF PROTECTING WRITER
PRIVACY. ALSO REDUCING CAR USED
TO TRAFFICKING CARBON
EMISSIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M FOR.
SURE THEY'LL BE A QUESTION OR
TWO- IN YOU MIGHT KEEP ONE IN
MIND WHICH IS. HOW WHAT
INFORMATION YOU DECIDE TO
COLLECT AND TO YOU ADVICE THE
USER OF YOUR- TRANSPORTATION
MECHANISMS. WITH THE RIGHT TO
OPT OUT. SO IF THE AND WE'LL
GET TO THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
OUR LAST SPEAKER LAST BUT
CERTAINLY NOT LEAST JAMIE LEE
WILLIAMS WHO IS A STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION I'VE-
WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE- YOUR
ORGANIZATION IN THE PAST AND
KNOW THAT YOU ARE. STRONG
PRIVACY ADVOCATES SO WE'LL LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING WHICH HAVE
TO SAY GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
AND GOOD AFTERNOON. AS YOU SAID
I AM JEANNIE WILLIAMS ON A
STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
WHICH IS A DIGITAL RIGHTS
NONPROFIT BASE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- HERE WITH ME TODAY
IS MY COLLEAGUE BENNETT CIPHERS
ONE OF OUR STAFF TECHNOLOGISTS
OF THERE'S- TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE DURING THE PANEL
WE HAVE BEEN HERE- SO WE ARE
HERE TODAY TO HIGHLIGHT THE
NEED FOR LEGISLATION THAT
LIMITS LOCAL AGENCIES TO.
AGGREGATE AND DE IDENTIFIED
TRIP DATA INTO PREVENT
GOVERNMENTS FROM UNNECESSARILY
STOCKPILING SENSITIVE LOCATION
DATA ABOUT RESIDENTS. AS YOU
HAVE HEARD TODAY EVEN WITH NAME
STRIPPED OUT DATA RELATING TO
INTERPRET INDIVIDUAL TRIPS ON
SHARED MOBILITY DEVICES IS
INCREDIBLY SENSITIVE DATA. IS
THE LOCATION DATA THAT PERTAINS
TO THE PERSON MOVEMENTS OF REAL
PEOPLE REAL TIME OR NOT EITHER
A VERY SENSITIVE. YET LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAYING AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE ARE CURRENTLY
DEMANDING THAT OPERATORS
PROVIDE ACCESS TO THIS
INFORMATION AS A CONDITION OF
GETTING A PERMIT TO OPERATE
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTIONS AND
THEY'RE HOPING. TO TRANSPORT
THIS WHOLE PLAN TO OTHER FORMS
OF TRANSPORTATION TO GET THE
SAME TYPES OF DATA FOR EVERY
EVERY TYPE OF TRANSPORTATION ON
THE STREETS- THE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES MAKING THESE
DEMANDS ARE NOT. BOUNCING
THEY'RE PLANNING GOALS WITH THE
PRIVACY INTERESTS OF THE
RESIDENTS AND THEY DO NOT EVEN
SEEM TO BELIEVE. THAT TRIP
DATA. IS PERSONAL INFORMATION
IN A LETTER OPPOSING A. B.
ELEVEN TWELVE CENTS LAST JUNE
FIVE CALIFORNIA CITIES ARGUED
THAT REMOVING CUSTOMER
IDENTIFIERS LIKE NAMES SHOULD
BE ENOUGH TO PROTECT WRITER
PRIVACY. BUT HUMAN MOBILITY
PATTERNS ARE HIGHLY UNIQUE AND
THAT MAKES ANONYMIZING LOCATION
DATA AND TORY SLEEP DIFFICULT
TECHNICAL TASK THE STUDY CHAU
REMOVING IS NOT ENOUGH TO
PROTECT PRIVACY. THE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES DEMANDING
INDIVIDUAL TRIP DATA ARE
FAILING TO COMPLY WITH EXISTING
PROTECTIONS IN THE LAW.
SPECIFICALLY THEIR FAILING TO
COMPLY WITH THE ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATIONS PRIVACY ACT AS
WE'VE HEARD. THEIR BILLING TO
COMPLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO PRIVACY
WHICH PREVENTS GOVERNMENTS FROM
COLLECTING AND STOCKPILING
UNNECESSARY INFORMATION ABOUT
US. AND FROM IS USING
INFORMATION THAT'S COLLECTED
FROM ONE PURPOSE AND USED FOR
ANOTHER PURPOSE HERE YOU OFTEN
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT USE CASES
THEY'RE COLLECTING THE STATE OF
FORCES NO WAY TO EVEN ENFORCE
THIS. THAT OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO PRIVACY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- AND THEY'RE FEELING
COMPLY WITH THE U. S. SUPREME
COURT'S HOLDING IN CARPENTER
REESE'S UNITED STATES WHICH
RECOGNIZE THAT LOCATION DATA IS
INCREDIBLY SENSITIVE PERSONAL
INFORMATION. PROTECTED BY THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT REASONABLE
EXPECTATION OF PRIVACY. CENTER
JACKSON YOU MENTIONED EARLIER
TODAY THE RECKLESS
DISSEMINATION OF INFORMATION
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
TODAY IS THE RECKLESS
STOCKPILING OF INFORMATION BY
GOVERNMENTS WHAT WE NEED. FROM
THE LEGISLATOR ARE CLEAR GUARD
RAILS THAT PLACE GRANULAR
ROCKCHIP DATA OFF LIMITS FOR
PLANNING PURPOSES. BY LIMITING
LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO AGGREGATE
ANTI IDENTIFY TRIP DATA NOT
JUST DATA WITH THE NAME
STRIPPED OUT. AND SUCH
GUARDRAILS ARE NECESSARY TO
PROTECT THE PRIVACY INTERESTS
OF CALIFORNIANS INTO SENT A
CLEAR SIGNAL TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT THEY ARE NOT
BEYOND THE LAW. AND I WANT TO
BE VERY CLEAR WE DO NOT THINK
THE STATE SHOULD BE CUT OFF
FROM ALL DATA WHATSOEVER NO ONE
HERE TODAY IS SAYING THAT. WE
AGREE THAT LOCAL AGENCIES
SHOULD BE ABLE TO COLLECT SOME
DATA IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
NEW TRANSPORTATION DEVICES ARE
DEPLOYED SAFELY. EFFICIENTLY
SUSTAINABLY AND EQUITABLY. BUT
LOCAL AGENCIES DO NOT NEED TO
COLLECT INDIVIDUAL FRAUGHT TRIP
DATA. ABOUT PEOPLE IN ORDER TO
DO SO THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
USE AGGREGATE AND DE IDENTIFIED
DATA. AND THIS IS PARTICULARLY
TRUE BECAUSE THE CITIES HAVE
NOT SHOWN THAT THEY ACTUALLY
NEED INDIVIDUAL TRIP LATER I
HAVE THE LUCKY POSITION OF
BEING THE LAST ONE TO SPEAK
TODAY WE HAVE NOT HEARD A
SINGLE. USE CASE THAT WOULD
NECESSITATE INDIVIDUAL FRAUD
DATA THERE'S BEEN A COUPLE OF
THINGS ARE MENTIONED. SUCH AS-
ENTERING THE VERACITY OF DATA
THERE ARE TECHNOLOGICAL
SOLUTIONS THAT SOLVE FOR THIS
WE ARE A MODERN STATE LET'S USE
A MODERN TECHNOLOGICAL
SOLUTIONS IS SOMETHING. THAT
THAT WOULD BE HAPPY TO TALK
MORE ABOUT. I HEARD ABOUT. PLAN
NEEDS IT PEACE BUT ALSO HEARD
THAT THE KEY THINGS THAT WERE
LOW FORWARD TO TALKING THAT.
PATTERNS WHERE PEOPLE ARE GOING
IT DOESN'T REALLY MATTER WHERE
I GO THE KEY IS WHERE MOST
PEOPLE ARE GOING AND THERE'S
WAYS TO MAKE SURE THAT CITIES
HAVE THE DATA THAT THEY NEED.
AN AGGREGATE WAY- THE OTHER
OTHER. USE CASES THAT WERE
MENTIONED WERE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT PEOPLE'S
PREFERENCES ARE BUT IT SEEMS
FROM. FROM THE TESTIMONY TODAY
THAT SURVEYS ARE GOING TO BE
THE MOST WAY THE BEST WAY TO
GET THAT YOU GET THAT
INFORMATION- AND THEN ALSO
ENFORCING SCOOTER CAPS MAKING
SURE THAT THERE'S NOT TOO MANY
SCOOTERS IN VENICE BEACH. THAT
YOU CAN GET WITH- INDIVIDUAL
LEVEL DATA THAT'S NOT
PERTAINING TO TRIPS BUT WE'RE
SCOOTERS ARE PARKING AND WE
HAVE NO PROBLEM. WITH CITIES
GETTING ACCESS TO INDIVIDUAL
DATA WHEN IT'S NOT A TRIP DATA
SO WHERE SCOOTERS ARE PARKED TO
ENFORCE PARKING LIMITS. CAPS
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION ANYTHING
LIKE THAT COMPLETELY FINE WITH
THAT. BUT WHEN CITIES START
THEM OUT AND I THINK IT'S
TELLING WITH SACRAMENTO IS
DOING WITH- WITH AGREEABLE DATA
THAT WAS GREAT TO HEAR I
WASN'T. SUPER AWARE OF WHAT'S
ACKERMAN TO WAS DOING BUT IT
BUT IT WAS. GREAT TO HEAR ALL
THE GREAT USE CASES THAT
THEY'RE DOING WITH AGGREGATE
DATA BUT WHEN CITY START
DEMANDED DEMANDING INDIVIDUAL
LEVEL TRIP DATA WE'RE NO LONGER
TALKING ABOUT SMART CITIES WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT SURVEILLANCE
CITY'S. TURNING OUR CITIES INTO
SURVEILLANCE CITIES IS NOT
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE THE
LAUDABLE PLANNING GOALS THAT
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES ACROSS
THE STATE ARE WORKING TOWARDS
WHAT WE NEED ARE SMART ENOUGH.
CITIES CITIES THAT HARNESS THE
POWER OF TECHNOLOGY AND DATA IN
A WAY THAT PROTECTS THE PRIVACY
INTERESTS OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
WE CAN HAVE A BEAUTIFUL CITIES
WITHOUT HAVING SURVEILLANCE
CITIES. AND WHAT WE NEED TO GET
THERE ARE CLEAR LIMITS FROM YOU
LEGISLATOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THAT CONCLUDES THE-
PANEL I JUST HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS AND- IF THERE ANY
OTHERS AND THEN WHAT WE'LL DO
IS- INVITE PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES EACH-
AND WE ALREADY HAVE OUR- PUBLIC
COMMENTERS. READY TO ROLL- BUT-
I JUST HAD A COUPLE QUESTIONS-
ACCEPTING THE PREMISE THAT WE-
CAN AND SHOULD BE USING DATA-
TO ASSIST US IT SEEMS THAT THE
QUESTION IS TO WHAT LIMIT WHAT
DATA DO WE NEED- TO ACCOMPLISH
THE GOAL THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE- AND I'D LIKE TO OPEN
THIS UP VERY BRIEFLY FOR IT HOW
DO WE GO ABOUT THAT ALLEN SINK
WHAT ARE THE RIGHT QUESTIONS
THAT WE SHOULD BE ASKING. AND
WHAT SHOULD WE AS POLICY MAKERS
WE PASS THE CPA- THERE I KNOW
GOING TO BE A BUNCH OF BILLS IS
HERE THAT ARE COMING FORWARD
THAT ARE. GOING TO TRY TO. DO
SOME TWEAKING OR SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES OR WHAT HAVE YOU- I
WOULD LIKE TO. GET JUST IF WE
WERE TO ASK A FEW QUESTIONS
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE TO
BALANCE THIS UNDERSTANDING
PERHAPS THAT DE AGGREGATING- IS
THE LAST RESORT. BECAUSE OF A
AND OF COURSE OF FEAR THAT EVEN
IF WE AGGREGATED SOMEONE CAN
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DE AGGREGATED
BUT- HOW DO WEACHIEVE THE
GOALS. ARE THAT WE'RE SEEKING
BOTH IN TERMS OF TRADE OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AND YET
PROTECTING PRIVACY. BECAUSE
PRIVACY IS THAT A FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA I KNOW
I TALK ABOUT THIS FREQUENTLY
IT'S WRITTEN RIGHT INTO OUR
CONSTITUTION. SO WE HAVE A DUTY
TO PROTECT THE FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT HOW DO WE DO THAT AND A
PERHAPS A MISTER ELSON WILL
START WITH YOU FROM A BIRD
BECAUSE CITED SORT OF GIVE YOU
A HEADS UP ON THAT. BEFORE YOU
DO THAT SO I WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR SO THERE'S NO. MISSION
STEVE DELAY FROM THE- OFFICE OF
THE LA CITY ATTORNEY SANTA
MONICA CITY ATTORNEY AN OFFICER
OF SAN JOSE THE CITY ATTORNEY-
DURING THE COURSE OF THIS
PROCEEDING SO I AM THIS COULD
COUNTY- WHEN I SUGGESTED YOU
MIGHT COMMENT ON IT I WAS NOT
AWARE THAT YOU HAVEN'T SEEN
THIS AND APPARENTLY WAS JUST
DELIVERED. TO THE- LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL TO MS BORDER FIND
DURING THIS HEARING- NOT A GOOD
PLAN- THIS IS NOT THE WAY WE
SHOULD BE DOING BUSINESS HERE
SO- MY APOLOGIES IF I SUGGESTED
TO YOU OR ANYONE THAT YOU
SHOULD HAVE BEEN PREPARED TO
ANSWER THIS- HOPE THAT WE WILL
HAVE THE- OPPORTUNITY AS WE
SHOULD. TO LOOK AT THIS
CAREFULLY. I WANT TO PRACTICE
LAW WHEN PEOPLE WOULD HAND.
DOCUMENTS TO THE COURT AT THE
VERY LAST MOMENT OR WHEN WE
STEPPED INTO THE COURTROOM- I
FOUND MYSELF REALLY QUITE
UNHAPPY WITH THAT PROCESS I
CONSIDERED TO BE SHARP
PRACTICE. I HOPE THAT THAT WAS
THE INTENT OF THESE THREE CITY
ATTORNEYS BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
SIT WELL WITH ME. SO WITH THAT
OF COULD YOU START MISTER OLSON
VERY BRIEFLY MAYBE A THIRTY
SECOND JUST TO HELP SORT OF
GIVE US SOME PARAMETERS. SURE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN FOR
YOUR QUESTION AND THANK YOU
TEARS FOR INCLUDING US IN THIS
PANEL- SO I THINK THE WAY THAT
I WOULD LOOK AT THIS PROBLEM
AND I WOULD BE CURIOUS ALSO
ABOUT- DOCTOR BISHOPS
RECOMMENDATIONS HERE BUT I
THINK ABOUT THE DIFFERENT
DIMENSIONS. THAT WE YOU KNOW
THAT WE LOOK AT THE DATA SO
THINGS LIKE THE RETENTION
PERIOD HOW LONG IS THE DATA
RETAINED BY THE GROUP THAT'S
CONSUMING IT A RECEIVING IT
RIGHT. I ALSO THINK ABOUT
THINGS LIKE ACCESS CONTROL SO
WHO HAS ACCESS AND WHAT ARE THE
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. THIS ALL
BOILS DOWN TO A THEME THAT
YOU'VE HEARD FROM MANY MANY
IDENTIFYING USE CASES. IF WE GO
BACK TO OTHER DIMENSIONS THE
MATTER GRANULARITY OF THE DATA
OR THE LEVEL OF AGGREGATION
THAT SUPPLY IS ALL WRITTEN ICAL.
I BISHOP. TO OKAY. SORRY SO
THINGS WELL. I'M ASIAN LEVELS
AS WELL AS OTHER TECH. THAT
HAVE. YOU KNOW REMARK ON BY A-
MEMBERS OF THIS PANEL. THE
OTHER PANEL. OUR EGGS. THE
TECHNIQUES ONE WOULD USE. TO
PROTECT. IN THESE CASES.
FRANKLY WE'VE PREPARED A NUMBER
OF HAND OUTS AND WE FINDS THAT.
TO DATE SIX PRINCIPLES AND THEN
THREE. PRACTICES AND- ALL ALL
REITERATE WHAT I SAID DURING MY
TESTIMONY- THIS DOESN'T NEED TO
BE ADVERSARIAL PROCESS I THINK
ACTUALLY EVERYONE HERE WOULD
APPRECIATE. YOU KNOW THE
APPROPRIATE LEGISLATION
ENACTED- THE KEY ISSUES REALLY
DO SURROUND THOSE. DIMENSIONS
AND PROP THERE ARE SOME OTHER
KEY TO ME. AS WELL SO IF YOU'D
MAKE SURE IF WE HAVEN'T.
RECEIVED ASSEMBLY GET THIS
THAT. ABSENT ANYONE ELSE WISH
TO COMMENT. BUT RESUMES YEAH
I'LL I MEAN I'LL JUST IT WHEN
IT TO DATA WHICH WE- HAVE A LAW
THAT PROTECTS THE STATE A IT'S
CAL ACT. AND I THINK WE COULD
HAVE ANOTHER WE AND WE ANOTHER
LAW LIMITING AS I SAID CITIES
TO AGGREGATE AND DE IDENTIFIED
DATA WOULD. SEND A CLEAR SIGNAL
TO THE CITY IS THAT THAT WAS
THE INTENT OF THE LEGISLATOR
AND THE STATE IS OFF LIMITS TO
YOU FOR THE- AND THERE'S A IF
YOU WANT IT THERE'S CERTAIN
PROCESSES THAT OUT AND COLLECT
BUT- YOU CAN GET. IS A SUBPOENA
PERCENT EXISTING LAW. AT. WHAT
THAT'S THE LAW THE PERTHE
STATE I WENT COMES. AGGREGATE
DATA I THINK A LAW THAT.
BROADLY LIMIT CITIES TO THE
MOST SENSITIVE DATA AND THEN
ALLOWS THEM WITHIN THAT TO WORK
WITH WHATEVER DAY THAT THEY
MIGHT WANT TO ASK FOR- I THINK
THAT WOULD BE A GOOD WAY OF
ALLOWING INNOVATION WILL ALSO
PROTECTING PRIVACY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. MR MINU. I
WORKING THERE WE GO YEAH OUR
FIRST STORY VERY MUCH FOR THE
LETTER COMING IN SO LATE- THAT
IS A SNAFU IN TERMS OF GETTING
SIGNATURES FROM VARIOUS
ATTORNEYS TOGETHER IT WAS
CERTAINLY NOT MEANT IN ANY WAY
WE DID NOT EXPECT YOU TO BE
ABLE TO RESPOND TO IT SO
QUICKLY. I CAN SPEAK TO THAT IN
A SECOND BUT- WE ALSO BELIEVE
THE ENUMERATED USES- DIRECTION
IS GOOD. I DON'T THINK IT THE
OTHER SIDE OF THAT WHICH IS
CLOSE DOWN ACCESS TO
DISAGGREGATED DATA IS GOOD ALSO
I THINK THAT THAT IT'S
PRECLUDING. THE ABILITY- TO
POTENTIALLY A FOR SOME VERY
GOOD POTENTIAL USES- WE DO NEED
A SEGREGATED. ALREADY IN TERMS
OF THAT REST STATE FOR DEVICES-
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO. VERIFY
THAT. NAM AND WE CAN'T DO IT
WITHOUT THAT- ALSO. LIKE WE
ALSO WANT ROUTE DATA
DISAGGREGATED TO BE ABLE TO
MEASURE- SERVICE LEVELS IN.
INCOME AREAS- WHERE WE HAD A
LOWER POINT WE ALSO. WANT
MEASURE WHERE WRITERS PREFER-
TO GO- SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE
WE'RE- WE'RE STANDING- UP WHERE
WE SHOULD. BE PAYING A NEW.
STRUCTURE NOW. THE ABOUT THAT
VARIOUS. BAG IN THE SECOND. IN
THAT. I DON'T THINK IT'S A VERY
CLEAN. I THINK THERE'S A. STRAY
IN AND STRONG WAS TO SAY WE
DON'T WANT THIS DISAGGREGATED A
OUT THERE. MY GUNS IN BUT IT'S
A VERY REASONABLE POSITION TO
TAKE BUT I THINK WHEN WE REALLY
LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH THIS DATA. TAKING AWAY
THAT ABILITY IS GOING TO HARM
THE PUBLIC GOOD WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND. WHAT
HAPPENED AS WELL AS AS THINGS
ARE COMING AS I WAS SAYING
EARLIER WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
START WORKING WITH THE
COMPANIES THEY'RE PROVIDING
SERVICE- AND THOSE SERVICES
WILL BE DONE IN DISAGGREGATED
FORM. AND WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
OPERATE WITHOUT. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER THOUGHTS. PART OF MISTER
MISS WARRANT THANK YOU CHAIR I
THINK THERE ARE. A THEIR DID
THERE'S A NEED FOR AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT DATA
NEEDS AGGREGATED VERSUS NOT
WHAT'S NOT FOR EXAMPLE IS RAMS
IS TALKED ABOUT. DEVICES THAT
ARE PART NOT MOVING NOW I PARTY
DEVICE BUT IT IS DEPLOYED OR IT
IS PARKED DOES NOT NEED TO BE
AGREED IT'S NOT RELATED TO A
PERSON. AND THAT'S HOW WE
COLLECT DATA ON REQUIRE.
PERCENT OF OUR DEVICES GO TO
OUR LOW INCOME AREAS OR THAT
THEY ARE DEPLOYED TO TRANSIT
LOCATIONS OR- ALMOST. FIVE
HUNDRED PRICES AND THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE A THOUSAND
DEVICES THT SORT OF PERMISSION
DOES NOT NEED TO BE ACCURATE IS
NOT RELATED TO A TRIP AND I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
US. AS STEWARDS OF THEIR WAY TO
IT THAT. WHEN A QUICKLY
CLARIFIED I'D SAY. AFTER DID I
AM AN AGGREGATE TRIPPED NOT ALL
DATA. AND I MEAN I THINK I
THINK ALSO I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT THESE
BECAUSE I THINK IT WOULD BE
POTENTIALLY USEFUL TO. TO FORCE
EVERY CALIFORNIAN TO WEAR.
ANKLE MONITOR TO MAKE SURE WE
COULD SEE WHERE THEY WENT AT
ALL TIMES. BUT THERE HAVE TO BE
LIMITS. DATA THAT WE GET ABOUT
WHERE PEOPLE ARE GOING- AND I
MEAN. IT'S NOT ONLY ME SAYING
THAT THE SUPREME COURT HAS
RECOGNIZED THAT LOCATION DATE
IS HIGHLY SENSITIVE DATA THIS.
RAISES SERIOUS CONSTITUTIONAL
QUESTIONS WHEN CITIES ARE
FORCING- OPERATORS TO TURN OVER
ACCESS TO THE STATE A ANSEL.
REASONABLE LIMITS THAT WOULD
ALLOW THEM TO PLAN FOR THE
BENEFIT OF ALL OF US WHILE ALSO
PROTECTING OUR PRIVACY SINCE.
SINCE ALL THIS IS SUPPOSED TO
BE THE BENEFIT OF CALIFORNIANS.
THAT'S THAT IS THE APPROPRIATE
BALANCING TEST AND THAT IS THE
ROLE OF THE LEGISLATURE THANK
YOU. I COULD DO YOU HAVE A
QUESTION I DO HAVE. MORE YEAH.
YOU HAVE ONE QUESTION AGAIN. IN
YOU DON'T HAS HAVE TO. CONSENT
KNOWLEDGE. SHOULD A WRITER OF
ONE OF THESE VEHICLES KNOW THAT
THEIR INFORMATION IS BEING
TRACKED OR- OBTAINED WHILE THEY
ARE. ON THESE VEHICLES AND
SHOULD THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
OPT OUT I MEAN IT DOES. I USED
TO BE A BIG FAN OF OPTING IN
BUT- AT LEAST MAYBE AT SOME
POINT PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO
KNOW WHAT'S THAT THAT WHEN THEY
TAKE THIS TRIP. THAT THERE THAT
IT'S BEING MONITORED AND
POTENTIALLY DE AGGREGATE I MEAN
THE PERSONALIZED SO THE PEOPLE
KNOW WHO WHO WHO IS WHO IT IS
IT'S TAKING THIS TRIP FOR WHERE
THEY'RE GOING FROM POINT A
WHICH MAY BE THEIR HOME. WITH A
CORNER OF THE STREET. TO THE
PLACE WHERE THEY WORK SHOULD
PEOPLE HAVE THE ABILITY TO KNOW
THAT DATE YOU ARE COLLECTING
INFORMATION AND THE RIGHT TO
OPT OUT. YES GREAT HOW ABOUT
YOU SIR. ALL ECHO THE SAME
POSITION- WE ACTUALLY PROVIDE
DISABILITY TODAY AND WE ALSO
PROVIDE THIS- THIS NOTIFICATION
AS WELL SO I THINK
FUNDAMENTALLY LOOK WE IT IS IN
OUR BEST INTEREST TO PROTECT
WRITER PRIVACY AND TO ENSURE
THAT ANY CUSTOMER OF OURS HAS
THEIR DATA EXTREMELY WELL
PROTECTED RIGHT AND IS EXACTLY
FOR THAT REASON THAT WE ALLOW
IN JURISDICTIONS WHERE YOU KNOW
IT'S HARD SUCH AS CALIFORNIA
AND TO BE. THE BILL FOR USER TO
OPT OUT OF DATA COLLECTION IN
THIS WAY THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THIS SENATOR BILL-
ENTER SO THE LEGALIZATION
SPARRING. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KIND OF. CLEAR
FIVE WHAT THE VARIOUS POSITIONS
OF VARIOUS GROUPS ARE- WE HAVE
OUR LAWYER HERE ARE LAWYER OF
YOUR PERCENT US AND OUR LAWYER-
MADE A CLEAR STATEMENT TO ME.
IN HER MEMO THAT WAS WRITTEN.
BACK IN. WITH THE FALL OF LAST
YEAR OKAY AND THEN. YEAH WE
RECEIVE THIS LETTER TODAY BUT
THERE'S BEEN OTHER LETTERS AS
WELL ABOUT THAT THE YOU KNOW
CONTRAVENING THE- LETTER THAT
WAS WRITTEN THE LEGAL COUNSEL'S
OPINION. SO I THINK IS YOU KNOW
LIKE YOU SAID I THINK WE NEED A
THEY COULD SPLURGE. FIND OUT.
WHAT THE RESPONSE WOULD BE YOU
KNOW. YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT
LETTERS BEEN SUBMITTED YOU KNOW
THAT'S SO. TOO BAD- THAT THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE DO IT BECAUSE-
THAT'S MY CITY AND- IS TOO BAD
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO BE MEETING
WITH THE MAYOR FRIDAY I'LL
BRING IT UP. HE'S ASKING ME FOR
A BUNCH OF MONEY SO YOU KNOW.
GOOD TIMING YOU KNOW. SO YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW YOU KNOW YOU KNOW
YOU GUYS ARE EVERY TIME I MEET
WITH THE MAYOR YOU ALWAYS WANT
SOMETHING RIGHT. YOU KNOW MAYOR
RIGHT THIS IS WHAT THEY DO NOW.
SO I AM INTERESTED IN. FROM
THIS PANEL OF. CONTROLLED
STUDIES OF FOR ACADEMIC
PURPOSES THIS ACADEMIC PURPOSE
ISSUE OF. IN TERMS OF GETTING
INFORMATION UNDER CONTROL-
HIGHLY CONTROLLED MANNER. OF
WHAT IS YOUR OPINION ABOUT. A
PROCESS THAT COULD BE
ESTABLISHED TO DO THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS. OF AND IS IT. AN
ACADEMIC STUDY ON US ON. FOR
VARIOUS REASONS THAT MIGHT BE
PERTINENT TO TRANSPORTATION THE
GOALS THAT WE HAVE- IN IN TERMS
OF SOME KIND OF FIRE WALLS ARE
CONTROLS WE CAN PUT ON. ON
THOSE KINDS OF STUDIES THAT
ORDER. GOING TO BE ATTEMPTED
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS FOR
VARIOUS REASONS. CAN YOU
COMMENT ON THE ISSUE. I'M I'M
SURE OTHERS HAVE INPUT AS WELL
BUT I'M I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE
BABY ONE VANTAGE POINT WHICH IS
WHAT WE TODAY AS A COMPANY DO-
SO WE ENGAGE WITH A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS
AND WE HAVE MANY RESEARCH
STUDIES THAT HAVE BEEN DONE FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE STATE ABILITY OF
OUR VEHICLES ARE MODE SHIFTER
HOW THEY YOU KNOW- ENABLE
EQUITABLE TRANSPORTATION AND
CITIES. ON AND FRANKLY- THE WAY
WE'VE APPROACHED IT RIGHT NOW
IS ACTUALLY QUITE RESTRICTIVE
WE ONLY SHARE HIGHLY I REDID
FORMS OF DATA- WE TYPICALLY
TRIM DOWN ONLY THE EXACT
RESEARCH QUESTIONS THAT ARE
NEEDED- AND YOU KNOW THE ONE I-
SALES THEM- LAST WEEK. HOW DO
WE GET MORE TRANSIT RIDERS THE.
NEW MOBILITY THAT WE HAVE IN
OUR SOCIETY HOW DO WE- RELATE
THAT TO GETTING- PEOPLE GET
OTHER CARS YOU KNOW WE GOTTA
WE'RE DO STARE POLLUTION. ONLY
WE HAVE SOME PRIMARY
IMPERATIVES HERE IN TERMS OF.
YOU KNOW THE CLIMATE CHANGE
ISSUE YOU KNOW THAT THAT THIS
COULD. HOW DO WE HOW DO WE DO
THE BEST JOB WE CAN TO
ACCOMMODATE THOSE KINDS OF
STUDIES. WITHOUT BREAKING THE
LAW OR WITHOUT INTERFERING WITH
PRIVACY AND SO FORTH YEAH I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
QUESTION YEAH ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE DONE IS A
COMPANIES WE'VE ALSO CREATED A
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
SERVICES GROUP. ON THAT ASSIST
WITH CITY PLANNERS AND WE DON'T
NECESSARILY FOR THE SPECIFIC
QUESTION THAT YOU ASKED AND
REALLY THAT DOT- AREA OF
QUESTIONING HOW DO YOU CONVERT-
OR HOW DO YOU ENCOURAGE USE OF
TRANSIT AND YOU KNOW HOW YOU
USE MICROBIOLOGY TWENTY. IS A
TRANSIT. IN GENERAL THE WAY
WE'VE REACHED. THIS IS NOT. BY
THIS. GROUP IS ON OUR GET
ORDERED IN. TODAY ON VINCE IT'S
LOW AT WE CALL SOURCE IN SIX.
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE DONE WITH MANY OF OUR
CITY PARTNERS AS WE LOOK AT THE
TRANSIT LINES AND THEN WE LOOK
AT WHERE OUR VEHICLES ARE
GOING. TO AND WHERE THERE TO
PULL. ON AND THEN WE CAN SHOW
FOR EXAMPLE THAT MICROVILLI
VEHICLES CAN ACTUALLY BE A
REALLY GOOD EXTENSION OF
EXISTING TRANSIT LINES AND CAN
ACTUALLY WIDEN. THE
APPLICABILITY OR UTILITY OF THE
FUNDS. BUT QUE IN POINT THAT
SPECIFIC. THAT YOU ASKED IS A
GREAT EXAMPLE HE- CREATED TO
UPDATE CAN'T BE PUT. THAT
SPECIFIC QUESTION WITHOUT
INCOME RIPPING ANY USER'S
PRIVACY OR YOU KNOW- REVEALING
ANY INDIVISIBLE PERSON. THAT
ARE ARE A- LANCE AND OTHER USE
CASE THAT HAVE BEEN YOU KNOW
DISC BY SOME OF OUR CITY
PARTNER TODAY BY OTHERS ON THIS
PAN THAT WOULD NOT FIT THE BILL
THEN THE- OKAY THAT'S THE
PLANNING. ISSUE THEN THERE'S TO
ME I ALWAYS ASK THE SCORES ALL
THIS. DISCRIMINATION. RACIAL
ETHNIC NEIGHBORHOOD. AGAINST
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO AFFIRM
EARLY PROTECT PEOPLE FROM THAT
KIND OF DISCRIMINATION. OKAY IN
OUR TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. AND
I A CONSISTENTLY A VAST UBER
LIFT. DAD A NOT DISCRIMINATE
EXCEPT WE FIND THAT THERE'S
LAWSUITS AGAINST THEM. THE DEAL
WITH THAT ISSUE THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE ADVOCATES FOR. PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THAT ARE CLAIMING
THAT THERE'S DISCRIMINATION.
HOW CAN WE HAVE. DATA SO THAT
THE- INSTITUTIONS OF GOVERNMENT
TO PROTECT PEOPLE FROM
DISCRIMINATION. AND THAT'S A
CONCERN OF MINE MAIENSCHEIN I'M
I'M ALWAYS GOING TO BE THE
GUY'S GONNA RAISE THE QUESTION
I REYES EVERY TIME WE HAVE A
HEARING ON THIS SUBJECT OKAY
EVERY TIME. I HAVE NOT FAILED
TO RAISE THE SUBJECT OF
DISCRIMINATION EVERY SINGLE
HEARING WITHOUT. THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS. AS CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE OF RAISE THIS
ISSUE. THE SO A LOT OF THE
REASONS WE NEED A CITY IS THE
DATA THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IS FOR PLUS AT PRECISELY THIS
REASON WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND
WHICH NEIGHBORHOODS ARE GETTING
SERVICES AND WHICH ONES ARE
WHICH ONES ARE ABLE TO USE THE
SERVICES AND A AND- CLEAN AND-
I HAVE. UNIMPEDED ACCESS RIGHT
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHERE OUR
PROVISION OF INFRASTRUCTURE IS
OR ISN'T. ADEQUATE TO GIVE
THESE SERVICES OUT- AND THAT'S
THE IRRESPECTIVE OF ALL THE
OTHER STUFF FOR TIME OUT
AGGREGATION ON AGGREGATION-
IT'S THE ABILITY TO. TO ASK
THESE QUESTIONS WRITE THIS
ABILITY TO SAY. NOW THE FOLKS
WHO ARE- AND WE TRY TO KEEP
THIS MERELY SPACE ONLY USE
CENSUS DATA TO LINE UP WHERE
FOLKS ARE- BUT UNDERSTANDING.
THE GEOGRAPHIES OF INEQUITY AND
THEN BEING ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
HOW SERVICES ARE WORKING
THROUGH THESE DIFFERENT
GEOGRAPHIES. THE PRIMARY
QUESTION AND A LOT OF CITIES
WORKING IN THE SPACE ARE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW. TO BALANCE
THIS REALLY HARD QUESTION.
RIGHT AS HOW DO WE GET THE
STATE IN THE RIGHT WAY. AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE. VERY
BRIEFLY IF WE'RE GONNA. TRY TO
GET WRAPPED UP SHORTLY THE VERY
VERY QUICK TIMES SIMILARLY WE
USE THAT DATA TO HELP TO ENSURE
PERMIT COMPLIANCE WHETHER IT BE
TWENTY PERCENT. NEEDS TO GO TO
OUR DISADVANTAGE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OR THEY'RE NOT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY DOING
EDUCATION PROMISE- WITHIN
AROUND ACCESSIBILITY ALSO ONE
BE REALLY CLEAR HOW THE CITY
SACRAMENTO ADDRESSES BLOCK
SIDEWALKS. AS OF DECEMBER WE
EMPOWER PARKING ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS ISSUE CITATIONS IN
THAT THE SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
SINCE DECEMBER ONE THAT WE'VE
ISSUED FOR. FOR EIGHTY EIGHT
ISSUES WE TAKE I VERY
SERIOUSLY WE TAKE IN A
DIFFERENT DATA FASHION. BY
EMPOWERING OUR PARKING
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ISSUE
FIFTEEN DOLLARS CITATIONS FOR
EVERY BOX SIDEWALK OR CURB RAMP
IN THE CITY- IT'S BEEN A- I
CAN'T IT GOES TO THE COMPANIES-
BUT- TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS MISSION TO THE
COMPANY'S WHETHER OR NOT THEY
CHOOSE TO. PASS THOSE COSTS ON
TO THE USERS UP TO THEM WE'RE
HOPING THEY DO BECAUSE THAT'S
HOW YOU GET BETTER BEHAVIOR.
WHEN I'M DOING IT FOR THE MONEY
WE'RE DOING IT FOR BETTER
BEHAVIOR. THANK THANK YOU. I
THINK ON THE QUICK AT THIS.
THIS IS WHITE SO. LOOK AT THIS
THE- WHAT THE DATE IS BEING
USED FOR HIS YOU DON'T ACTUALLY
NEED TRIP DATA. TO SEE WHERE
THE CITIES WHERE THE SCOOTERS
ARE PARKED- AND WHERE THEY'RE
BEING DEPLOYED YOU CAN LOOK AT.
TRIP OR YOU CAN LOOK AT THE
INDIVIDUAL SCOOTERS THEMSELVES
BUT THAT DOESN'T IMPLICATE.
PRIVACY IN THE SAME WAY. OKAY
WELL OBVIOUSLY WE- OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S FURTHER DISCUSSION TO
BE HAD I THINK THAT WE ALL
AGREE. THAT WE NEED TO NARAL.
THE INFORMATION. TO MAKE SURE
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
CONNECTS WITH WHAT THE-
LEGITIMATE PURPOSES ARE FOR
WHICH IS BEING SOUGHT. AND THEN
WE GOT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
PROTECT IT- AND THESE ARE ALL
DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE. STILL
OVER PROBABLY IN THEIR NASCENT
STAGES SO. I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE. I ALSO WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT RESEARCH WE
DON'T WANT TO. REMOVE THE
ABILITY OF THE GREAT RESEARCH
WE DO HERE AT THE UNIT AT. THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
THROUGHOUT OUR- RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS. THERE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN A LOCK BOX ON THAT
INFORMATION IT DOESN'T IT YOU
KNOW SO WE HAVE A HISTORY AND A
TRADITION. OF PROTECTING THAT
INFORMATION. THIS IS THE
POTENTIAL APPLES AND ORANGES
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE-
SO. I WANT TO THANK THE GOOD
DOCTOR DOES THE RESEARCH AND
ALL OF THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
DOING. RESEARCH HAS BEEN VERY
HELPFUL TO THE STATE. THIS IS
MORNING ECONOMIC ISSUE AS WELL
AS A- PLANNING ISSUE- AND-
OTHER DIFFERENT LEVELS AND WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO DO MORE ON
THIS AND SO. I THINK THIS IS A
GREAT START AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE. THAT
WILL GO TO THANK YOU AND GO TO.
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD TWO
MINUTES SO ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO
SEE. GOOD AFTERNOON I WISH YOU
HAD A FULL BOARD OUT THERE
BECAUSE I DON'T TO ALL OF YOU
SENATORS I WILL SAY BE WHERE OF
THE UNINTENTIONAL CONSEQUENCES
WOULD YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME
FIRST JST FOR THE RIGHT
PROBABLY DID JEFF HARDY KIA. AN
ADVOCATE AND TO THE VARIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS PART OF THE
BACKGROUND YOU DON'T KNOW IS I
WORK WITH DUN AND BRADSTREET SO
WE KNOW EXACTLY THE INFORMATION
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. AND HOW
WILL IT CAN PROLIFERATE. ALSO
LOSE TWENTY YEARS AGO INVOLVED
WITH THE IF WE SEE. A SNIPER IN
THE THREE PRIVACY AND THOSE
ISSUES WITH THE IEEE BUT FOR
TODAY. PRIVACY ISSUES YOU NEED
TO YOU'RE COLLECTING THE DATA
YOU NEED TO HAVE THE CONTROL OF
THE DATA WHAT I DIDN'T HEAR YOU
GUYS REALLY POSE THE QUESTIONS
TO THESE PEOPLE IS REALLY WHAT
ARE THE FIVE PIECES OF DATA.
THAT REALLY NEED TO BE
COLLECTED TO PROVIDE THE
ANSWERS FOR MOST OFTHE
QUESTIONS. THAT WILL BE HELPFUL
THE OTHER TWO THING- TO YOUR
SENATORS IS THROUGH THE
HOMELESS PROJECT YOU'VE DONE A
HUGE BUNCH OF RESEARCH ABOUT
PROTECTING THE P. R. E. N. FOR
DEALING WITH THE COLLECTION OF
INFORMATION AND HOW YOU MAKE IT
SO THAT FOR OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR ANY OTHER
ORGANIZATION. IN THAT SETTING
UP THE STERN FROM YOUR BOTH
YOUR- TAX AARON YOU'RE A SHOULD
WE SEE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
SELECT A STRONG STANDARD BUT
YOU LOOK AT THAT WOULD BE
EXTREMELY HELPFUL FOR THIS
PURPOSE. THANK YOU. COMMENTS
OKAY I GUESS IS MY TWO MEN.
THANK YOU. BY NEXT. NEXT THE
PUBLIC COMMENT GOOD AFTERNOON
ANDREAS ARMY DOES ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF OAKLAND
DELIMITATIONS THAT KEEP CITIES
FROM PROPERLY REGULATING TNC IS
THE RESULT IN POOR PLANNING
LEADING TO AN INABILITY TO ME
SOME STATE REQUIREMENTS AS WELL
AS COMPROMISING TRANSIT SAFETY
WITH GOODERS. GLENN CAN
IMPLEMENT ROBUST PROGRAMS TO
MEET LOCAL GOALS SUCH AS
TRANSIT SAFETY AND EFFICIENT
ROUTES CREATE PINPOINTED
PARKING AND DROP OFF LOCATIONS
AND REDUCE DISCRIMINATION HOUSE
WAS RECENTLY MENTIONED. WITHOUT
TRACKING INDIVIDUALS OR THEIR
TRAVEL PATTERNS WE FEEL THE
STATE CAN AND SHOULD SET SOME
STANDARDS BIRDS THE LEGISLATURE
TO SUPPORT LEGISLATION THAT
ALLOWS MUNICIPALITIES TO HAVE A
GREATER ACCESS TO TARGETED
PORTIONS OF TNC DATA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS MY NAME IS JUDY MASAKO
AND I'M FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
MUNICIPAL TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
I'M HERE TODAY MAINLY TO
AMPLIFY A LOT OF MY OTHER CITY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY TALKED
ABOUT ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
OUR NEED TO A RETAINER ACCESS
TO CERTAIN ABILITY DATA- IN
ORDER TO CARRY OUT OUR PERMIT
PROGRAMS AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVELY. AS FROM TEH WE HAVE A
ROBUST CERTAIN ABILITY PROGRAMS
STOCKS DOUGLAS. BIKES AS WELL
AS SCOOTERS AND WE USE THIS
DATA TO ENFORCE COMPLIANCE WITH
OUR GOALS SURROUNDING EQUITY IN
ACCESSIBILITY. PRIMARILY WHERE
ARE DEVICES ARE LOCATED MAKING
SURE THEIR AND OUR LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS THEIR
GEOGRAPHICALLY DISTRIBUTED. AND
MAKE SURE THAT THE COMPANIES
ARE AT HEARING TO THE CAPS FOR
THE ALLOWANCE OF NUMBER
DEVICES. AND SINCE PRIVACY IS
THE FOCUS OF TODAY'S HEARING ON
THE FOCUS I'M A LITTLE BIT ALSO
JUST TO. LET YOU KNOW THAT WE
PRESERVE ANONYMITY BY DESIGN
AND HOW WE RETAIN OUR DATA. AND
WE ALSO PLAY ALL OF OUR
INDUSTRY BEST PRACTICES FOR HOW
WE MAINTAIN OTHER. PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION FOR
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WE NEED
THAT FOR WHAT AN ASSET AND THIS
IS CURRENTLY TO NOT HAVE AN-
TO. DATA WE RECENTLY PRESENTED
I THE CPC THROUGH THE RULE
MAKING PROCESS A COMPREHENSIVE
TNC DATA COLLECTION PROPOSAL.
THAT LAYS OUT WHAT INFORMATION
PUBLIC ENTITIES NEED. AND
EXACTLY HOW WE WOULD USE THAT
WHAT WE ALSO DO IN THIS
PROPOSAL IS. PROVIDE A LINE BY
LINE REBUTTAL. OF HOW A
PROPOSED- SO WE PROVIDE AN
OUTLINE OF WHAT DATA WE WOULD
LIKE AND THEN PROVIDE A
LANDLINE REBUTTAL OF- WHAT
OTHER PARTIES HAVE SAID HOW
THIS DATA COULD BE USED. SO WE
WANT TO REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
READ THAT HAPPY TO SHARE IT-
WITH YOUR OFFICES OF THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL. WOULD APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON IN THE
COMMISSION WITH A CALIFORNIA
BICYCLE COALITION. FOR OUR
PURPOSES AND THE FRUITFUL
DISCUSSION TODAY IT'S IMPORTANT.
TO SEE THE NEED FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ASPECT AS OF
LOOKING AT THE INFORMATION THAT
IS PROVIDED BY EITHER THE
COMPANIES OR THE CITIES. THE
OTHER THING TOO AS A COMPONENT
IS THAT THIS ISN'T THIS ISN'T
NEW MOBILITY SURE MOBILITY HAS
BEEN AROUND A CITIES HAVE HAD
BIKE SHARE AT THIS IS JUST BEEN
A PROLIFERATION OF THAT AN
EXTENSION OF THAT WE SEE MORE
IMPORTANT FOR PROVIDING THAT
MOBILITY OPTION. ONE THING THAT
WE DON'T I MEAN THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF SESSION ABOUT A
DISCLAIMERS AND OPTING IN
OPTING OUT. TO MY KNOWLEDGE
THERE ISN'T AN OPPORTUNITY TO
USE THE DEVICE YOU'RE GONNA OPT
OUT OF THE INFORMATION YOU'RE
SHARING SO THAT'S HE HOOKED IT
BECAUSE THAT'S THE CASE. THEIR
PERMISSION SHARED I THAN WHAT
IS THEIR MOBILITY OPTION WELL
THAT'S WHERE WE SEE WE HAVE TO
HAVE THE DISCUSSION AROUND. AT
HOW CITIES FIT INTO PROVIDING
OR HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
THAT TYPE MOBILITY- AS FAR AS
WHAT IS PROVIDED BY THE CURRENT
OPERATORS- YOU KNOW IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR CITIES TO HAVE
INFORMATION NOT JUST FOR. THE
TO BE ABLE TO REACT MORE REAL
TIME THEN TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING ALLOWS FOR IT COME
FROM PLANNING BACKGROUND NO.
THE DURATION THE EXTENT AND HOW
EXPENSIVE IT IS TO BE.
INFRASTRUCTURE INTO THE GRASS-
BUT WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND MUCH QUICKER THAN THAT
TO INFORMATION IS KEEP FOR
CITIES TO BE ABLE TO. HAVE THAT
REAL TIME I'D IN IN THE EXTENT
THAT IT HELPS TO CREATE A
QUICKER TURNAROUND. A RESEARCH
AND- I. WOULD TO UPSET A LOT OF
IS A PUBLIC ENTITIES ARE
PROVIDE THE ARE TIME A RIGHT
HERE SERVICE WORDS SOCCER T.
HAS SMART RIGHT NOW SO ARE APT
BASS ON A MOBILE OPTION AND SO
BRING IN THAT AS WELL WHEN
WE'RE TALKING TO AND PRICE THAT.
THEY'RE ALL PROVIDING SOURCING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON THE SYLVIA SOLUTION
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA WE WERE THE FIRST CITY
IN CALIFORNIA TO SEE ELECTRIC
SCOOTERS ON OUR STREETS WE HAVE
A ROBUST SHARED MOBILITY
PROGRAM IN THE CITY- BUT IT IT
OUT IT IS ALSO OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURECLEAR
AXE TO THE PUBLIC RIGHT OF WAY
IS FOR USERS OF SCOOTER THAN BY
EXTRA. PEDESTRIANS AND PULLED.
TO AND WILL DO NEED ACCESS TO
DATA WE ARE OPEN TO CONTINUING
OUR DISCUSSION- REGARDING
PRIVACY GUARD RAILS BUT WITH
THAT THE DATA IS GOING TO BE
VERY KEY IN ALLOWING US TO.
MOVE FORWARD WITH OUR
REGULATORY EFFORTS AND ENSURING
THAT THE PUBLIC RIGHT OF WAYS
INDEED PUBLIX OF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. I THINK WE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. THERE ISTHAT
RESPONSIBILITY THERE IS
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO MORE WITH
THE CURRENT TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS. IT IS THE ISSUE IS A
BALANCING HERE SO. YOUR COMMENT
YES YES SIR. HI MY NAME'S
MORGAN HER LOCKER I MEANT
SUFFERING JUNIOR CHAIRED
STREETS A NONPROFIT WORKING TO
ENABLE DATA TO BE SHARED
BETWEEN PRIVATE ENTITIES AND
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES- I BECAME
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS ISSUE LAST
YEAR WHEN I BEGAN TO SEE CITY
RELATED DATA POLICIES REGARDING
AND YES PROCESSING THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR RE IDENTIFICATION.
USERS TO AIMS THE DAY THE I.
FIVE. SOME OF THE MADE PUBLIC.
I BEGAN INVESTIGATING THESE
PUBLIC MOBILITY TWO FEEDS
FOLLOWING THESE PRACTICES AND
CONFIRM THAT SEVERAL DID NOT
PROPERLY ANONYMIZE TRIPS.
INCLUDING ONE THAT ALLOWED ME
TO IDENTIFY TRIPS BETWEEN HIGH
SCHOOL AND YOUR BY PLANNED
PARENTHOOD. THE PREPARATION IS
RIGHT IN THE SCHOOL AND RIGHT
NEXT TO THE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
I SINCE BEEN ABLE TO FIND
HUNDREDS MORE OF THESE. ON THE
LEVEL OF TIME PRECISION WAS
PLUS OR MINUS SEVEN MINUTES ON
THIS TRIP SO IF YOU HAD
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ABOUT A
STUDENT AT SCHOOL YOU WOULD BE
ABLE TO FULLY IDENTIFY THEM.
OTHER RESEARCHERS HAVE USES
DATA TO STOCK CELEBRITY.
IDENTIFY VULNERABLE RELIGIOUS
POPULATIONS. AND EVEN TRACK
PROTESTERS AT LAST YEAR'S WOMEN
MARCH AS FOR WOMEN'S MARCH AS
REPORTED BY THE NEW YORK TIMES
JUST THIS MONTH. OVER THE LAST
YEAR I FOUND NUMEROUS A DAY
PHONE ABILITIES NEW SYSTEMS
ALONG THE TRACK NEARLY ONE
BILLION TRIPS GENERATED BY
MILLIONS OF RIDERS GLOBALLY AND
REYES. PINE FROM HOME COMPUTER.
LAST WEEK TELL. AUDITOR FAN
SIMILAR WITH SIMILAR DATE
GENERATED BY A- P. R. SYSTEMS
WAS WIDELY SHARED INADVERTENTLY
WITH THOUSANDS OF FEDERAL
AGENCIES AND PRIVATE ENTITIES
INCLUDING ICE. CBP AND POUNDS
HERE. TO THE INCOMPLETE.
SECURITY POLICIES AN
INSUFFICIENT TRACKING OF DATA
SHARING AGREEMENTS. AT SHARED
STREETS WE BELIEVE WITH WE
PARTNER WITH SACRAMENTO TO
pYOU COULD DO THIS DATA- YOU
COULD TREAT THIS DATA IT SAFELY
AND ACCOMPLISH POLICY GOALS. WE
BELIEVE THAT CITIES CAN AND
SHOULD DEVELOP DATA COLLECTION
INFRASTRUCTURE. IT'S CRITICAL
THIS WORK MUST BE DONE THOUGH
IN A WAY THAT'S PAIRED WITH
MEASURE IT TECHNICAL AND POLICY
INFRASTRUCTURE ANSWERS IN TO IN
AS PROPERLY AB. AND NOT BE USED
IN A WAY THEY CAN COMPROMISE
SAYS PRIVACY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LAST TO ANY
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT THE LAST
SPEAKER. GOOD AFTERNOON HI MY
NAME IS DAVID AS A VETO MISSES
HIS STATE DIRECTOR WITH A RP
CALIFORNIA. ON BEHALF OF OUR
NEARLY THREE POINT THREE
MILLION A. R. P. MEMBERS IN THE
STATE. WE ARE CLOSELY
MONITORING THIS LEGISLATION DID
WAS IMPLICATIONS OF THE SAFETY
OF OUR OLDER ADULT MEMBERS
THEIR FAMILIES WHILE THEY ENJOY
THE STREETS HOWEVER THEY
CHOOSE- AS ONE OF THE NATION'S
OLDEST CONSUMER ORGANIZATIONS
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE IN.
BOTH POP AND SEASONPRIVATE
COMPANIES TO PROTECT CONSUMER
PRIVACY. THIS CLIP HERE TRADING
OF. HEARINGS THE- AND FUTURE
WHERE DATA IS KING AND CO IS
THE NEW. WHOEVER CONTROLS THAT
CODE IN CONTROL THE DATA
CONTROLS THE PUBLIC GOOD. THE
PUBLIC GOOD IN QUESTION HERE IS
THE STREET IN THE TAPE THE OF
ITS USERS. WHAT KING BY.
SINGERS BEING IS NOT TO BE
REBELS GREAT IT'S NOT TO BE.
AGAINST SOME EIGHT THE BILL
WOULD BE AT THIS. OR ZIP CODE
IN WITH THE POINTS TO MIND.
EIGHT A RP ONE TO SEE LET. THAT
HAS A CLEAR LINE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY BETWEEN THOSE
WHO MAINTAIN THE PUBLIC GOOD
WHICH ARE CITIES AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES. AND THOSE WHO OFFERS
SERVICE OR PRODUCTS TO NAVIGATE
THAT PUBLIC GOOD WHICH ARE
PRIVATE COMPANIES. THE CLOUD
YOUR THAT LINE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY IS THE HARDER IT
WILL BE TO HAVE SAFE STREETS
THAT WORK FOR EVERYBODY. OKAY
CLOUDINESS HERE NOT FROM FIVE
COMPANIES PUBLIC AGENCIES. BUT
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OURS THAT
REPRESENT CONSUMERS THAT ARE
NOT JUST SCOOTER USERS BUT
OTHER USERS OF THAT PUBLIC
GOOD. UP WHICH SCOOTERS ARE
AFFECTING AND NOT JUST CRITTERS
AS WE KNOW. THIS IS A PRECURSOR
IN A LOT OF WAYS- TO WHAT. I'M
ABOUT AUTOMATED VEHICLES. AND
INNOVATION FOR THE STREET SO
ARE WE KNOW THAT THIS IS THAT
THE COMMENTS LIKE THESE MAKE
YOUR JOB HARDER AS LAWMAKERS
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE. YOU
HEARING FROM US AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE BEING
ENGAGE WITH YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE LOVE THIS KIND OF
STUFF THAT WE CHEN FRAZIER
STAFF. THE WHY WE WHITE HAIR.
OF BUT THE ISSUE OF THE ERROR
WELL THIS WEALTHY MAKE OUT YOU
HAVE IT HERE AT ANY RATE SO-
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE DIS-
THE SENATOR DOLLY DO YOU HAVE
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS SENATOR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
THIS I THINK WE SHARE. THIS IS
A NON IDEOLOGICAL. ISSUE THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT. MAKING SURE
THAT WE CAN MAXIMIZE WHAT
TECHNOLOGY DOES AND DOES WELL
BUT PROTECTING PRIVACY WHICH IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
MAINTAIN- OUR DEMOCRATIC
SOCIETY WE DON'T WANT BIG
BROTHER HERE SNOOPING. NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR IT'S NOT THAT. LONG
AGO AND SOMEHOW IT SEEMS RATHER
PRESSING INTO AND THAT WAS
WRITTEN IN ONE IS SORT OF
DYSTOPIAN VIEW SO- A LEAD TO
ALERT THE GOOD TO SENATOR FROM
SAN JOSE HAVE THE OLD PASSWORD
BUT WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR.
BEING HERE AND THANK THOSE A
FEW WERE STILL HE IN THE
PARTICIPANTS IN THE PANELS
TODAY I THINK. THIS IS NOT THE
END OF THE DISCUSSION BUT THE
BEGINNING AND WANT TO THANK OUR
STAFF TO FOR. PUTTING TOGETHER
THIS VERY- IN IMPORTANT HEARING.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY I JUST WANT
TO- ALSO- MAKE EVERYBODY- STAND
THIS IS A VERY INTENSIVE
DISCUSSION WE HAD OVER TWO
HEARINGS. AND MANY MANY HOURS
ON THE SUBJECT WE- WE WANT TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE-
SENATE GOVERNMENT FINANCE
COMMITTEE AND OF COURSE OUR
JUDICIARY. COMMITTEE WITH OUR
TRANSPORTATION ME TODAY. AND
WE'VE REALLY HAVE LEARNED A LOT
OF BY HAVING THESE HEARINGS I
WANTED TO THANK ESPECIALLY THE
STAFF OF ALL THOSE COMMITTEES
ESPECIALLY. TODAY ARE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND ARE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION READY STAFF FOR
THE FINE JOB THEY DID IMPROVE.
FOR THIS HEARING WITH HER BACK
REPORTS AND ALL THE IN. THEY
READ THEY GOT. TO US SO AND
ALSO THE STAFF TO FACILITATE
THE MEETING THE SERGEANTS AND
EVERYBODY ELSE SO- THANK YOU
EVERYBODY FOR ALL THE FINE WORK
YOU DID. THE LEAD. HAVE
HEARINGS ON IT AND- THIS POINT
ONE MAJOR. THEY WERE GERMAN.